SUBCOMMITTEE ONE IS CALLED
REPORTER MAN LET ME JUST DO
SOME HOUSEKEEPING THINGS AT
FIRST. BECAUSE IN RESPONSE TO
THE COVERED NINETEEN EMERGENCY
TO PROTECT THE PUBLIC WE LIMIT
NONESSENTIAL GATHERINGS IN
COMPLIANCE WITH THOSE ORDERS
THE SENATE IS MADE NECESSARY
ADJUSTMENTS TO NORMAL PRACTICES
WERE HOLDING OUR COMMITTEE
HEARINGS HERE IN THE CAPITAL.
WITH ALL MEMBERS PARTICIPATING
IN PERSON AND ALL MEMBERS ARE
PRESENT RIGHT NOW. THOSE
PROVIDING TESTIMONY BEFORE THE
COMMITTEE TODAY ARE
PARTICIPATING REMOTELY AND JUST
REMIND THE REMOTE PARTICIPANTS
ARE PLEASE MUTE YOUR PHONES. OR
COMPUTERS SO THAT- THERE'S NOT
FEEDBACK WELL YOUR- A
TESTIFYING IF YOU IF YOU WANT
TO TALK REYES USED TO RAISE
YOUR HAND FEATURE. R. I. T. PUT%
YOU ON MUTE WHEN IT'S DONE TO
ALLOW THE PUBLIC ACCESS BOARD
MEETING MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC
SOCIALLY DISTANCE AND WITH MASS
TO TWO HEARING ROOMS- THIS IS
ONE AND ROOM TWENTY FORTY TODAY
IS THE OTHER- FOR ALL
INDIVIDUALS WISHING TO PROVIDE
PUBLIC COMMENT- THE TOLL FREE
NUMBER AND ACCESS CODE IS
POSTED ON OUR COMMITTEE WEBSITE
IT WILL BE DISPLAYED ON THE
SCREEN AND I WILL ANNOUNCE IT
NOW. TODAY'S PARTICIPANT
NUMBERS. 844-291-6364.
844-291-6364 AND THE ACCESS
CODE. IS. 654-289-7654. TWO
EIGHT NINE SEVEN. AND- ARE YOUR
INTO TO ME I'M GOING TO MAKE
MAINTAINED WHEN THEY HEAR IS
NOW- AND I'M ALSO GOING TO WIN
THE TAP WHEN WE GET TO A TWO
ONE WILL GO TO THE C. ITEM AND
THEN DO TESTIMONY AT THE END-
CHECK ANY OF THIS ITEM. THIS IS
THE FIFTH OUT OF THE HEARINGS
OF OUR REGULAR SUB COMMITTEE
PROCESS TO HEAR THE GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET PROPOSALS AND OTHER
RELATED PROPOSALS WITHIN THE
JURISDICTION OF SUB COMMITTEE
ONE THESE HEARINGS ARE LARGELY
INFORMATIONAL WILL BE TAKING
THE ACTUAL ACTION WHEN WE GET
INTO APRIL OR MAY IN TODAY'S
HEARING WILL REVIEW THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSALS REGARDING
THE CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY
COLLEGES THAT'LL BE THE ENTIRE
SUBJECT IS BROKEN DOWN INTO SIX
ITEMS. COVERING APPORTIONMENT
STUDENT SUPPORTS ONLINE
EDUCATION AND SEVERAL. OTHER
PROPOSALS- WITH THAT- ARE THERE
ANY COMMENTS FOR THE SENATE. I
THANK YOU CHAIR LATER WITNESSES-
THE LARGEST ONE TO AND TO THAT
IT EVEN KOBE ARKHAM COLLEGE WAS
FACING A LOT OF CHALLENGE I
NEED THINK THAT THIS BUDGET
PROPOSAL THAT WE DISCUSSING
TODAY LAYS OUT SOME IMPORT
FIRST STEP THAT I CAN WE NEED
TO. ON EC ON A FORTY. ON
PENTAGON AND AN REALLY THE KEY
THEY CAN COLLEGE SYSTEM- YOU TO
EVERYBODY FOR APPEARING TODAY
AND LOOK FORWARD TO HEARING
YOUR TESTIMONY. THANK YOU AND I
THINK PEDAGOGY IS A WORD WOULD
BE. BY THE WAS PRETTY OF.
BEFORE SERVING ON THIS
COMMITTEE. SO WILL MOVE
DIRECTLY INTO PANELS ONE. AND
LET ME JUST SAY THAT THIS IS
PROBABLY THE ONE THAT ONE OF
THE MOST QUESTIONS ON SO JUST
WHEN WE'RE DONE. WE WILL DO
THAT AND WE'RE GOING TO HEAR
FROM DAN. HANDWORK FROM THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE PAUL
STEEN HOUSING FROM THE
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S OFFICE
AND WITH THAT NAVARETTE. FROM
THE COMMUNITY COLLEGE
CHANCELLOR'S OFFICE. WILL TAKE
THEM IN THAT ORDER AND WILL
BEGIN WITH THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE WELCOME. TO THE BUDGET
SUB COMMITTEE. GOOD MORNING
SURE NUMBERS- DANTAN ARE WITH
THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE.
CHAPTER THIS FIRST ITEM I WILL
BE AN OVERVIEW OF THE
PROPOSAL'S AND THE GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET RELATED TO APARTMENT
FUNDING FOR THE- COMMUNITY
COLLEGES. LOOKING AT THE BIG
PICTURE AT THE GOVERNOR'S BY
PROPOSAL CAN CAUSE FOUR BILL.
IN LOCAL ASSISTANCE ON FOR TWO
COLLEGES AND THE DOCTOR. THE
NEW ESTIMATES AND WORK FACT THE
BY CRUNCH TOLD COMP REVENUE FOR
THE STATE CENTERED FUNDING
FORMULA AND SEVEN POINT. SIX
SEVEN DOLLAR. OR TWENTY TWENTY
ONE TWENTY JAIL. THIS IS UP TO
THE PROJECT OF SEVEN POINT
THREE BILLION. FOR TWENTY
TWENTY TWENTY ONE AT THE TWENTY
TWENTY BUDGET ACT. INCLUDING
THE TO ARE EIGHT TWENTY ONE
TWENTY TWO COSTA LIVING AND- OR
COLA- ONE FIVE PER OR A HUNDRED
ELEVEN POINT ONE MILLION
DOLLARS. AND TWENTY FOUR POINT
5% GROWTH OR THREE POINT ONE
DOLLARS. IN ORDER ONE THAT THE
CALIFORNIA CAN COLLEGES
CONTINUE TO MEET THE NEEDS OF
THEIR STUDENTS. THE GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET REQUIRES SEVERAL
CONDITIONS FOR COMMUNITY
COLLEGES- DISTRICTS ARE
RECEIVING P. TWENTY TWENTY ONE
TWENTY TWO KOLEJKA. FIRST EACH
COMMUNITY COLLEGE DISTRICTS.
REPORT DETAILING SPECIFIC.
ACTIONABLE PLANS ON HOW THEY
PLAN TO CLOSE ACHIEVEMENT GAPS
BY TWENTY TWENTY SEVEN IN
FURTHERANCE BUT THE GOLD
OUTLINED IN ADDITION FOR
SUCCESS. SECOND COMMUNITY
COLLEGE DISTRICT SHOT POLICIES
TO MAINTAIN ONLINE COURSE AND
PROGRAMS AT A LEVEL THAT A TEN
PERCENTAGE POINTS HIGHER THAN
EIGHTEEN NINETEEN LEVELS. I
WILL LEVERAGE ON THE ONLINE
COURSE PROPOSED. DURING ITEM OF
YEAR. I WOULD ALSO NOTE THAT
SIMILAR EXPECT FOR THE UC AND
CSU OR AT THE GOVERNMENT BUDGET
AS WELL. THE TERM. AND YOU KNOW
THE TO TWENTY BY ACT DEFERRED
ONE POINT FOUR FIVE THREE TWO.
IN TWO TWENTY TO ONE PORTION
MEANT. AND GIVEN EXPECTED IN
POPULOUS NINETY EIGHT. THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET TO REDUCE
TIME TWENTY ONE TWENTY TWO
DEFERRALS. TO THREE HUNDRED AND
TWENTY SIX POINT FIVE BILLION
PROPOSITION NINETY EIGHT
GENERAL FUND APPORTIONMENT.
ADDITIONALLY THIS BUDGET
PROPOSES REPAY TWENTY TWO
TWENTY TO FOR ALL OF ONE POINT
FOUR FOUR FIVE THREE BILLION.
USING SOURCES FROM MULTIPLE
FISCAL YEARS INCLUDING A
HUNDRED AND FORTY FOUR POINT
SIX MILLION PEOPLE SCHOOL YEAR
TWENTY NINETEEN TWENTY. NINE
HUNDRED POINT EIGHT MILLION
FROM PHYSICAL YOUR TWENTY
TWENTY TWENTY ONE. AND FOUR
HUNDRED AND SEVEN POINT NINE
MILLION PER FISCAL YEAR TWENTY
TWENTY ONE TWENTY TWO. BY
CONTINUING TO IMPLEMENT A
DEFERRAL. ALBEIT AT A
SIGNIFICANTLY LOWER LEVEL THE
ADMINISTRATION IS ABLE TO
INCLUDE ADDITIONAL PROPOSALS
DESIGNED DIRECT TO DIRECTLY
ADDRESS THE NEEDS OF CALIFORNIA
COMMUNITY COLLEGE STUDENTS. AND
HELP THEM THROUGH THIS
DIFFICULT TIME. AS WELL AS TRY
TO COUNTER THE ENROLLMENT.
REPORTER FOR FALL TWENTY TWENTY
TERM. AND WITH THAT ABOUT IT
ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS YOU HAVE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH NOW WILL
MOVE TO THE LEGISLATIVE ANALYST.
THEN AND WILL DO QUESTIONS
AFTER ALL PANELISTS OF SMOKE.
GOOD MORNING ALL STATE HOUSE
AND WITH THE ANALYST'S OFFICE.
SO YESTERDAY OUR OFFICE
RECEIVED- RELEASE AND ANALYSIS
OF THE GOVERNOR'S COMMUNITY
COLLEGE PROPOSAL'S TITLE THE
TWO THOUSAND TWENTY ONE TWENTY
TWO BUDGET CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY
COLLEGES. WE WORKED WITH STAFF
TO INCORPORATE MUCH OF THAT
REPORT INTO YOUR AGENDA. CHIU
WITH REGARD TO THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSE ONE POINT 5% COST OF
LIVING ADJUSTMENT ON
APPORTIONMENT. WE NOTE IN OUR
REPORT THAT DISTRICTS ARE
FACING A NUMBER OF COST
PRESSURES. IN THE BUDGET YEAR I
HEALTH CARE PREMIUM INCREASES.
TENSION INCREASES ALL THOSE
THOSE REALLY RAMP UP STARTING
IN TWENTY TWO TWENTY THREE
VARIOUS OTHER OUR BASE
OPERATING COST INCREASES AND
PRESSURE TO INCREASE EMPLOYEE
SALARIES ESPECIALLY AFTER NOT
RECEIVING A CALL UP. IN THE
CURRENT YEAR. SO THE CALL RATE
WHICH IS BASED ON A PRICE INDEX
OF OUR STATE AND LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS WILL BE UPDATED IN
APRIL WHEN THE STATE RECEIVES
ADDITIONAL ECONOMIC DATA BY
EARLY MAY THE LEGISLATURE ALSO
HAVE BETTER INFORMATION ON
STATE REVENUES. WHICH IN TURN
WILL AFFECT THE AMOUNT
AVAILABLE TO SPEND ON K.
FOURTEEN EDUCATION THROUGH
PROPOSITION NINETY EIGHT. IF
ADDITIONAL ONGOING PROPOSITION
NINETY EIGHT FUNDS ARE
AVAILABLE IN MAY THE
LEGISLATURE MAY WANT TO
CONSIDER PROVIDED ME PROVIDING
AN EVEN GREATER INCREASED TO
APPORTIONMENT. AND WHAT THE
GOVERNOR IS CURRENTLY
PROPOSING. THE LEGISLATURE
COULD ALSO CONSIDER REPURPOSE
SEEN LOWER PRIORITY PROPOSALS
AND THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET TO
SUPPORT A LARGER BASE
AUGMENTATIONTO APPORTIONMENT.
AND THROUGHOUT THIS HEARING I
WILL IDENTIFY SOME PROPOSALS
THAT MIGHT BE GOOD CANDIDATES
FOR SUCH A REDIRECTION. WITH
REGARD TO THE PROPOSAL FOR
DISTRICTS TO DEVELOP EQUITY
PLANS AS A CONDITION OF
RECEIVING A COST OF LIVING
ADJUSTMENT IN THE BUDGET YEAR
WE WOULD NOTE THAT SUCH A
REQUIREMENT IS ALREADY- IN
STATUTE. ACTUALLY THE DISTRICTS
ARE REQUIRED TO. DEVELOP AND
MAINTAIN STUDENT EQUITY PLANS
AS A CONDITION OF RECEIVING
STUDENT EQUITY AND ACHIEVEMENT
MONEY SO WE THINK. THAT IN THIS
CONDITION AS PROPOSED BY THE
GOVERNOR WOULD REALLY BE
REDUNDANT WE RECOMMEND THE
LEGISLATURE REJECT THIS
PROPOSAL. ON THE PROPOSED RULE
PAYDOWNS WE THANK THE GOVERNOR
IS REALLY ON THE RIGHT TRACK.
BY PAYING DOWN SO MUCH OF THE
DEFERRALS ARE BUT COULD GO EVEN
FURTHER AND PAY OFF EVEN MORE
OF THEM. I'M USING ONE TIME
FUNDS TO RETIRE MORE THE%
DEFERRALS. HAS A LOT OF
ADVANTAGES- REDUCE SEEN
DISTRICTS- NEED FOR BORROWING
FOR CASH FLOW PURPOSES. IT ALSO
GIVES THE LEGISLATURE MORE
BUDGET TOOLS TO RESPOND TO
FUTURE ECONOMIC DOWNTURNS. SO
THROUGHOUT OUR REPORT AND IN
THIS HEARING- WE DO IDENTIFY
SOME LOWER PRIORITY PROPOSALS
AND THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET THEY
COULD BE USED INSTEAD TO PAY
DOWN MORE REFERRALS OR HELP
DISTRICTS. IN OTHER WAYS SUCH
AS BY MITIGATING FUTURE.
PENSION COST INCREASES. SEVEN
OTHER TOPIC IN ISSUE ONE CAN-
IN ROME IN A ROW GROWTH. THE
PANDEMIC IN THE RECESSION HAVE
REDUCE SIGNIFICANTLY-
ENROLLMENT DEMAND OF THIS YEAR.
IN THE NEXT SEVERAL MONTHS WILL
HAVE A MUCH CLEARER IDEA ON
ROMAN WHERE ENROLLMENT MIGHT GO
INTO ONE TWENTY TWO YEAH
THERE'S A LOT OF REASONS WHY
ENROLLMENT DEMAND IS DOWN THE
STUDENTS NOT WANTING TO TAKE
ONLINE ONLY COURSES. CERTAIN
COURSES ARE NOT OFFER BECAUSE
THEY DON'T CONVERT WELL TO AN
ONLINE ENVIRONMENT STUDENTS- A
LOT OF TIMES SPECIALLY ROLLER
HAVE LIVED TAX. TO ONLINE
CLASSES- IT MIGHT NOT HAVE A
QUIET PLACE TO TAKE THEIR
CLASSES ARE TO STUDY OUR HAVE
CHILD RESPONSIBILITIES AND
THEIR THEIR KIDS OR OTHER
OTHERS ARE HAVING TO TAKE CARE
OF OUR ARE. AT HOME RATHER THAN
IN THEIR K. TWELVE SCHOOLS.
ANOTHER BIG REASON IS OUR
INDIVIDUALS AND FLOSSER JOBS
ARE LOOKING FOR JOBS- THEIR
FAMILY INCOME HAS DECLINED AND
SO THEY NEED TO WORK RIGHT NOW
RATHER THAN I TAKE TIME TO GO
TO SCHOOL. SO DISTRICTS ARE
HOPEFUL ALL RIGHT NOW THAT THEY
CAN OFFER A LOT MORE IN PERSON
COURSES IN THE FALL BUT FOR NOW
THEY ARE TAKING A GENERALLY
TAKING A WAIT AND SEE APPROACH
YOU KNOW LOOKING AT OTHER
VACCINES VACCINE DEPLOYMENT
LOOKING AT THE OVERALL PROGRESS
TOWARD. HERD IMMUNITY SOME OF
COLLEGES AND SCHOOLS REOPEN IN-THE FALL AND THE ECONOMY. IS
STILL SLOW TO RECOVER. THIS
COULD SEE A SIR. IN IN. ON
OTHER HAND IF CALL AND ARE.
REMAIN PRIMARILY ON. AND FALL
WE SEE CURRENT. TRENDS. ALSO
LATER THIS MONTH THE CHANCE OFF
WILL RELEASE UPDATED- AND ROMAN
A DATA ON THE CURRENT YEAR. SO
WE'LL HAVE THAT DATA SOON AND
BY SPRING WILL LIKELY HAVE A
CLEAR PICTURE OF WHERE THE
STATE AND COLLEGES AND SCHOOLS
ARE ARE HEADED IN TERMS OF-
ENROLLMENT. STARTS A PLANS FOR
THE FALL AND SO THE LEGISLATURE
WILL HAVE AN OPPORTUNITY- IN
THE COMING MONTHS USE THAT DATA
TO MAKE A CALL ON A ROMAN
FUNDING AT THAT TIME. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH AND THEN
THE CHANCELLOR'S OFFICE. THIS
MORNING SENATOR LAYERED AND
MEMBERS OF THE SENATE BUDGET
SUB COMMITTEE ON EDUCATION MANY
MISSILES THAT NUMBER AT AND I
SERVICES BY STUDENTS FOR
COLLEGE FINANCE OF THE
CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY COLLEGES.
AS WE APPROACH THE ONE YEAR
ANNIVERSARY OF THE COPA
NINETEEN PANDEMIC THIS IS THE
DISRUPTION ITS CAUSES ARE ALL
TOO FAMILIAR OUR STATE OUR
STUDENTS OUR SYSTEM HAVE BEEN
SUBSTANTIALLY CHANGED AND THE
RESULTS IN THE AFFECTS CONTINUE
TO CHALLENGER CALIFORNIA
COMMUNITY COLLEGES. HOWEVER WE
BELIEVE THE RING ROAD TO
RECOVERY WILL PRESENT
OPPORTUNITIES TO ADAPT AND TO
VIEW COMMUNITY COLLEGES I START
AS A STRATEGIC INVESTMENT IN A
MORE EQUITABLE. AND RESILIENT
CALIFORNIA. WE ME. FOR A BI
PROPOSAL THAT LAYS A STRONG
FOUNDATION FOR THE POST PANDA
RECOVER. DURING THIS CRISIS
PROVIDING FISCAL STABILITY HAS
BEEN A TOP PRIORITY TO THAT END
DATE CANCERS OFFICE HAS USED A
MULTI FACETED APPROACH TO
PROVIDE FISCAL STABILITY DURING
THIS UNCERTAIN PERIOD. THIS
APPROACH INCLUDED ONE THE
APPLICATION OF TITLE FIVE
EMERGENCY CONDITION ALLOWANCES
TO DISTRICT WHOSE ENROLLMENT
WAS IMPACTED BY THE COVER
NINETEEN PANDEMIC. AND TO
EQUITY ADJUSTMENT TO THE
DEFERRAL CALCULATION WHICH
ENSURED EACH DISTRICT RECEIVED
AT LEAST 83% OF THEIR REVENUE
FROM ALL SOURCES AND PREVENTED
DISTRICTS AND LOCAL PROPERTY
WEALTH COMMUNITIES COMMUNITIES.
FROM BEARING THE BURDEN OF
DEFERRALS AS THEY TRADITIONALLY
DO. THESE ACTIONS HAVE ENABLED
SOME FISCAL STABILITY. DURING
THIS COMPLEX PERIOD. HOWEVER
THE PANDEMIC CONTINUES AND THE
RETURN TO NORMAL APPEARS MORE
DISTANT IT IS CLEAR TO EVALUATE
AND PLAN FOR THE LONG TERM
FISCAL RESILIENCY OTHER SYSTEM.
THAT INCLUDES PERFORMING
FINANCIAL AID FOR STUDENTS WE
TELL ADDRESS AN ITEM TO.
PROVIDING ONGOING RESOURCES
CHORE DISTRICTS AS THEY PREPARE
FOR INCREASED COSTS IN
RECURRING EXPENSES ASSOCIATED
WITH A SAFE CAMPUS RE OPENING.
PAYING DEFERRALS AND CONTINUING
THE IMPLEMENTATION OF STUDENT
CENTERED FUNDING FORMULA WHICH
PRESENTS OPPORTUNITIES TO MORE
DELIBERATELY FOCUSED ON
ENROLLING ANSWERING MORE LOW
INCOME CALIFORNIANS AND
SUPPORTING THEIR SUCCESSFUL
JOURNEY. IN THE MIDST OF A
PANDEMIC OUR COLLEGES HAVE
EXPERIENCED THE SOCIAL
RECKONING OCCURRING ACROSS THE
COUNTRY CHALLENGING US TO
DISMANTLE STRUCTURES AND
PRACTICES THAT PERPETUATE
SYSTEMIC RACISM. SINCE TWENTY
SEVENTEEN THE VISION FOR
SUCCESS HAS SERVED AS THE
CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY COLLEGES
NORTH STAR TO CLOSING EQUITY
GAPS THE GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL
PRESENTS AN OPPORTUNITY TO
ALIGN SEVERAL KEY PLANS THAT
ARE PRODUCED BY OUR COLLEGES.
INCLUDING STUDENT EQUITY IN
ACHIEVING PLANS AND LOCAL
VISION GOALS THESE EFFORTS ARE
NOT NEW TO OUR COLLEGES RATHER
THEY WILL BE APPROACHED MORE
COHESIVELY. WE SUPPORT THE
PROPOSING AND ONGOING FUNDS
INCLUDING A COLA AND GROSS.
UNDER THE SCF GROWTH CAN SEE
MORE THAN THE TWO NOTION OF
INCREASED ENROLLMENTS BUT
RATHER GROSS CAN. EFFORTS BY
COLLEGES THAT I'VE SEEN
INCREASES IN THE LOW INCOME
STUDENTS THEY SERVE AND IN
THEIR SUCCESS. WHERE POSSIBLE
WE ENCOURAGE MORE ON GOING
SUPPORT FOR THE LONG TERM
OPERATIONAL NEEDS OF OUR
COLLEGES. LASTLY WE URGE THAT
SHOULD NEW RESOURCES BE MADE
AVAILABLE AT ME REVISED.
PRIORITY BE PLACED ON PAYING
DOWN DEFERRALS THAT DISTRICTS
ARE NOT THREATENED BY FUTURE
UNCERTAINTIES OF THESE DEBTS
OWED TO THEM. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH AND I'M HAPPY TO ANSWER
QUESTIONS ON THIS ITEM. THNK
YOU VERY MUCH. AND NOW WE WILL
MOVE TO QUESTIONS ON ITEM
NUMBER ONE INDECISIVE AT THE
OUTSET OF THE HEARING THIS'LL
PROBABLY BE THE PLACE. WHERE
THE MOST QUESTIONS BECAUSE THIS
IS WHERE THERE IS A COMPLETE
OVERVIEW. OF THE BUDGET LET ME
BEGIN BY ASKING FINANCE- ALL
THREE OF THE WITNESSES
MENTIONED- JUST THE STATUS OF
PAYING OFF DEFERRALS. GIVEN THE
FACT THAT LOCAL DISTRICTS HAVE
TO PAY INTEREST ON THE
DEFERRALS. INTO GIVEN THE FACT
THAT IF FOR AN ECONOMIC
DOWNTURN. GOES INTO THE NEXT
YEAR THIS MIGHT BE A TOOL WE
WANT IN THE TOOL BOX. WHY WAS
THE CHOICE MADE NOT TO PAY OFF
DEFERRALS IN THIS PROPOSED
BUDGET. DAN OUR DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE- SO DIMINISH ASIAN
UNDERSTAND BUT OUR COMMUNITY
COLLEGES AND OUR STUDENTS
ESPECIALLY OUR ARE STILL IN
NEED OF IMMEDIATE RESOURCES-
HELP THEM WEATHER THE STORM OF
CO THE NINETEEN- AND BY GETTING
A SMALL BUBBLE FOR ALL OF I DID
RESEARCH ARE FREE TO. IN OUR
AREAS OF THE COMMUNITY COLLEGE
BUDGET HELP PROVIDE. MEDIA
FUNDS GENERALLY TO STUDENTS.
AND IF YOU DON'T PAY OFF THE
DEFERRAL AND ECONOMIC CAN AT
THE ARE ONE TIME HELPS TO SEE.
WERE TO SET LEAVE US NEXT YEAR
AND ABOUT. I THINK THAT THE
SOMETHING THAT WE HAVE TO TAKE
WHEN WE WHEN WE TO THAT POINT
AGAIN- THIS BUDGET REALLY TO
BALANCE THE AVAILABLE GOING ON
ONCE EVERY. OF BASED ON OUR OUR-
ARE AND HELPING TRYING HELP
STUDENTS TO THAT THE CURRENT
STORM A CO IN NINETEEN. ARE L.
A. O. T. A ANY OF COMMENT ON
THIS. OF THE DEFERRALS AND DID
MADE I KNOW YOU MAY IN YOUR-
COMMENTS BRIDGES IF YOU HAD ANY
OF THE CON. YEAH THINGS STAFF-
FIRST OF ALL. THIS BY GETTING
PAID LESS DISTRICTS ARE EITHER
HAVING A EXTERNALLY WHERE THEY
MIGHT PAY INTEREST AS YOU MAY.
WHAT IS HAVE RESERVES THEY'RE
HAVING TO TAP INTO TO MEET-
WHEN MONEY FOR THE STATE COMES
AND CASE OR- I. ON THEIR ARE
THERE ARE- THERE THEY'RE NOT
GETTING THE ARE. ON THERE AND
SO THAT'S MY THAT THAT IT
INSTEAD BEING A VET HAVE TO GO
OUT PAYROLL TOLD TO STAY. IS
ABLE TO PAY. ANOTHER THING- TO
KNOW IS. OUR VIEW IS IF THE
STATE. YOU WANT TO. YOU WANNA
PAY AUTOCRATIC. AS SOON AS CAN.
OF THE DAY. AND NOT AT ALL NOW
WHEN STATE HAS. ONE TIME MONEY
AND QUITE A BIT OF ONE TIME
MONEY. IS THAT IT JUST SORT OF
A- AND JUST DOESN'T GET PAID
AND- IN WHEN YOU AS YOU MAY IF
YOU A DOWN. SAY ANY THE YEAR TO
HAVE DOWNTURN. EVEN NOW YOU
DON'T HAVE THAT OFF ON THE TWO
TO FOR. THREE TWENTY MILLION.
FROM MAY TO JULY OR JUNE TO
JULY AND THAT FACT OF- LOW
HANGING FRUIT AS IT AS A BUDGET
SOLUTION IS ALREADY BEEN USED
BECAUSE BECAUSE YOU DIDN'T
ADDRESS IT WHEN YOU COULD HAVE.
AND SO IT'S JUST KIND OF
KEEPING THAT IN MIND. THE
IMPACT ON THE DISTRICTS AND
HAVING TO BORROW INTERNALLY OR
EXTERNALLY AND THEN NOT HAVING
THAT AS A BUDGET SOLUTION IN
THE OUT YEARS. WHEN YOU REALLY
MIGHT NEED IT. THANK YOU FOR
YOUR COMMENTS AND OTHER
COMMITTEE. OF RIGHT TIME SPEAK
FOR THEMSELVES BUT- I REALLY
SUBSCRIBE TO THE NOTION THAT WE
SHOULD PRIORITIZE PAYING OFF
THE DEFERRALS AND- AS YOU. GO
TOWARD THE MAY REVISE IF THERE
IS EXTRA MONEY. OR YOU DECIDE
YOU WANT TO REASSIGN PRIORITIES
THAT WOULD BE AN IMPORTANT
THING TO DO. THEN LET ME NEXT
ASK ABOUT ENROLLMENT GROWTH.
AND THE L. A. O. JUST SAID
THAT- AS TO ARE COMING- BUT WAS
WONDERING AND MAYBE ALL ASK
THE- A. O. FOR AND GO FINANCE.
OR THE- CHEN OFFICE DOES AND-
HAVE ANY ESTIMATE OF WHAT THE
ENROLLMENT LOSS HAS BEEN. SINCE
THE BEGINNING OF THE PANDEMIC
TO NOW. IT SAYS THE C. L. A-
NOW YEAH. HISTORY YEAH WE'VE-
WE DON'T HAVE FINAL DATA AT
LEAST WHEN WE LOOKED AT. AS OF
ABOUT TWO WEEKS AGO- WE LOOKED
AT ENROLLMENT DATA. BY DISTRICT
IN. THE FALL AND- YOU WASN'T
COMPLETE THEN I IT'S GETTING
THERE I TO BUT WE DON'T THE
FINAL NUMBERS YET THOUGH SHOULD
COME SOON. BUT WHAT WE SAW WAS-
THE MOMENT WAS DOWN IN FALL
TWENTY TWENTY- BY ABOUT 10%
1011% COMPARED WITH FALL TWENTY
NINETEEN. AND IT SEEMED TO
AFFECT. VIRTUALLY ALL DISTRICTS
VIRTUALLY ALL DISTRICTS FOR
DOWN BASED ON AS I SAID THAT
KIND OF INCOMPLETE DATA OTHER
WE HAVE. AND THE KIND OF MORE
THAN THAT- RECEIVE JUST. IN OF.
ON CERTAIN. GROUP OF STUDENTS
AFRICAN AMERICAN STUDENTS. WE
SEE EVEN MORE OF A PRONOUNCED
REDUCTION. WE ALSO SEE A MORE
OF A KIND OF DISPROPORTIONAL
IMPACT ON MALE STUDENTS IN
GENERAL AN OLDER ADULTS FOR
THAT MATTER. SO THE DATA IS
KIND OF COMING IN NOW BUT IT'S-
IT'S REALLY- WHAT WE TEND TO
SEE THROUGHOUT THROUGHOUT THE
STATE THROUGHOUT THE REGIONS
IS. IS A REDUCTION IN
ENROLLMENT ENROLLMENT COMMANDED
THROUGHOUT THE SYSTEM. THANK
YOU WHAT DOES THE CHANCELLOR'S
OFFICE HAVE ANYTHING THEY WISH
TO ADD ALMOND. THANK YOU
SENATOR LAYERED- CURRENTLY
ABOUT 90% OF THE COLLEGES HAVE
REPORTED ENROLLMENT DATA SO A
PICTURE AROUND ENROLLMENT IS
BECOMING CLEARER AND WE'VE SEEN
DIFFERENCES THAN WHAT WE SAW IN
SPRING AND SUMMER AND SPRING
AND SUMMER AND ROMAN HAD. HELD
STEADY AND SUMMER WE EVEN SAW
GROWTH COME FALL- AS THE ELLIE-
MENTIONED WE HAVE SEEN A RANGE
ACROSSTHE STATE WITH SOME
COLLEGES HOLDING AT ABOUT HALF
A PERCENT DECLINE TO SOME AS
MANY IN THE DOUBLE DIGIT
PERCENTAGE. AND MOST STARK IS
WHAT WE'VE SEEN AGAIN ARE
UNDERREPRESENTED STUDENTS OF
COLOR WHY AGAIN YOU SEE OUR
STRONG SUPPORT OF EFFORTS THAT
PUT STUDENTS FIRST RECOGNIZING
THAT THERE'S CLEARLY ENOUGH
FACT HAPPENING ON STUDENTS AND
THEIR ABILITY TO STAY ENGAGED
IN OUR COLLEGES. AND WHATEVER
WE CAN DO TO SUPPORT THEM IN
THEIR JOURNEY OR AND RETURNING
BACK TO OUR CAMPUSES IS KEY- AS
WE BEGAN TO FURTHER ANALYZE
WHAT IS HAPPENING. WE WANT TO
LEARN ABOUT WHAT'S HAPPENING TO
THESE PARTICULAR STUDENTS ARE
AGAIN MANY OF THE EARLY
PRESUMPTIONS ARE THESE ARE
WORKING LEARNERS- KAREN'S AND
THOSE THAT WERE ALREADY ON THE
CUSP OF POVERTY. AND ANY
EMERGENCY CAN PUT THE STUDENTS
IN OUR STUDENTS OVER THE ADS
SO- SOME OF THE KIND OF EARLY
FINDINGS THAT WE ARE SEEING
THANK YOU. ARM I HAVE A BRIEF
COMMENT AND NON I WANNA DIRECT
QUESTIONS TO FINANCE AND H. R.
WAS ON A COMMUNITY COLLEGE
BOARD FOR EIGHT YEARS BEFORE
SELECTED TO THE ASSEMBLY. AND
IN MY HOME DISTRICT THE
ENROLLMENT IS DOWN EIGHTEEN
PERCENT. AND I DID ASSUME WITH
THE CHANCELLOR OF THE LOS
ANGELES COMMUNITY COLLEGE
SYSTEM AND HE TOLD ME THAT IN
ROME. WAS DOWN 10% ARE WE GAS.
ONE THE CHANCELLOR'S OFFICE
JUST SO. SOME ARE DOWN A HALF
OF. THAT IS REALLY THE- BUT I
THINK WE GONNA FONG A SOMETHING
THAT'S MORE TOWARD THE- AND
MIKE FOR. IS IF ENROLLMENT IS
DOWN AND MAYBE BY LET'S JUST
PICK A NUMBER AVERAGE BY 10%
ACROSS THE STATE. OF WHY DID
YOU RECOMMEND FUNDING FOR
ENROLLMENT GROWTH. HOW DO THOSE
TWO THINGS FIT TOGETHER. DAN
OUR DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE- SO
THIS IS REALLY MORE OF A
TECHNICAL ADJUSTMENT THAN IT
IS- UP. IT IS MORE BATES ON.
THREE IT'S GROWTH THAT HAS
ALREADY HAPPENED SO THIS IS
REFLECTING THE FACT THAT S. T.
E. R. FOR TWENTY NINETEEN
TWENTY WAS ABOVE THE LEVEL THAT
WE HAD PREVIOUSLY- ESTIMATED OR
OR I HAD COME AND WILL BE PUT
IN FOR THE TOTAL COMPUTATIONAL
REVENUE FOR THAT YEAR. SO AND
IT'S BASED ON THAT THAT THREE
YEAR ROLLING AVERAGE ABOUT THAT
FTS AND MOVE FORWARD IN THE
FORMULA AND HOW IT AFFECTS- ALL
THREE ARE- SO AGAIN I THINK WE
ALSO UNDERSTAND THAT THE ARE.
GENERAL THE QUAN ARE NOT GO TO
WHAT WE AS WELL DISASTER. ON
THE ENDING LEVEL OF TWO
NINETEEN F. E. R. BASED ON
ABOUT WHAT WE HAD PREVIOUSLY.
FOR THE WATCH AT HOME ARE YOU
JUST LAUNCHED IN AN ONYX ACT SO
YOU'RE TALKING FOR TIME THE
GLOBAL STUDENT RIGHT FOR T. S.
YEAH MY APOLOGIES ON THE NOT NO
FOR. I SAW UNDER BROWN AND HE
BE BY MY HEAD RIGHT SO I AN
UNDER. ACRONYMS A NUMBER. YOUR
DIRECT. COULD INST YOU ON. HOW
THAT HAPPENED HER AS WELL
REGULAR. AND SO WHAT REALLY IS
THE RECORD RECOMMENDATION ABOUT
AND ENROLLMENT IS MORE RETROS.
IN YOUR IT'S NOT AND- THAT
GONNA WORK OUT OF THIS AND THEN
TO MOVE INTO A WRONG GROWTH.
RIGHT YES SENATE YET- YES IT IS
MORE ABOUT- I JUST MEANT THAT
IT IS LIKE OUR PROJECTION OF
THE PUBLIC. AND DOES L. A. O.
OF ANY KIND ON THIS THAT DAY
BEEN ADDRESSED OR IN COMMENTS.
YEAH JUST ON ON YOUR- JUST NOW-
I MENTION THAT. EARLIER BUT-
THE CHANCE OFFICE IS WORKING ON.
UPDATE INFORMATION ON IN ROME
FOR THE CURRENT FOR TWENTY
TWENTY TWENTY ONE AND THAT
INFORMATION IS GOING TO.
PROVIDE MORE CLARITY ON IN
ROMAN GROWTH ON PRIOR GROWTH
IT'S A LITTLE MORE COMPLICATED
BECAUSE AS YOU HEARD FROM THE
CHANCELLOR'S OFFICE THE CHANCES
OFFICES INVOKE TO EMERGENCY
CONDITIONS ALLOWANCES- SO THAT-
COLLEGES ARTS- HARM FINANCIALLY.
THE PANDEMIC IN THE DOWNTURN
FROM THE PANDA SO LOSING EIGHTY
A LOOK AT THE UPDATED NUMBERS
INTERNATIONALLY CONDITIONS
ALLOWANCE WHETHER IT REALLY IS
THE CASE THAT DISTRICTS HAVE AN
ABILITY TO GROW AND CAN USE AN
APPOINTMENT GROWTH MONEY
BECAUSE THAT'S NOT APPARENT TO
US RIGHT NOW GIVEN EVEN BEFORE
THE PANDEMIC THERE WERE
DOWNTURNS. IN IN A MOMENT THE
SOFTNESS OF THE MOMENT A LOT OF.
PLACES IN THE STATE. THANK YOU
AND I A- FROM MICHELLE NO OF.
THE DEPARTMENT OF FINE WITH
LIKE TO SEE SOMETHING. MORNING
EARLIER UNDER WHEN FROM THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINE- DO A BUILD
UP MY COLLEAGUE I DO HANNAH OR-
COMMENT AND YOU KNOW TO ECHO.
THAT- MY COLLEAGUE A CHANCE
OFFICE AND UNUSED. OR ANY
UNUSED AND GROWTH DAHLE CAN IN
STILL BE TO OTHER OF THE
STUDENTS FUNDING FORMULA. YOU
KNOW GROW IN MENTAL HEALTH.
GROWTH IN SIX ALIKI. AS WELL AS
YOU KNOW BACK TELLING- YOU KNOW
PROPERTY TAX. SOURCE. I I'VE
BEEN OUT I THINK YOU I'M ONLY
GROWTH AND IS A VERY TERM YOU
OFF WITH THE IT'S FOR AND
GROWTH SPECIFIC BUT IT BE USED
HAVE FUN PARTS THE- FOR ME
MORTGAGE. AND WHAT THE TRICK.
WHAT'S THE TRIGGER FOR DISH TO
BE TO YOU THE CROSSMAN YOU'RE
MAKING IT SOUND LIKE THEY JUST
USE IT. OF HOW TALL TO GROW IF
IT'S RECTORS. IT'S THEIR AND
THEY CAN JUST YOU IT FOR PART.
SEPE WHAT YOU'RE SAYING. I
THINK I SAY IS THAT IF. YES
WHAT HEY YOU KNOW THE WHAT WE
ARE AWARE WE RECKON THE AND
DECLINED. WE'RE SEEING A THE-
INSIDE AT THREE POINT IN THAT
YOU OFFICE DETERMINED THERE'S
IN OTHER THAN THERE MAY BE AN
EVEN. EMERALD GROWTH BASED ON A
THREE YEAR AVERAGE SO IF YOU
KNOW. AT THAT POINT THEN THEY
MAY TAKE THE MORE OF IT I THINK
ADMINISTRATIVE ON THE
CHANCELLOR'S OFFICE AND THEY
CAN TAKE THAT ON I KNEW THEN
ROAMING GROWTH AND PLUG IT INTO
OTHER PARKING FORMULA THE
CHANCELLOR'S FOR THOSE OF YOU
FOLLOWING UP ON THE
CHANCELLOR'S OFFICE STAFFER HAS
BEEN NODDING DURING THIS
PRESENTATION. DO YOU HAVE ANY-
AND NOT NODDING OFF JUST
NODDING SO DO YOU HAVE ANYTHING
YOU'D LIKE TO ADD TO THAT.
THANK YOU SENATOR. AS I WOULD I
WOULD ADD TO- APPOINT MICHAEL
FROM THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
MENTIONED OUR ENROLLMENT UNDER
THIS NEW FORMULA IS IN MANY
WAYS A MISNOMER BECAUSE IT
COLLEGE CAN ESSENTIALLY THOSE
RESOURCES CAN BE USED TO PAY A
COLLEGE FOR ANY GROWTH AND
AGAIN AS I MENTIONED- THEIR
ENROLLMENT OF LOW INCOME
STUDENTS- UNDER THE SUPPLEMENT
ALLOCATION OR THEIR INCREASES
OUR GROWTH AND SUCCESSES- AND-
TO PORTIONS OF OUR FORMULA
AREN'T BASED ON THREE YEAR
AVERAGES. AND SO THAT MEANS
THAT AS WE'RE CALCULATING THIS
IS BUILDING FORWARD AND WE'RE
BUILDING AND INCREASED
SUCCESSES OF OUR COLLEGES TO
AREAS WHERE COLLEGES HAVE DONE
WELL THEY'VE DONE MUCH MORE TO
BE INTENTIONAL ABOUT ENROLLING
IN CONNECTING STUDENTS TO
FINANCIAL AID SO WE ANTICIPATE
THAT MOVING FORWARD GIVEN THE
URGENCY AROUND MAKING EIGHT
AVAILABLE AT THIS WILL BE AN
AREA WHERE WE DO SEE SOME
INCREASES. AND COULD LEVERAGE
THESE DOLLARS. THANK YOU AND
I'M GONNA AND QUESTION AND
AMOUNT OF BACK TO THE- BETWEEN
THE FOR HERE YEARS BUT WHAT
JUST ASK. A RELATED QUESTION A
FINAL SO. THERE IS A COLD IN
HERE. A OF FOUR THE BUDGET YEAR.
HOW DO YOU SEE THE COLD FITTING
ENROLLMENT AND UNPAID OFF TO F.
HOUSE IS THAT IN YOUR MY FOR
TOGETHER. MICHON OF. THE CHAU
LUEN DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE- NO
IT IT MIGHT BE DELAYED BUT
IT'LL GET TO WHOEVER'S TALKING.
YEAH IT SHIFTED OVER TO MICHAEL.
ON SCREEN SO I KNOW HE LOOKED
LIKE HE WAS YOUNG FOR YOU TO
TALK SO PLEASE GO AHEAD. SO IF
I AM I UNDERSTAND YOUR- RIGHT
AND I MEAN BE PLEASE YOU KNOW
UP- IF THAT IS THE CASE. THAT
THE CALL IS SIMPLY BY. THE DEBT
RATE WENT DOWN. BUT STUDENTS I
FUNDING FORMULA SO- THERE THE
RATE FOR- FTS OR IT'S THE ALEX.
AT THE END ROLE PART OF FOR.
THERE IS A RATE FOR THE COUPLE
KNOWLEDGE THANKS FOR YOUR YOUR
NOTE YOU'RE ACTUALLY DOES THE
LAW BIT OF THE WATER BILL. IN
AND WHAT I WAS TO DO. IS THE
BUDGET IS A C. OF TWO. SO THERE
WAS A RECOMMENDED CHOICE NOT TO
PAY OFF THE DEFERRALS THERE WAS
A RECOMMENDED CHOICE FOR
CERTAIN ENROLLMENT GROWTH. AND
THERE'S A RECOMMENDED CHOICE
FOR COAL EVERY ONE OF THOSE
WOULD BE IT. COULD BE AT
DIFFERENT LEVELS SO WHAT
INFORMED YOU IN NOT PAYING OFF
THE DEFERRALS DURING AN
ENROLLMENT GROWTH OF A CERTAIN
AMOUNT AND THEN DOING A COAL OF
A CERTAIN AMOUNT ALL OF WHICH-
COULD BE PUT TOGETHER IN A
DIFFERENT. FRAMEWORK OF
PRIORITIES I'M JUST TRYING TO
UNDERSTAND HOW THE CALL WASN'T
WROTE HE DID NOT A MEDICALLY DO
IT BECAUSE OF SOME FACTORS
RIGHT TO SORT OF A CHOICE TO
RECOMMENDED AT THE LEVEL. THAT
IT WAS RECOMMENDED. SO THAT
CALL IS BASS UPON. A ONE TWENTY
COMP. OF THE CALL AT GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET- HELLO. HERE YOU TECH WE
CAN HEAR ME IS ON MY PART OKAY
GREAT- SO- WITH REGARD TO THE
COLA THE COLON IS THAT IS A-
AND THAT'S BASED ON IT AND THAT
MIGHT COLLEAGUES THE L. A. O.
AND MEN IT THE TWENTY TWENTY
COMP. OF. THE COST OF LIVING
ADJUSTMENT AND THAT'S THAT ONE
POINT 5% WE- THE GOVERNOR IS.
PRESS FORWARD. FOR TO MEET THAT
TWENTY ONE TWENTY TWO KOLEJKA.
WITH REGARD TO. AND WE GROWTH
THAT THAT WAS YOU KNOW BASED ON
AVAILABLE RESEARCH THAT WE HAD
AT THE PUMP BUT- AND I WOULD
JUST ARE YOU SAYING THAT THE
LOWER NOT BASED ON A VERY. READ
YOU JUST WANT TO WEAR OF TO YOU
AND BOTH DEFERRAL. ENDED ROOM
GROWTH BASED ON A VERY REYES.
AT WHICH SAYING. YES IT TOOK AN
IN TYPICAL YEAR WE WILL. WE
WOULD FIND THE ME CALL AND THAT
IT CAN BE FOR THAT YEAR SO.
THAT THE CALL IT WAS COMPUTER.
FOR- YOU KNOW THAT ONE POINT
TWO TRAINER RECALL IT PREVIOUS
YEAR. BUT FOR TWENTY ONE OH
SOME HEN I WHEN THEY'RE WENT
THE CALL RIGHT TERMS. OF
RECOMMENDING. ALL RIGHT WELL I
THINK IT THEY'RE JUST TO
UNDERSTAND THE CHOI OF THE
THREE TOGETHER. AND IT SOUNDS
LIKE YOU'RE SAYING THE CALL WAS
ON A FORMULA YOU RECOMMENDED
JUST. THE MINIMUM OF WHAT THE
FORMULA PROVIDED AND THE OTHER
A POLICY CHOICE IN HOW MUCH TO
PUT. WELL I THINK THE PRIORITY-
FOR THE ADMINISTRATION AT THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET WISE. YOU
KNOW TO HELP POVIDE IMMEDIATE
NEEDED RESOURCES FOR OUR
STUDENTS ARE VULNERABLE DURING
CONGRESS NINETEEN. AND THEN TO
ALSO TRY TO COUNTER SOME OF THE
WOMAN DECLINED BUT WE'RE- YOU
KNOW THAT WERE SAYING FROM
EARLY EVIDENCE RIGHT NOW. SO
AND YOU KNOW I THINK ANOTHER
ONE OF OUR PRIORITIES WAS.
SIGNIFICANT PAY DOWN OF THE
DEFERRALS FROM THE TWENTY
TWENTY TWENTY ONE AMOUNTING TO
TWENTY TWENTY ONE TWENTY TWO
AMOUNT SO I WOULD SAY THE ALL
THREE OF THOSE WERE KIND OF
GUIDING GUIDING PRINCIPLES THAT
WE ARE WORKING ON THEM FOR THE
COMMUNITY COLLEGE BUDGET WE'LL
GET TO THIS DURING THE GREAT
RECESSION. WE HAVE A SEPARATE
ITEM ON THE STUDENT SUPPORT AND
SO WE'LL TALK ABOUT THAT I'M
TRYING TO GLOBAL SURE LET YOU
TRYING ADDRESS WHAT THE CHOICE
ARE. WERE IN FRONT OF AND ARE
IN FRONT US TO WHAT OUR TRYING
TO. IT IN ME JUST A BEFORE WE
MOVE ON TO ANOTHER SUBJECT IS
THE ONLY- HAVE A COMMENT ON.
THIS EXCHANGE. AND ANYONE. YES
SO THE YOU ASKED ABOUT. CAN YOU
GO CAN YOU PAY BE. THE CALL OF
WHAT'S IN PRICING YEAH ANSWERS
ABSOLUTE YES OF SUCH CARE HAS.
YOU KNOW THAT THAT ABILITY- AND
IS DONE NOW IN THE PAST PROVIDE.
OF HIGHER YOU KNOW HOW AMOUNT
THAN WHAT YOU KNOW IS OUT. FOR
A PRICE INDEX- AND AN IN SOME
TIME SOMETIMES- LET'S SEE FROM.
ADDITIONAL BASE AUG. NANI'S
OF A- FACE INCREASE THAT GIVES.
A LOT OF FLEXIBILITY IN HOW
THEY USE THAT MONEY. I DID WANT
TO MENTION YOU'VE YOU'VE HEARD
THIS ALREADY DID WANT TO
MENTION THAT ACTUALLY THE
GOVERNOR PROPOSES A HIGHER
COLA. FOR K. TWELVE THREE K.
TWELVES LOCAL CONTROL FUNDING
FORMULA WHICH IS THEIR
EQUIVALENT OF A PORTION AND
IT'S THE GOVERNOR AND I CASE
PROVIDES A ONE POINT FIVE
PERCENT. AS WELL AS A MAKE UP
COLOUR CATCHER COLE AFFORD
REPRESENTING THE CURRENT YEAR
SO COMBINED IT WOULD SO THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSING THREE
POINT EIGHT FOUR PERCENT. OF
THE COST OF LIVING ADJUSTMENTS
FOR K. TWELVE'S A LOCAL CONTROL
FUNDING FORMULA. AND THEN YOU
KNOW AS YOU PART ONE JUST ONE
POINT 5% FOR A COMMUNITY
COLLEGES SO THAT SOMETHING
LEGISLATURE. SHOULD KEEP IN
COULD SHOULD ABOUT KEEPING MY
IS THIS. KIND OF DIFFERENT. OF
WHAT YOU WANT IS THERE A USER
BASE FOR- AND IF AND IF THE
LEGISLATURE WANTS TO PROVIDE
MORE YOU TO TAKE A LOOK AT
WHAT. WHAT APRIL AND MAY
REVENUES LOOK LIKE WHAT
PROPOSITION NINETY EIGHT LOOKS
LIKE AND MAKE THAT DECISION AT
THAT POINT AS I MENTIONED
EARLIER AS WELL THERE SOME
OPPORTUNITIES TO TAKE SOME.
MONEY THAT THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSING. SOME ONGOING
PROPOSALS AND PERHAPS REPURPOSE
THAT TOWARD A HIGHER CALLISTO
LEGISLATURE HAS ALL SORTS OF
OPTIONS ERE TO DISCUSS. AND
THINK ABOUT AND THEN. I'M JUST
GOING TO KEEP GOING TO ALL THE
IS. BECAUSE ONE OF THE OTHER
ISSUES THAT TIES TO THIS IS THE
FOR STATE. AND WHEN THE- OF
FEDERAL STIMULUS CAME AND FOR
K. THROUGH TWELVE. R. IT WAS
NOT OFFSET IN ANY WAY IT WAS
JUST VIEWED AS COMPLEMENTARY TO
WHAT WAS IN THE GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET WHEN THE STIMULUS CAME
IN. FOR COMMUNITY COLLEGES AND
HIGHER EDUCATION. THEY WERE NOT
BROUGHT BACK TO THE LEVEL. THAT
THEY WERE BEFORE IN THE
STATEMENT WAS MADE IN THE
OVERALL BUDGET HEARING THAT THE
STIMULUS WOULD MAKE UP THE
DIFFERENCE SO AS WE HAVE JUST
BEEN TALKING IT DOESN'T GO BACK
ON THEIR BASE WITH THE
DEFERRALS ARE PAID OFF. BUT THE
STIMULUS IS VIEWED AS THE THING
THAT OUR COURT WILL RELIEVE
SOME OF THE PRESSURE PRESSURE
IS THERE AN ANALYSIS BY FINANCE
ANALYST AT OHIO. ON WHERE THE
STIMULUS WILL GO IN RELATION TO
WHAT'S RECOMMENDED IN THIS
BUDGET HOW DO THEY FIT TOGETHER
I HAVE FINANCE COULD YOU SPEAK
TO THAT. AND THEN IN OUR
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE. I THINK
SPECIFICALLY WITH REGARD TO-
THIS BUDGET AND THAT THE SECOND
WAVE- FEDERAL FUNDING THAT HAS
BEEN COMING IN- DOCUMENT AFTER
THE- AFTER WE DEVELOPED THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET- AND SO WE-
OF COURSE BE LIKE BACK IN AT IN
OREGON SAID THAT AS PART OF OUR
MAY REVISION PROCESS BUT- WE
DEVELOP TO THE GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET WITHOUT THE FULL
KNOWLEDGE OF WHAT THE SECOND
ROUND OF TROUBLE. THANK YOU
HAVE A PRO STATEMENT ON WHAT
YOU'VE LEARNED ABOUT IT SINCE
THE MONTH SINCE IT WAS APPROVED
AND HOW IT MIGHT FIT. TOGETHER
TO ACHIEVE RECOMMENDED. AT THE
TIME WE DO NOT HAVE A BUT
FORMAL STATEMENT ON HOW. DON'T
GET TOGETHER AT A AS AS WE
LEARN MORE THAT THE FEDERAL
FUNDING IN AND WORK TOWARD THE
MACRON RIGHT A WORK BY. WITH
YOU IN STAFF- TAKING A OUR
UNDERSTAND AND CERTAINLY WILL
COMMUNICATE IT AS PART OF MAJOR
VERSION. AND THEN L. TO HAVE A
CALM ON THIS. YEAH THAT'S- ONE
OF THE- MAJOR THEME. OF OUR-
ANALYSIS ON FOR COMMUNITY
COLLEGES AND IN K. TWELVE
EDUCATION IS OF THAT THE
ADMINISTRATION DIDN'T HAVE THE
BENEFIT OF KNOWING ABOUT THIS A
SECOND ROUND OF. FEDERAL RELIEF
FUNDING IT ARRIVED JUST AFTER
CHRISTMAS AND IF IT IS A
SIGNIFICANT AMOUNT OF MONEY AND
IT'S SIGNIFICANT AMOUNT OF
MONEY FOR INSTITUTIONS FOR THE
COLLEGES THEMSELVES FOR- TO
FOUR EXTRAORDINARY COSTS AND
REVENUE LOSSES RELATED TO THE
PANDEMIC AND IS ALSO MONEY FOR
A AS A PASSED THROUGH DIRECTLY
TO STUDENTS. THROUGH FINANCIAL
AID GRANTS FEDERALLY FUNDED SO-
COMBINES BETWEEN THIS SPRING
TWENTY TWENTY MONEY THE CARES
ACT MONEY AND THEN THE MONEY
THAT'S JUST ARRIVING NOW AT THE
COLLEGES ABOUT TWO BILLION
DOLLARS- ABOUT ONE POINT FOUR
BILLION OF THAT IS FOR CAN BE
USED FOR INSTITUTIONAL MONEY IN
ABOUT SIX HUNDRED MILLION NEEDS
TO BE USED AS A PASS THROUGH TO
STUDENTS. SO THIS IS SOMETHING
WE'LL WE'LL TALK ABOUT MORE AS
WE GO THROUGH THE AGENDA BUT
YOU KNOW IN LIGHT OF THIS THIS
NEW MONEY- TO KIND OF EVALUATE
THE US THE GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL
FOR STATE FUNDED URGENCY.
FINANCIAL AID GRANTS. WE ABOUT
THE NEED FOR- FOR OUR- TOOL-
THAT'S GOING TO COME UP WITH
ONLINE TO. ARE LIGHT OF. ALL
THIS NEW FOR MONEY THAT'S
COMING AND FACT PROFESSOR
DEVELOPMENT GIVEN THAT- FEDERAL
RELIEF MONEY CAN BE USED FOR
ALL THREE OF THOSE THINGS THE
GRANTS FOR STUDENTS OUR ONLINE.
TOOLS ONLINE INFRASTRUCTURE IN
PROFESSIONAL DEVELOPMENT FOR
AND THEN. ONE COMMENT AND IT
CAN BE TAKEN INTO CONSIDERATION
WHATEVER THIS AND ALSO SYSTEM
IT'S MY UNDERSTANDING. AND IF
SOMEBODY KNOWS TO CORRECT ME
CORRECT ME. THAT THE FEDERAL
STIMULUS THERE WAS A
PROHIBITION ABOUT IT GOING TO
UNDOCUMENTED STUDENTS AND THE
STATE ASSISTANCE DOES NOT HAVE
THAT PROHIBITION SO. IS THERE
GOING TO HAVE TO BE SOME
CORRELATION TO MAKE SURE IF
THERE'S A NEED HERE TO BE MET
BUT IT'S THEIR SOME INSURANCE
DENTAL BE MET FROM THE STATE
LEVEL BECAUSE OF THE FEDERAL
PROHIBITION. I DON'T KNOW
WHETHER FINANCER LA. A ONE
RESPOND. I CAN I CAN ADDRESS
THAT. SO THE AND ACTUALLY LOOK
BY CHANCE OFFICE MY CHINA AS
WELL BUT YEAH ORIGINAL THE
CARES ACT MONEY THEM FROM WAS
NOT TO BE USED FOR
UNDOCUMENTED. STUDENTS BUT THE
ACTUALLY THE CALIFORNIA
COMMUNITY COLLEGES CHANCELLOR
OAKLEY LED THIS LAWSUIT AGAINST
THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT
ULTIMATELY WON SAID THAT THE
COMMUNITY COLLEGES ARE ALLOWED
AND HAVE USED CARES ACT MONEY
FOR UNDOCUMENTED STUDENTS
EMERGENCY AID AND. THEY ARE
USING OR WILL BE USING. HE- THE
LATEST ROUND OF MONEY THAT KIND
OF WINTER. TWENTY THEN I SHOULD
PROBABLY ASK THE REPRESENTATIVE
FROM THE CHANCELLOR'S OFFICE IF
SHE WANTS TO TAKE A VICTORY LAP
ABOUT THAT LAWSUIT. WE'VE
DEFINITELY WON'T GLOW BUT-
WE'RE GLAD I DID THAT- THIS
LAWSUIT WAS. I. N. ENABLED US
TO SERVE UNDOCUMENTED STUDENTS
AND THOSE THAT WOULD HAVE BEEN
LEFT OUT BY THE CHARISMATIC AND
WE'RE AND OPERATING UNDER THE
SAME PROVISIONS. PROVIDING THE
SAME GUIDANCE TO COLLEGES THAT
THEY MAY USE THAT RESOURCE SAYS
IN THE STIMULUS- ON ALL THE
STUDENTS THAT WE SERVE AND SO
AGAIN THAT'S THE GUIDANCE WE
PROVIDED TO OUR COLLEGES. THANK
YOU ANNEMASSE FINANCE A IT WAS
MENTIONED IN ONE OF THE
PREVIOUS THINGS THAT THAT SOME
OF THE BUDGET ITEMS ARE ARE
BASED ON MULTIPLE YEAR ROLLING.
AVERAGES AND I WANT TO ASK
ABOUT THE FUNDING FORMULA
CHANGE OF A COUPLE OF YEARS AGO
COUPLE BUDGET YEARS AGO. WHERE
THERE WAS A MAJOR FUNDING
FORMULA CHANGE FOR COMMUNITY
COLLEGES AND CREATED WINNERS
AND LOSERS AND A LOT OF THE
LOSERS HAPPEN TO BE IN MY
SENATE DISTRICT. AND SO THE
LEGISLATURE TOGETHER WITH THE
GOVERNOR DID A HOLD HARMLESS.
FOR THE LOSERS IN THE WHOLE
AREA AND IT IS A FISCAL CLIFF
THEY WILL GO OVER IF THE HOLD
HARMLESS IS NEVER RENEWED. AND
IT'S MY UNDERSTANDING THAT PAUL
THAT WAS SUMS RELATIVELY SMALL.
PORTION OF THE TOTAL- OF
COMMUNITY COLLEGE. THAT NOW THE
ANGELES CA COLLEGE SO. IS ON
THE VERGE OF MOVING INTO THE
CATEGORY THAT IS. THE SORT OF
PROTECTED BY THE HOLD HARMLESS.
I WAS GONNA IT AND BECAUSE OF
THE ROLLING YEARS IT'S
PROTECTED FOR THIS YEAR AND
THEN PROTECTED FOR NEXT YEAR. I
WAS GONNA ASK FINANCE IF THEY
CONTEMPLATED ANY LONG TERM FIX
FOR THIS- IN THE NEAR FUTURE
RATHER THAN JUST TO IN THIS
YEAR BY YEAR. SHAHRABAD
MASHONALAND WITH THE DEPARTMENT
OF FINANCE SO AS YOU KNOW THERE
THERE'S A THREE YEAR ROLLING
AVERAGE- IN THE BASE ALLOCATION
OF THE FUNDING FORMULA WHICH
IS. NOT PART OF THE FUNDING
FORMULA THAT IS MORE GEARED
TOWARD INVOLVEMENT. IN TWO
THOUSAND NINETEEN THERE IS ALSO
A THREE YEAR ROLLING AVERAGE
IMPLEMENTED IN THE EAST XFL
ALLOCATION. ONE OF THE FUNDING
FORMULA IS MEANT TO YOU KNOW
PROVIDE A PHYSICAL INCENTIVES
FOR DISTRICTS THAT ARE YOU KNOW
EDGED ACHIEVING CERTAIN WILL-
SUCCESS METRICS. ON A NEW NOTE
THE NOTE. WHOLE HARMLESS WAS
IMPLEMENTED IN THE TWO EIGHT
BUDGET I WITH THE ACT MAN ON
THE UNDER FORMULA- IT AT THAT A
HOLD HARMLESS Q. THREE TWENTY
FOUR IT'S GOING YEAR. YOU KNOW
THIS IS SOMETHING THAT WE ARE
PAYING A LOT OF ATTENTION TO
AND ARE MONITORING ON. HEY WE
DON'T HAVE A SPECIFIC PROPOSAL
FOR IT RIGHT NOW IN THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET BUT- YOU KNOW
THIS IS SOMETHING THAT WE ARE
PAYING CLOSE ATTENTION TO TOWN
WOULD LOVE TO SEE A SPECIFIC
PROPOSAL THAT JUST PUT THIS OUT
OF. ITS MISERY AND THE- THE
OTHER THING IS I GET.
UNFORTUNATELY I KNOW HOW
FINANCED. AND IF YOU FIXED IT
FOR THE OUT YEARS YOU WOULD-
ADD A LITTLE TO THE BASE AND
HAD A LITTLE TO THE HOUSE HERE
DEFICIT AND IT'S EASY TO JUST
DO THIS YEAR BY YEAR AND NOT
GET TO PROJECTING A DEFICIT BUT
IT APPEARS TO BE SOMETHING
THAT'S GOING TO BE DONE AT SOME
POINT. SO IT SHOULD JUST BE
DONE IT IN MY TECH- BEFORE I
MOVED TO MY LAST QUESTION DOES
THE L. A. O. HAVE ANY COMMENT
ON THIS. YEAH ALL COMMENTS ON
THE ON THE FORMULA ITSELF- THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE MENTIONED
THAT YOU KNOW IT HAS THREE
COMPONENTS ENROLLMENT AND
ENROLLMENT WAS WAS THE MAIN
FEATURE OF THE OLD FORMULA BUT
THE NEW FORMULA ADDS TO
ADDITIONAL COMPONENTS. AND IF
IT DOES THOSE COMPONENTS- TEND
TO FAVOR CERTAIN DISTRICTS- ONE
OF THE COMPONENTS IS A
SUPPLEMENTAL FACTOR FOR.
DISTRICTS SERVING HIGH HIGHER
NUMBERS OF STUDENTS WHO ARE
IDENTIFIED AS AS FINANCIALLY
NEEDY AND THE OTHER IS- IS
BASED ON OUTCOMES STUDENT
SUCCESS OUTCOMES SO DISTRICTS
THAT ARE SERVING RELATIVELY
HIGHER INCOME STUDENTS. DON'T
DO AS WELL- AND THEN DISTRICTS
OR SERVING RELATIVELY YOU KNOW
HIGHER AMOUNTS OF LOWER INCOME
STUDENTS AND YOU ALSO HAVE-
BECAUSE OF THE SUCCESS
COMPONENT A CERTAIN DISTRICTS
ARE CAN TO SERVE OLDER STUDENTS
STUDENTS THAT MIGHT NOT BE
THERE ARE TO TRANSFER OR GET
SOME SKILLS CERTIFICATE THEY
MIGHT BE THERE FOR OTHER
REASONS OF THOSE DISTRICTS-
DON'T DO AS WELL- DIDN'T TEND
TO DO AS WELL. UNDER THE NEW
FORMULA SO. DEPARTMENT FOR DID
MENTION THAT THE HOLD HARMLESS
RUNS FOR ANOTHER COUPLE YEARS I
THINK IT'S SCHEDULED TO RUN
THROUGH TWO THOUSAND TWENTY
THREE TWENTY FOUR AND- THAT'S
SOMETHING THAT THE LEGISLATURE
WILL WANT TO YOU KNOW CONTINUES
TAKE A LOOK AT AS IT SHOULD.
WITH ANY FORMULA IS WHETHER THE
FORMULA IS DOING WHAT IT SHOULD
DO ACHIEVING ITS OUTCOMES AND-
AND NOT KIND OF NECESSARILY
PENALIZING DISTRICTS- FOR
CERTAIN FACTORS THAT MIGHT BE
UNDER CONTROL MIGHT NOT BE
UNDER THEIR CONTROL. TAKING
INTO ACCOUNT HOWEVER- YOU KNOW
COSTS AND WHAT IT COSTS TO
REALLY STIR SERVICE STUDENT
CREATE INCENTIVES FOR DISTRICTS
TO SERVE STUDENTS BETTER. THANK
YOU AND I ONE LAST QUESTION A
MASCOT OF THE COMMUNITY COLLEGE
CHANCELLOR'S OFFICE IN. IT
MIGHT SEEM ESOTERIC. BUT IN
NINETEEN EIGHTY EIGHT THERE WAS
A LAW THAT SET THE GOAL OF 75%
FULL TIME FACULTY AND 25% PART
TIME FACULTY WITHIN THE
COMMUNITY COLLEGE SYSTEM. AND
THIS WAS DONE- BECAUSE OF A FOR
A NUMBER OF BELIEFS BUT ALAS ED
JUNKS AND MORE PERMANENT. IN
TERMS OF THE- WORKFORCE IN N.
SO IT SEEMS THAT IN THE THIRTY
TWO YEARS SINCE THAT BILL WAS
ENACTED IT IT MOVES UP MOVES
DOWN MOVES UP MOVES DOWN THAT
GOAL IS NEVER BEEN REACHED IT'S
BEEN THIRTY TWO YEARS. DOES THE
CHANCELLOR'S OFFICE HAVE ANY
ACTIONS IT CONTEMPLATES TO
ADDRESS THAT ISSUE. YOU CENTER
LAND FOR THAT QUESTION- THERE
IT WHAT YOU WERE REFERRING TO
IS THE FACULTY OBLIGATION
NUMBER THE FACULTY OBLIGATION
NUMBER SET IN NINETEEN EIGHTY
EIGHT AS YOU MENTIONED
ESSENTIALLY TOOK A POINT IN
TIME. AND SAID THAT ANY
DISTRICT ARE COULD NOT FALL
BELOW THEIR CURRENT FACULTY
LEVELS THAT WERE ESTABLISHED IN
NINETEEN EIGHTY EIGHT AND THEN
IT BUILDS UP FROM THERE
ALLOWING FOR ADJUSTMENTS- WHEN
IT DISTRICT- IS SERVING FAR
FEWER STUDENTS OR WHEN THERE
ARE DEFICITS WITHIN- ARE STATES
BUDGETS AS WE'VE SEEN DURING
THE GREAT RECESSION AND IN
OTHER PERIODS. AND SO- FOR A
FEW YEARS THE CHANCELLOR'S
OFFICE HAS. HELLO WORKER. TO
CONVENE AND DISCUSS THIS VERY
COMPLEX TOPIC- WITH THE GOAL OF
SUPPORTING OUR FACULTY BUT ALSO
SUPPORTING THE FISCAL HEALTH
AND RESILIENCY OF OUR COLLEGES
THAT THEY MAY SERVE. STUDENTS
OF CALIFORNIA- ULTIMATELY YOU
WHERE WE OFTEN LAND IS A NEED
FOR GREATER INVESTMENT IN FULL
TIME FACULTY AND AN ONGOING
COMMITMENT FOR FUNDS FROM THE
STATE AND THESE ARE COMMITMENTS
AND ENDS IN EMPLOYEES. OF OUR
COLLEGES THAT CAN'T BE FUNDED
ON A ONE TIME BASIS AND SO ANY
REFORMS REALLY DO LOOK AT. LONG
TERM- INVESTMENTS IN RESOURCES
SO THAT WE CAN SUPPORT OUR
CONTROL I'M GETTING PRESSURED
TO INTRODUCE A BILL ON THIS
BECAUSE IT'S JUST BEEN GOING ON
FOR SO LONG. AND I'M OPEN TO
DOING IT BUT I DON'T WANT TO
REARRANGE THE DECK CHAIRS I
WOULD. LIKE TO HAVE A SENSE.
THAT THERE'S A PER TO GO AND
MANAGE A PLACE. OR METHOD WHICH
WE MIGHT MAKE SOME PROGRESS ON
SO I WOULD HOPE TO WORK WITH
YOU ON THAT AND LET ME
APOLOGIZE. TO MY COLLEAGUES
BECAUSE I WANTED TO WALK THEM
THROUGH EVERY SINGLE MAJOR
ISSUE THAT I THOUGHT EXISTED
AND- I KNOW THAT WE STILL HAVE
FIVE OTHER ISSUES AND WE HAVE
TO MOVE ON BUT I WANT TO GIVE
YOU. THE CHANCE TO ASK ANY
QUESTIONS THAT DIDN'T GET PAST.
NOTHING FOR MACHO BOAT. MISTER
MAN I THANK YOU CARE WHERE I
THINK YOU'VE COVERED MOST OF
THE ISSUES VERY
COMPREHENSIVELY- I JUST WANT TO
STEP BACK IN EMPHASIZE THAT.
YOU KNOW OUR COMMUNITY COLLEGES
RIGHT NOW ARE REELING WITH
DECLINING ENROLLMENT- MY
UNDERSTANDING IS THAT THEY HAVE
ACROSS THE SYSTEM. LAID OFF A
SIGNIFICANT NUMBER OF PART TIME
FACULTY THEY BORROWED FROM THE
RESERVES- IN AND- THE I WANT TO
ECHO CHAIRMAN LEONARD'S POINT
THAT. YOU KNOW WHETHER IT'S THE
CALL- WEATHERS THE PARTIAL
REPAYMENT OF THE DEFERRALS. WE
ARE VERY CLEARLY IN THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET CLEARLY DE
EMPHASIZES COMMUNITY COLLEGES
VIS A VIS K. THROUGH TWELVE-
AND THAT DIFFERENCE IS
STRIKING. AND IT DOES NOT SEEM
FISCALLY PRUDENT TO BE
DEPRIVING THE COMMUNITY
COLLEGES WHETHER IT'S THE CALL-
WHETHER IT'S THE REFERRALS- IN
SO I DO HAVE SOME CONCERNS
ABOUT HOW THIS IS LAID OUT- BUT
I LOOK FORWARD TO CONTINUING
THIS CONVERSATION. GIVE VERY
MUCH IN IT AND I WOULD JUST
CLOSE AS WELL BY SAYING. WE
LAID OUT LOTS OF ISSUES THAT WE
JUST HOPE WILL BE CONSIDERED IN
THE MAY REVISE. OF AN AND NOW
ALL ACTION TRYING TO MOVE THE
HEARING. ARE ISSUE NUMBER TWO
STUDENT SUPPORTS AND BASIC
NEEDS. IT IS THE SAME THREE
PEOPLE WITH STARK WITH THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE. THANK
YOU AGAIN DAM AND OUR
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE- SAID
THAT AND I'VE MENTIONED BEFORE
THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET IS FIRST
AND FOREMOST A STUDENT FOCUSED
BUDGET- THE ADMINISTRATION
RECOGNIZED THE CHALLENGES FACED
BY OUR STATE COMMUNITY COLLEGE
STUDENTS. THERE IS ALSO THE CO
IN NINETEEN PANDEMIC AND DOING
RECESSION. AT THE CHALLENGES
THAT LED TO AN ESTIMATED EIGHT
PERCENT- DECLINING COMMUNITY
COLLEGE ENROLLMENT FALL TWENTY
NINETEEN TO CALL TWENTY TWENTY
OF MY COLLEAGUES AT. HE
DESCRIBED- THIS BUDGET DESIGN
TO ADDRESS THE NEEDS OF
STUDENTS ARE THE TRIP TIME-
INTERNET AND THEY GOT BUDGET
INCLUDES. BOND TO HELP ADDRESS
STUDENTS ABILITY TO AFFORD
COLLEGE. BASICALLY THE
BUDGETING. CHILDREN FIFTEEN-
FOR A BIRD FUNDING JUST GRANTS
FOR STUDENTS- OF WHICH ONE
HUNDRED MILLION IS PROPOSED FOR
THE EARLY ACTION PACKAGE- ONE
HUNDRED AND THIRTY MILLION OF
WHICH THIRTY EIGHT ON GOING TO
ADDRESS STUDENT BASIC NEEDS.
AND TWENTY MILLION ONE TIME FOR
OUTREACH TO STUDENT RETURNED TO
INCREASE STUDENT RETENTION AND
ENROLLMENT RATES. WHICH IS ALSO
PROPOSED FOR THE EARLY ACTION
PACKAGE- I WANT TO NOTE HERE
THAT THIS BUDGET PROVIDES ARE
CONTEMPLATING ADJUSTMENT TO
SEVERAL CAN YOU COLLEGE
CATEGORICAL PROGRAMS. INCLUDING
A MAN DAY BLOCK GRANT DISABLED
STUDENTS- PROGRAMS AND
SERVICES. TO OUR STUDENTS
SERVICES EXTENDED OPPORTUNITY
PROGRAMS AND SERVICES. THE
CAMPUS CHILD CARE TAX BAILOUT
AND FRIENDSHIPS. THESE COLORS
TOP TOTAL ROUGHLY SIX POINT ONE
MILLION DOLLARS IN ONGOING
PROPOSITION NINETY EIGHT
GENERAL FUND. AND WITH THAT I'M
HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS
YOU MIGHT HAVE. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. DELEO THE
ADMINISTRATION'S FOCUS ON BASIC
NEEDS INCLUDING FOOD HOUSING
MENTAL HEALTH. WE FIVE IS
LAUDABLE- BASIC NEEDS- WERE
PROBLEM BEFORE THE PANDEMIC AND
IT'S JUST GOTTEN WORSE SINCE
THE PANDEMIC IT OF. THIS OF THE
STATE- SO TO DATE THE STATE'S
APPROACH TO ADDRESSING BASIC
NEEDS REALLY IS BEEN PIECEMEAL
LACKING AN OVERARCHING GOALS
AND STRATEGIES IS NOT A LOT OF
ONE TIME MONEY ONE TIME
INITIATIVES FOR MENTAL HEALTH
AND FOOD PANTRIES AND THAT SORT
OF THING OVER THE YEARS. SO
ALTHOUGH THE GOVERNOR SHOULD BE
COMMENDED FOR HIS FOCUS- HE
CONTINUES THE STATE'S
UNCOORDINATED AND REALLY
PIECEMEAL- APPROACH TO
ADDRESSING THIS PROBLEM. FOR
EXAMPLE THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET
DOESN'T SPECIFY HOW PROPOSALS
HOW PROPOSED NEW PROGRAMS WOULD
INTERACT WITH EACH OTHER OR HOW
THEY'D INTERACT WITH EXISTING
PROGRAMS SO COULD POTENTIALLY
CREATE MORE SILOS. ON THE
GOVERNOR ALSO PROVIDES ONE TIME
FUNDS FOR A PURPOSE FOOD PANTRY
AND HOUSING ASSISTANCE PROGRAMS
THAT REALLY REQUIRES SOME
ONGOING FUNDING TO BE
SUSTAINABLE. THE GOVERNOR'S
PROVIDES FUNDS WITHOUT ANY
EXPECTATIONS IN THE EXPECTATION
OF LEVELS OF SERVICE OR DESIRED
OUTCOMES WHICH WE SEE AS A KIND
OF FLAW IN THE PROPOSAL. WE
RECOMMEND THE LEGISLATURE
CONSIDER A DIFFERENT APPROACH
AND BY CREATING OF BASIC NEEDS
BLOCK GRANT UNDER SUCH AN
APPROACH THE LEGISLATURE COULD
USE ALL OR A PORTION OF THE
PROPOSED FUNDS FOR MENTAL
HEALTH TECHNOLOGY FOOD AND
HOUSING AND THEN INTEGRATE
EXISTING ONGOING FUNDING. OF
FOUR FROM THE- CURRENT- HOUSING
ASSISTANCE PROGRAM THAT THE
LEGISLATURE FINDS. AND ALONG
WITH THIS APPROACH THE
LEGISLATURE COULD BE CLEAR
ABOUT EXPECTATIONS ABOUT
MINIMUM SERVICE LEVELS ABOUT
DESIRED OUTCOMES FOR STUDENTS.
BUT THEN GIVE FLEXIBILITY TO
COLLEGES TO DECIDE HOW TO
STRUCTURE THE PROGRAM AND USE
THE FUNDING. TO MEET THE NEEDS
OF THEIR STUDENTS- AND- A BIG
PART OF THAT IS YOU HAVE THE
EXPECTATIONS OF WHAT THIS MONEY
IS SUPPOSED TO BE FOR- BUT THE
DISTRICTS NEED TO REPORT
REGULARLY ON THEIR SERVICE
LEVELS SUCH AS APPOINTMENT WAIT
TIMES. THE NUMBER OF STUDENTS
SERVED THE NUMBER OF STUDENTS
WHO FIND HOUSING WHO WERE IN
DANGER OF BEING HOMELESS THE
NUMBER OF STUDENTS ENROLLING IN
THE STATE'S. FOOD STAMPS
PROGRAM CALFRESH AND OTHER
MEASURES. SO THAT'S THAT'S ONE
RECOMMENDATION FOR THE
LEGISLATURE TO CONSIDER. REALLY
REDUCE THOSE SILOS AND KIND OF
BE CLEAR ABOUT WHAT THE
EXPECTATIONS ARE ON THE
EMERGENCY FINANCIAL AID GRANTS
SOMETHING WE TALKED ABOUT A BIT
IN THE- IN THE PREVIOUS ISSUE
THE ADMINISTRATION DID NOT OF
COURSE NO ABOUT THE SECOND
ROUND OF FUNDING FROM THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT WHEN
DEVELOPING THE GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET NOW WE KNOW THAT AT
LEAST TWO HUNDRED NINETY
MILLION DOLLARS OF DISTRICTS
KNEW. FEDERAL RELIEF FUNDS MUST
BE PASSED THROUGH STUDENTS AS A
PURCHASING GRANTS SO WE
ENCOURAGE THE LEGISLATURE TO
EVALUATE WHETHER WOULD LIKE TO
ADD IN THE STORY USING STATE
MONEY. TO HELP WITH THIS
DECISION MAKING A LEGISLATURE
COULD DIRECT THE CHANCELLOR'S
OFFICE TO. A SURVEY COLLEGES ON
THEIR PLANS FOR USING THE
UPCOMING FEDERAL RELIEF FUNDS
THE FUNDS ARE ABOUT TO RECEIVE
OR ARE RECEIVING NOW. COLLEGES
COULD BE ASKED- HOW MUCH IN
FEDERAL FUNDS THEY INTEND TO
PROVIDE AS EMERGENCY STUDENT
AID THE NUMBER OF STUDENTS
LIKELY TO RECEIVE THE STATE AND
HOW MUCH ELIGIBLE STUDENTS ARE
ESTIMATED TO RECEIVE. THIS
INFORMATION LEGISLATURE WOULD
BE IN A BETTER POSITION TO MAKE
A DECISION ON WHETHER TO
PROVIDE STATE FUNDED EMERGENCY
STUDENT A GRASS ON TOP OF THE
FEDERAL EMERGENCY. AID GRANTS.
FOR EXAMPLE OF THE LEGISLATURE
COULD DECIDE TO ADD TO THE
FEDERAL MOUNT THIS IS MAYBE-
SUMMER TERM ASSISTANCE OR
DECIDED THAT FEDERAL EMERGENCY
GRANTS ARE SUFFICIENT SO SIZE.
AND INSTEAD REPURPOSE THE MONEY
FOR OTHER PRIORITIES. SUCH AS
ADDRESSING THE DEFERRED. A
LIABILITIES THAT WE'VE TALKED
ABOUT. WITH TO RETENTION AND
ENROLLMENT STRATEGIES PROPOSAL
THAT THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET HAS
ASSEMBLY SIMILAR MESSAGE TO-
WHAT WE SAID ABOUT THE
GOVERNOR'S ENROLLMENT- PROPOSAL
WE RECOMMEND THE LEGISLATURE
HOLD OFF ON APPROVING THEM THE
FUNDING UNTIL THE STATE HAS A
CLEAR PICTURE OF WHAT THE
UPCOMING YEAR WILL. LOOK LIKE
IF THERE ARE SIGNS THAT
COLLEGES WILL RE OPEN THE FUNDS
COULD BE PUT TO GOOD USE SO
THAT COLLEGES CAN GET THE WORD
OUT TO RESIDENTS THAT THAT THE
RE OPENING- BUT OTHERWISE IF
COLLEGES AND K. TWELVE SCHOOLS
FOR THAT MATTER. STAY ONLINE
FOR THE MOST PART IN TWENTY ONE
TWENTY TWO IT'S UNCLEAR HOW OUT
OF REACH MONEY WOULD HELP
BECAUSE THE UNDERLYING REASONS.
WHY INDIVIDUALS ARE GOING TO
COLLEGE WOULD STILL REMAIN
THEY'D STILL BE IN PLACE. SO
THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
AND NOW WILL MOVE TO THE
CHANCELLOR'S OFFICE. THANK YOU
CENTER LAYERED AND MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE. FOR TOO MANY
STUDENTS FINANCES OF THE MAIN
BARRIER TO ACHIEVING THEIR
EDUCATIONAL GOALS WE THANK THE
GOVERNOR FOR RECOGNIZING THAT
COMMUNITY COLLEGE STUDENTS HAVE
BEEN THE MOST AFFECTED. A
POPULATION IN HIGHER EDUCATION
AND WE STRONGLY SUPPORT AND
INVESTMENT IN EMERGENCY GRANT
RESOURCES TO ADDRESS THE MOST
PRESSING NEEDS OF OUR STUDENTS.
AND ENSURE THAT THIS ECONOMIC
AND HEALTH CRISIS DID NOT PUT
THEIR- EDUCATIONAL DREAMS ON
HOLD. IMMEDIATE ACTIONS ARE KEY
TO PREVENTING THE LOSS OF THE
GENERATION OF LEARNERS AND TO
STABILIZE OUR ENROLLMENTS. WE
DO ASK HOWEVER FOR
CONSIDERATION OF AN APPROACH
THAT IS MORE FLEXIBLE AND
INCLUSIVE OF A BROADER GROUP OF
STUDENTS WOULD DESPERATELY NEED
ECONOMIC ASSISTANCE INCLUDING
PART TIME STUDENTS DISPLACED
WORKERS. AND OUR LOWEST INCOME
STUDENTS- IT'S ALSO IMPORTANT
TO NOTE THAT THESE FUNDS WILL
BE DISTRIBUTED BY FINANCIAL AID
OFFICES THAT HAVE SEEN
REDUCTIONS FOR SEVERAL YEARS
INCLUDING A THREE POINT SIX
MILLION REDUCTION IN THIS
BUDGET. THE MORE STREAMLINED
THE PROCESS OF THE FASTER WE
CAN ASSIST STUDENTS BUT AGAIN
WE THINK THE GOVERNOR AND THE
LEGISLATURE FOR PUTTING
STUDENTS FIRST. IN THE TWENTY
ONE TWENTY EIGHTEEN BUDGET. I
WITH REGARD TO OUT REACH THE
CHANCES OFFICE STRONGLY
SUPPORTS AN INVESTMENT
RESOURCES FOR OUT REACH
ENGAGEMENT AND RE ENROLLMENT OF
OUR STUDENTS. AND WE STRONGLY
SUPPORT THE APPROACH OUTLINED
IN THE BUDGET BILL. TO MAXIMIZE
OUR REGION MARKETING EFFORTS
THE CHANCELLOR'S OFFICE WOULD
CREATE STATEWIDE ENROLLMENT
CAMPAIGNS THAT CAN BUILD A
COHESIVE MESSAGE AND LEVERAGED
ECONOMIES SCALE. THAT SMALLER
GRANTS- MAY NOT ALLOW AND TO
ALLOW THESE DOLLARS STRETCH
FURTHER. DISTANCES OFFICE WILL
BE READY TO LAUNCH OUTRAGE
CAMPAIGNS BASED ON TESTING
MESSAGES- THROUGH AN APPROACH
THAT REACHES MANY AUDIENCES IN
FAR CORNERS OF THE STATE IN
MULTIPLE LANGUAGES. THE
APPROACH WOULD ALLOW US TO ACT
FAST GAINING ACCESS INTO
MARKETS THAT INDIVIDUALIZED
GRADES MAY NOT. AND THE
INVESTMENTS WOULD PREVENT- YOU
WOULD PRESENT AN OPPORTUNITY
FOR MORE INTENTIONAL FOCUS ON
PROSPECTIVE STUDENTS ARE HARDER
TO ATTRACT BUT ULTIMATELY NEED
ACT LITTLE AT EQUITABLE
EDUCATIONAL. ACCESS MORE THAN
EVER. I WAS REFERRED DEVELOP A
CENTRIC APPROACH TO BASIC NEEDS
WE LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING WITH
THE LEGISLATURE IN THE
ADMINISTRATION. TO INTEGRATE-
CALFRESH OUTREACH AND INCREASE
ENROLLMENT AND THAT PROGRAM WE
ARE PREFERRED. TO LEVERAGE THE
FLEXIBILITY PROVIDED AT THE
FEDERAL LEVEL- TO ENROLL MORE
STUDENTS IN THIS IMPORTANT FOOD
AID AND FORTY FIVE PARTNERSHIPS
WITH THEIR COUNTIES SO THAT
THESE RESOURCES ARE WIDELY
UTILIZED. LASTLY I AS THE
SENATE CONSIDERS APPROACHES TO
BASIC NEEDS WE ASSET LONG TERM
SOLUTIONS BY WAY OF CAL GRANT
REFORM- THAT PROVIDES MORE AID
TO COMMUNITY COLLEGE STUDENTS
CONTINUE TO MOVE FORWARD AND WE
THANK YOU FOR YOUR PASSENGER
SHIP IN THIS AREA. COMMUNITY
COLLEGES SERVE OVER 70% OF
CALIFORNIA'S PUBLIC HIGHER ED
STUDENTS AS A RESULT OUR
STUDENTS REPRESENT AN
OPPORTUNITY FOR AN EQUITABLE. A
RECOVERY FOR THE MAJORITY OF
CALIFORNIANS AND WE BELIEVE
THAT SUPPORTING THEIR CORE
NEEDS IS A FIRST STEP THANK
YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH. MY TO
GIVE THE OPPORTUNITY TO MY
COLLEAGUES TO ASK THE FIRST
QUESTION SHE DOESN'T. CENTER.
CHAU BOAT DO YOU HAVE A
QUESTION. HAVE ATTENDED WOULD
YOU TURN MICROPHONE ON PLEASE.
FOLLOW. I JUST HAD A QUESTION I
JUST WANT FOR CURVE PURPOSES-
WITH REGARDS THE MENTAL HEALTH
SERVICES FUNDING- THE CCC-
NOTED THAT THE FUNDING WAS
DISTRIBUTED TO FIFTEEN
COMMUNITY COLLEGE DISTRICT IN
TWENTY SEVEN INDIVIDUAL
COLLEGES. AND THERE WAS A
REPORT- THAT WAS SUBMITTED TO
THE LEGISLATURE IN OCTOBER
TWENTY TWENTY SPECIFYING HOW
THESE MONIES WERE. WERE SPENT
MY QUESTION IS. AM I TO
UNDERSTAND THAT NOT EVERY
SINGLE COMMUNITY COLLEGE
RECEIVE A FUNDING FOR BEHAVIOR
HEALTH PREVENTIVE HEALTH PLAN
IS TO HOST A QUESTION TO SET TO
THE CHANCELLOR'S OFFICE. YES I
GUESS IT WOULD BE TO CHESTER'S
OFFICE YES PLEASE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU SENATOR BO GAS- YOU
ARE CORRECT TODAY GRANT THAT
WAS PROVIDED- IN THE THROUGH
THOSE ONE TIME DOLLARS FOR
MENTAL HEALTH. UNFORTUNATELY
WE'RE NOT ABLE TO REACH EVERY
DISTRICT IN EVERY COLLEGE THAT
WAS INTERESTED IN PROVIDING
THOSE SERVICES- AS- CAMPUS OF
OUR SYSTEM OF OUR SIZE DID HAVE
A LOT OF INTEREST. BUT WITH
LIMITED FUNDS- THEY WERE ONLY
AVAILABLE FOR. THOSE COLLEGES
THAT MET CERTAIN CRITERIA-
HOWEVER I WOULD NOTE THAT-
WHICH IN OUR SYSTEM BUDGET
REQUEST- THAT WAS CREATED WITH.
SYSTEM LEADERS AND STAKEHOLDERS
WE DID INCLUDE A REQUEST FOR ON
GOING FUNDS FROM PROP SIXTY
THREE FOR THIS VERY PURPOSE SO
THAT WE CAN OFFER MENTAL HEALTH
SERVICES AND ALL OF OUR
COLLEGES AND. MAKE IT AVAILABLE
TO ALL THE STUDENTS WE SERVE.
IS THAT. WHICH TO QUESTION YES
BUT I DO HAVE A FOLLOW UP
QUESTION WITH THAT SO MOVING
FORWARD WITH THE CURRENT
BUDGET- ARE WE- ASSURING THAT
EVERY SINGLE COMMUNITY COLLEGE
RECEIVES FUNDING FOR BEHAVIOR
HEALTH. SHOULD THIS MOVE
FORWARD- IN THE BUDGET WE
WOULD- STRUCTURE THE WAY THAT
WE RELEASE DOLLARS TO DISTRICTS
AND COLLEGES SO THAT EVERY-
EVERY COLLEGE DOES HAVE ACCESS
TO THESE FUNDS. AND I'M SORRY
ONE MORE QUESTION- NO GO AHEAD
I THINK YOU'RE A FOR THE- SO
JUST SO THAT I UNDERSTAND. WHAT
SORT OF CRITERIA WERE YOU
LOOKING FOR- COMMUNITY COLLEGE
HAD TO MEET IN ORDER TO RECEIVE
THE FUNDING FOR BEHAVIOR HEALTH.
WE CURRENTLY DON'T HAVE A
CRITERIA ESTABLISHED UNDER
SOMETHING THAT WE WOULD DEVELOP
OVER THE NEXT COUPLE OF MONTHS
AS THIS. PROPOSAL MOVES FORWARD
WE LIKELY WOULD USE A
COMBINATION OF ONES THAT. I
COUNTY THAT FULL TIME
EQUIVALENT STUDENTS THAT WE
HAVE IN SOME OTHER COMMUNITY
FACTORS BASED ON AVAILABLE DATA.
RIGHT THANK YOU OKAY THANK YOU
SENATOR MEANT. THANK YOU CHAIR
LAYERED- HAVE A QUESTION FOR
THE PARDON OF FINANCE- VIEW ALL
DONE AN ANALYSIS OF WHERE WE
ARE GOING TO BE RECEIVING
FEDERAL FUNDS INCLUDING WITH
THE CURRENT STIMULUS PACKAGE
THAT I DON'T THINK IT'S BEEN
SIGNED YET- AND WHERE THAT'S
GOING TO FILL IN SOME OF OUR
PARTICULAR COMMUNITY COLLEGE
NEEDS AS EXPRESSED. IN THIS
BUDGET. THE TO THE DEPARTMENT
INVESTED APARTMENT FINANCE. CAN
OUR DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE-
AGAIN AS I MENTIONED EARLIER-
THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET DOES NOT
REFLECT- THE- MOST RECENT ROUND
OF FEDERAL RELIEF FUNDS- BUT
THAT IS SOMETHING THAT WE WILL
CERTAINLY TAKE INTO
CONSIDERATION AS PART OF THE
MAY REVISION- AND I THINK WE'LL
HAVE BEEN WORKING GIVEN YOUR
STATUS. AS WE GET A MORE.
FLESHED OUT UNDERSTANDING OF
WHAT OF THOSE FEDERAL FUNDS AND
WHAT THEIR FOR THE END IS A
CORRECT THAT THERE IS
SIGNIFICANT FEDERAL FUNDING.
BOTH WITH THE PAST IN THIS
PACKAGES AND ALSO ANTICIPATED
IN THIS ONE FOR. AMERICANS YOU
NEED A MENTAL HEALTH. AGAIN
THAT'S FOR DEPARTMENT FINANCE
IT. OKAY FANTASTIC I'M NOT A
HUNDRED. GOD OKAY- YEAH I DON'T
HAVE THE SPECIFICS I KNOW THAT
THERE IS A LOT OF FLEXIBILITY
PROVIDED ESPECIALLY IN THE
NEWEST ROUND OF FUNDING- BUT I
CAN'T COMMENT ON ON ON THE
SPECIFICS OF WHAT'S INCLUDED IN
IN THE STIMULUS AND THAT'S WHAT
WE'LL LOOK FORWARD TO
DISCUSSING WITH YOU AFTER THE
NAY REVISED THANK YOU THANK YOU
CENTER AND THEN I'M GONNA CLOSE
WITH TWO QUESTIONS IN THE FIRST
ONE IS FOR FINANCE. OF THE L.
A. O. REPRESENT RECOMMENDED A
BLOCK GRANT FOR THESE TO BETTER
COORDINATE THEM AND MAYBE EVEN
STRETCH THE MONEY A LITTLE
ABOUT WHAT YOU RESPONSE. TO THE
L. A. O.'S PROPOSAL. MANY OF
THE DAY FROM THE BANK I THINK
THAT THAT'S COMING WILL WIN THE
TAKE IT A GENERATION AS PART OF
THE MAYOR VISION PROCESS AND
ENGAGE IN FUTURE. ON THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET. DOES INCLUDE
A HUNDRED MILLION PER BASIC
NEEDS BUT UP TO THE SPECIFIC-
PROPOSAL FROM THE LEGISLATIVE
OFFICE I KNOW IT IS THAT
ANALYSTS OFFICE THINK WHAT
HAPPY TO TAKE I AND CONSIDER.
AND ENGAGE IN FUTURE
CONVERSATION ON. GREAT THAT'S A
GOOD DIRECTION AND THEN MY LAST
QUESTION IS. DID YOU MENTION
SIX POINT ONE MILLION. DOLLARS
FOR- THE COST OF WITH AND JOSH.
FOR PER. IN THIS BY YOU WHAT IN
BUT SOMETHING SUTTER. I THINK
PART TIME FACULTY HOURS
APPOINTED MESA. WHY DID YOU NOT
EXTEND THE COLON TO THOSE ITEMS
THAT YOU EXTENDED TO OTHER
ITEMS. SURE SAID THAT THE COST
OF LIVING ADJUSTMENTS PROVIDED
THAT CERTAIN CATEGORICAL
PROGRAMS AND KEEPING WITH- THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET PROVIDES AT A
COST OF LIVING ADJUSTMENT TO
THE CATEGORICAL PROGRAMS THAT.
HAVE TRADITIONALLY RECEIVED A-
COST OF LIVING ADJUSTMENT AND
IN PREVIOUS BUDGET. BUT I MEAN
IT'S SO A MESS A TRADITIONALLY
DOES NOT HAVE A COST OF LIVING
INCREASE IN THERE FOR EVERY
YEAR THEY DON'T GET AN INCREASE
IN EVERY YEAR THEY HAVE TO CUT
THEIR SERVICES BY THE AMOUNT OF
INFLATION. IS THERE A REASON
WHY YOU HAVEN'T CONSIDERED
MOVING THEM INTO. COST OF
LIVING COVERAGE- I THINK WAS
PUT PERSPECTIVE IT CURRENT I
THINK WE WENT WITH THE-
TRADITIONAL. CATEGORICAL GRANTS
TO HAVE RECEIVED A COLA- IF YOU
HAVE THAT THE SPECIFIC PROGRAMS
LIKE. WE ARE HAPPY TO TAKE INTO
CONSDERATION- OTHER
CATEGORICAL PROGRAMS ON HOW TO
TAKE THAT REQUEST BACK. I THINK
YOU SHOULD JUST TAKE A LOOK AT
THAT HEADED TOWARD THE MAY
REVISE. ANY OTHER QUESTIONS
BEFORE WE MOVE ON. AND WE'RE
GONNA MOVE TO ISSUE NUMBER
THREE. ONLINE EDUCATION IT'S
OUR SAME THREE PANELISTS WILL
START WITH THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE. THANK YOU CHAIR-
ALTHOUGH THE ADMINISTRATION
EXPECTS AN EVENTUAL RETURN TO
PRIMARILY IN PERSON INSTRUCTION
I COMMUNITY COLLEGES THE
PANDEMIC YOU'VE MADE IT CLEAR
THAT ONLINE EDUCATION IS VIABLE.
ADMINISTRATION OFFICE THESE
ONLINE EDUCATION AS AN
EFFECTIVE METHOD OF INCREASING
ACCESS TO THE COLLEGES
PARTICULARLY WITH RESPECT TO
NONTRADITIONAL STUDENTS. AS
SUCH THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET
INCLUDES NEW PROPOSAL DESIGNED
TO SUPPORT ONLINE EDUCATION
INTO THE FUTURE. AND THEIR
WEAPONS EARLIER THE COST OF
LIVING ADJUSTMENT FUNDING IS
PROVIDED CONTINGENT UPON
COMMUNITY COLLEGES IMPLEMENTING
POLICIES TO MAINTAIN ONLINE
COURSES AND PROGRAMS AT A LEVEL
THAT IS 10% UP TEN PERCENTAGE
POINTS HIGHER. THAN TWENTY
EIGHTEEN NINETEEN LEVELS
BECAUSE THE COLLEGES HAVE
ALREADY SHIFTED TO PROVIDING
EDUCATION THAT IS ALMOST
COMPLETE THE ONLINE AS A RESULT
OF THE PANDEMIC. ADMINISTRATION
BILLS COME CONFIDENT THAT THIS
GOAL IS READILY ACHIEVABLE. IN
ADDITION THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET
INCLUDE TEN POINT SIX MILLION
TO SUPPORT THE CONTINUITY OF
EDUCATION AND QUALITY DISTANCE
LEARNING. INCLUDING ACCESS TO
ONLINE TUTORING ONLINE
COUNSELING AN ONLINE STUDENT
SUPPORT SERVICES SUCH AS MENTAL
HEALTH SERVICES. HE'S AREAS OF
NEED WERE IDENTIFIED AT THE
CHANCELLOR'S OFFICE. MARIN FROM
THE CURRENT ENVIRONMENT. THE
INVESTMENTS PROVIDED ON ONGOING
BASIS TO HELP ADDRESS THE NEEDS
OF CURRENT AND FUTURE ONLINE
STUDENTS. I DON'T HAVE AN
ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS YOU MAY
HAVE AFTER MY CONSULTATION.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH WO. FIRST
ALL TAKEN THE ORDER THAT YOU
JUST HEARD FROM THE DEPARTMENT
OF FINANCE THE FIRST IS THE- IS
THE CONDITIONFOR. COLLEGES TO
ADOPT POLICIES TO PERMANENTLY
BOOST ONLINE INSTRUCTION TO TEN
PERCENTAGE POINTS ABOVE THEIR
PRE PANDEMIC LEVELS AND TO MAKE
THAT AS A- CONDITION OF.
RECEIVING A COST OF LIVING
ADJUSTMENT. YOU KNOW THIS THIS
PROPOSAL. TRY SERVICES AS
ARBITRARY CONTINUE TO BE FRANK
GIL COASTLINE COLLEGE IN ORANGE
COUNTY ALREADY. THREE PANDEMIC-
WAS FOR PROVIDING A DISTANCE
EDUCATION TO ABOUT 78% OF THEIR
STUDENTS SO. MORE NOT SURE
WHAT'S NECESSARILY DESIRABLE
ABOUT BUMPING THAT UP 288% OF
OTHER COLLEGES HISTORICALLY DO
OF MOSTLY IN PERSON- BECAUSE
THEY'RE FOCUSED ON- HANDS ON
PROTECTION COLLEGE EDUCATION
PROGRAMS LIKE LOS ANGELES
STRAIGHT TECHNICAL COLLEGE OR
COLLEGES IN RURAL AREAS- TEND
NOT OFFERS MUCH ONLINE BECAUSE
A LOT OF THEIR STUDENTS DON'T
HAVE THAT CONNECTIVITY. TO TALK
ONLINE CLASSES SO WE RECOMMEND
REJECTING THIS PROPOSAL. OF THE
GOVERNOR'S WE DO UNDERSTAND THE
ADMINISTRATION'S DESIRE TO
MAINTAIN MOMENTUM TOWARD
DEVELOPING AND IMPROVING ONLINE
COURSES YOU JUST HEARD THAT
FROM THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
THE LEGISLATURE COULD ADOPT A
BUDGET BILL LANGUAGE DIRECTING
THE CHANCELLOR'S OFFICE TO
REPORT ON CAMPUSES EXPERIENCES
WITH ONLINE EDUCATION SPECIALLY
SINCE MARCH OF LAST YEAR.
COLLEGES COULD SHARE WHAT
COURSES THEY HAVE FOUND TO BE
MOST SUITABLE FOR ONLINE
EDUCATION PLANS FOR IMPROVING
STUDENT ACCESS AND OUTCOMES AT
THE LOCAL LEVEL- CAN INCLUDE AN
ASSESSMENT OF THE NEED FOR
ADDITIONAL FACULTY PROFESSIONAL
DEVELOPMENT AND IT THAT'S
SOMETHING THE LOOK THE CHANCES
OFFICE COULD SUBMIT TO THE
LEGISLATURE BY NOVEMBER TWENTY
TWENTY ONE- SO THE LEGISLATURE
WOULD HAVE A BETTER BASIS FOR
DETERMINING HOW TO. HOW TO
SUPPORT ONLINE EDUCATION AND
COMMUNITY COLLEGES. IN THE
COMING YEARS. WITH REGARD TO.
THE ONLINE TOOLS THAT'S TEN
POINT SIX MILLION DOLLARS
ONGOING PROPOSED FOR. ONLINE
INFRASTRUCTURE AT THE COLLEGES
SEVERAL YEARS AGO THE STATE
BEGAN PROVIDING BASE FUNDING
THAT SUBSIDIZES COLLEGES THEIR
SUBSCRIPTION AND USAGE COSTS.
FOR SYSTEM WIDE COURSE
MANAGEMENT SYSTEMS IN VARIOUS
ONLINE TOOLS THAT INTEGRATE
INTO THAT ONLINE COURSE
MANAGEMENT SYSTEM. ARE THESE
TOOLS INCLUDE A PLATFORM
SOFTWARE FOR STUDENTS TO MEET
VIRTUALLY WITH AN ACADEMIC
COUNSELOR AND ACCESS ONLINE
TUTORING SESSIONS. AS A RESULT
OF THE MASS MIGRATION TO ONLINE
LAST MARCH USAGE RATES INCREASE
SIGNIFICANTLY THROUGHOUT THE
SYSTEM RESULTING IN HIGHER
SUBSCRIPTION AND SERVICE COSTS.
OF FOR THE SYSTEM OFFICE WHICH
IS RECEIVING STATE MONEY FOR
THIS PURPOSE OUR CHANCES OFFICE
HAS RECENTLY NOTIFIED COLLEGES
THAT ABSENT ADDITIONAL STATE
FUNDING THEY'RE GOING TO NEED
TO SHIFT SOME COSTS TO COLLEGES
IN THE BUDGET YEAR AND SO THAT
TEN POINT SIX MILLION DOLLARS
OF ITS PROPOSED. COULD
SUBSIDIZE COLLEGES FOR ONLINE
TOOLS SUCH AS THE TUTORING
PLATFORM AND SERVICES AND
SUBSCRIPTIONS TO TELEHEALTH
SERVICES AMONG OTHER. AWESOME
JOIN THIS PROPOSAL WILL JUST
NOTED IT'S UNCLEAR HOW LONG
ONLINE USAGE RATES WILL REMAIN
AT THESE CURRENT ELEVATED
LEVELS IF THE COLLEGES GO BACK
TO MORE IN PERSON INSTRUCTION
IN THE BUDGET YEAR COST
PRESSURES FOR ONLINE TOOLS
COULD GO DOWN SOMEWHAT OF
COLLEGES ALSO HAVE FEDERAL
RELIEF FUNDS THAT ARE AVAILABLE
FOR JUST THIS SORT OF
EXTRAORDINARY COST AND SO GIVEN
THAT OUT YOUR COSTS FOR ONLINE
TOOLS ARE UNKNOWN AT THIS TIME
GIVEN THAT THERE'S A
SIGNIFICANT AMOUNT OF FEDERAL
RELIEF FUNDS THAT REMAIN
AVAILABLE TO COLLEGES. WE THINK
IT WOULD BE PREMATURE TO
PROVIDE AN ONGOING AUGMENTATION
FOR THESE ONLINE TOOLS SO WE
RECOMMEND THE LEGISLATURE
REJECT THE PROPOSAL CONSIDERING
PURCHASING IT FOR OTHER
PRIORITIES THE LEGISLATURE
COULD DIRECTORS CHANCELLORS
OFFICE TO REPORT SPRING NEXT
YEAR TWENTY TWENTY TWO ON THE
STATUS OF CAMPUS RE OPENINGS
AND THAT THAT IMPLICATION IS
FOR COSTS FOR THESE ONLINE
TOOLS THESE ONLINE PLATFORMS
AND SOFTWARE IN THIS
INFORMATION WOULD HELP THE
LEGISLATURE DETERMINE WHETHER
AN AUGMENTATION IS NEEDED FOR.
TWENTY TWENTY TO TWENTY THREE
FISCAL YEAR AND BEYOND. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH CHANCELLOR'S
OFFICE. YOU SENATOR LAYERED
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE IN
SPRING TWENTY TWENTY IN ORDER
TO ENABLE US WITH TRANSITION TO
DISTANCE LEARNING THE
CHANCELLOR'S OFFICE HAD TO
PURCHASE AN INCREASE USAGE OF
SEVERAL LEARNING PLATFORMS ON
COLLEGES BEHALF THIS FAST
ACTING APPROACH MADE IT
POSSIBLE TO TRANSITION TWO
POINT ONE MILLION STUDENTS AT A
HUNDRED AND SIXTEEN COLLEGES
WITHIN OUR SYSTEM COMPLETELY
ONLINE IN A MATTER OF WEEKS.
THESE WERE UNEXPECTED COSTS
THAT CANNOT EASILY BE ABSORBED
INTO EXISTING BUDGETS AS THE
OFTEN OUR ON GOING COST AS
PLANS FOR FALL TWENTY TWENTY
ONE ARE DEVELOPED WE ANTICIPATE
THAT 1100% FACE TO FACE
INSTRUCTION IS UNLIKELY DUE TO
INCREASING INFECTION RATES AND
SLOWLY IMPROVING INOCULATION
RATES COLLEGES ARE LOOKING AT
HYBRID OPTIONS THAT USE A BLEND
OF TECHNOLOGY AND IN PERSON
INSTRUCTION. TO SUSTAIN SUCH
INSTRUCTION COLLEGES WILL NEED
A ROBUST ONLINE INFRASTRUCTURE
AND PLATFORMS INCLUDING
TUTORING TOOLS TECH SUPPORT FOR
FACULTY AND ADA ACCESSIBILITY
RESOURCE SAYS THIS INVESTMENT
WILL ALLOW SOCIAL DISTANCE
EDUCATIONAL ACCESS TO STUDENTS
THAT I FOUND THIS MODALITY FIT
INTO THEIR BUSY SCHEDULES WE
STRONGLY SUPPORT THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSAL FOR TEN POINT SIX
MILLION AND AN INVESTMENT IN AN
ONLINE. ECOSYSTEM THAT SERVES
ALL STUDENTS IN EVERY PART OF
THE STATE THE PROPOSAL ALSO
RESPONDS TO THE BUDGET REQUESTS
DEVELOPED IN CONSULTATION WITH
JUSTIN STAKEHOLDERS BY
PURCHASING THESE PLATFORMS AS A
SYSTEM COMMUNITY COLLEGES
LEVERAGE ECONOMIES OF SCALE AND
OBTAIN SERVICES AT A
SIGNIFICANTLY REDUCED COST
FURTHER I STATEWIDE APPROACH
PREVENTS INCONSISTENCY ACROSS
DISTRICTS AND EQUITABLE ACCESS.
TO TECHNOLOGY SERVICES FOR
STUDENTS. LASTLY WE LOOK FOR TO
CAN. TO AND TO WITH THE
ADMINISTRATION AND LEGISLATURE
ON A PROPOSAL TO BUILD THEIR
ONLINE ONLINE PRESENCE AS
DISCUSSIONS UNFOLD WE WILL
PROVIDE DATA SUGGESTIONS AND
CONSIDERATIONS SUCH AS ONES
THAT INCREASE THEIR ONLINE
PRESENCE. THROUGH INCREASED
PARTICIPATION IN THE CALIFORNIA
VIRTUAL CAMPUS COURSE EXCHANGE
INSTEAD. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
THANK YOU VERY MUCH WILL MOVE
TO QUESTIONS FROM THE COMMITTEE
LESS FOR MASS MY COLLEAGUES
FIRST IF YOU HAVE ANY QUESTIONS
NONE FROM CHOMBO. NO I JUST
WANTED AMEND THAT BRIEFLY. TIED
THE I THINK THAT- YOU WHEN WE
TALK ABOUT YOU KNOW PEDAGOGICAL
BRING THAT WORD UP AGAIN BUT
BUT HOW WE TEACH- I THINK THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET IS A
REASONABLE AS AN IS NEVER IT
JUST STATED IT PROVIDES
IMPORTANT. ECONOMIES OF SCALE
AND RESOURCES FROM MY LEARNING-
I THE ONE POINT I JUST WANT TO
EMPHASIZE IS THAT WE'RE IN A
KIND OF A UNIQUE TIME RIGHT
NOW- I THINK THE COMMUNITY
COLLEGE SYSTEM- PROBABLY WILL
OPERATE BEST AS A MODE OF
EXPERIMENTATION AND SO- JUST TO
BE MINDFUL OF ALLOWING. EACH
PARTICULAR COMMUNITY COLLEGE TO
EXPERIMENT WITH ITS ITS OWN-
METHODS OF LEARNING- SOME MAY
WANT TO DO MORE IN PERSON SOME
YOU WANT TO BE MORE ONLINE BUT
I THINK NOW IS A FRUITFUL TIME
TO TRY TO EXPERIMENT WITH THAT
AND SO- NOT TO TRY TO
MICROMANAGE TOO MUCH BUT-
THAT'S A STATEMENT NOT A
QUESTION AS THEY SAY. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. AND THEN LET ME ASK
MONICA. OF THE COMMUNITY
COLLEGE CHANCELLOR'S OFFICE I
KNOW THAT- EVERYBODY EXCEPT I
THINK THE ONLINE COLLEGES BEEN
MOVED TO THE CAMPUS SYSTEM ARE
COULD YOU JUST COMMENT BRIEFLY
ON HOW IT'S WORKING IF THE COST
SAVINGS HAVE BEEN REALIZED AND
HAS IT IN FACT YOU ALLUDED TO
IT BUT YOU DID NAME THE SYSTEM
IN YOUR IN YOUR COMMENTS AND SO
I WONDERED IF. IF YOU WOULD
SPEAK TO THAT. YES THANK YOU AT
THE- AT OUR COLLEGES ARE
UTILIZED CANVAS- OVER THERE'S A
ALMOST A YEAR- ARE YOU SAID YOU
CAN BASS AND- OUR RELIANCE ON
THAT PLATFORM HAS SIGNIFICANTLY
INCREASED- WE NOW HAVE ALL
SHELLS FOR ALMOST EVERY CLASS
THAT IS. ABLE TO BE CONVERTED
TO ONLINE PLATFORMS- AND
THROUGH VERY SOON VESTMENTS
THAT WE'VE MADE THIS YEAR WE'VE
PROVIDED MORE TECH SUPPORT
PROFESSIONAL DEVELOPMENT SO
MANY WAYS ARE YOU SEE THE
GENERAL UNDERSTANDING OF THIS
PLATFORM HAS SIGNIFICANTLY
IMPROVED- AND YOU KNOW IN A WAY
OF LOOKING AT AND THIS IS A
SILVER LINING- OF THE PANDEMIC.
THANK YOU I'M JUST INTEREST IN
THAT IN A YOU CAN KEEP US
POSTED- I WOULD APPRECIATE ANY
FURTHER QUESTIONS. MAN WHAT'S
MOVED ISSUE NUMBER FOUR
WORKFORCE. I'M SORRY FOR
HONESTY OHIO SILVA I'M SORRY SO
WHAT HELLO JUST QUICKLY JUST
WANTED TO CLARIFY SOMETHING FOR
THE COMMITTEE MEMBERS SO AS
YOU'VE HEARD- THE COLLEGES THE
SYSTEM THE COMMITTEE COLLEGE
SYSTEM OFFICES HAS ON BEHALF OF
COLLEGES- PURCHASE THESE THE
CAMERA SYSTEM AS YOU MENTIONED
AND- MANY OF THESE ONLINE
TOOLS. AND WAS ABLE HAS BEEN
ABLE TO- TO GENERATE COST
SAVINGS OF THAT'S- YOU KNOW
THERE'S BEEN A BET BIG BENEFIT
TO THE COLLEGES SINCE THE
COLLEGES DON'T HAVE TO PAY-
UNDER THE WAY THINGS HAVE BEEN
I JUST WANTED TO CLARIFY THAT
UNDER OUR RECOMMENDATION. OF
THE SYSTEM OFFICE COULD STILL
NEGOTIATE ON BEHALF OF THE
COLLEGES AND GET THAT LOWER
RATE BUT THEN JUST PASS ON SOME
OF THOSE COSTS TO THE COLLEGES
IF IT DOESN'T HAVE ENOUGH
MONEY. THROUGH STATE FUNDING AS
I MENTIONED THERE ARE
SUFFICIENT FEDERAL RELIEF FUNDS
THAT COLLEGES COULD USE TO
COVER THOSE IN ADDITIONAL COSTS
AND THEN THE RECOMMENDATION IS
TO TAKE A LOOK AT THIS NEXT
YEAR WHEN WE HAVE A LOT MORE
INFORMATION ABOUT. WHAT
SUBSCRIPTION COSTS AND USAGE
RATES ARE. THANK YOU. AND LET
ME JUST SAY BEFORE WE MOVE ON I
KNOW THIS. THIS IS MUCH MORE OF
AN ISSUE OVER IN EIGHT WEEKS
YOU SEE WHERE. THE THERE'S A
PROPOSAL FOR EVERYBODY TO MOVE
TO IT AND IT'S A SOLE SOURCE
THING AND ONLY IF. NOT ALL OF
THEM ARE THERE AND YET TO
COMMUNITY COLLEGES EXCEPT FOR
MAYBE THE ONLINE HAVE TOTALLY
MOVED THERE SO JUST TECHNOLOGY
AT THIS MAY COME UP IN UP. IN
THE HEARING WE HAVE WHEN YOU
SEE. ANYTHING ELSE BEFORE I
MOVE ON. MUCH MOVED ITEM FOUR
WORK FORCE. SAME THREE
PANELITS WILL BEGIN WITH THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE. THANK
YOU AGAIN DAND ALL DEPARTMENT
OF FINANCE- CONTINUES ITS
COMMITMENT TO WORK BASED
LEARNING AND HELPING STUDENTS
ATTAIN OR RETAIN EMPLOYMENT
AFTER FINISHING THE PROGRAMS.
THIS COMMITMENT HAS BECOME EVEN
MORE IMPERATIVE AT THE COPA
NINETEEN PANDEMIC HAS AFFECTED
EVERY SECTOR OF THE STATE'S
ECONOMY. AND IT'S BECAUSE
RECORD HIGH UNEMPLOYMENT. TO
THAT END THE BUDGET INCLUDES
TWENTY MILLION ONETIME
PROPOSITION NINETY EIGHT
GENERAL FUND TO EXPAND WORK
BASED LEARNING MODELS AND
FIFTEEN MILLION ONGOING
PROPOSITION NINETY EIGHT
GENERAL FUND TALIBAN TO
CALIFORNIA APPRENTICESHIP
INITIATIVES. THAT ARE HAPPENING
ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS YOU. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH L. A. O. THANK
YOU JUST WANT TO MENTION
THERE'S ONE OTHER PROPOSAL IN
THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET- ON WORK
BASED LEARNING IN
APPRENTICESHIP AND THAT'S A
COST OF LIVING ADJUSTMENT FOR
APPRENTICESHIPS AND WE DON'T
HAVE. A CONCERN WITH THAT
PROPOSAL. AT ONE MILLION
DOLLARS IN THE AUGMENTATION
COULD HELP SUSTAIN PROGRAM
OPERATIONS. SO TALK ABOUT THE
OTHER APPRENTICESHIP- FOR
PROPOSAL HERE THE CALIFORNIA
TOWNSHIP INITIATIVE THAT'S
FIFTEEN MILLION DOLLARS ONGOING
AND THEN THE OF WORK BASED
LEARNING INITIATIVE. SO WE HAVE
A COUPLE OF CONCERNS WITH
EXPANDING FUNDING FOR THE
CALIFORNIA APPRENTICESHIP
INITIATIVE THE- PROPOSALS TO
TAKE IT UP TO THIRTY MILLION
ONGOING YOU'RE LOOKING AT THE
MOST RECENT ROUND OF GRANT
AWARDS FOR. THE APPRENTICESHIP
INITIATIVE IN THE PROGRAM'S
BEEN AROUND FOR ABOUT FIVE
YEARS NOW- DEMAND AMONG
ELIGIBLE APPLICANTS FOR THESE
GRANTS APPEARS TO BE.
INSUFFICIENT TO FULLY UTILIZE
EVEN EXISTING FUNDING LEVELS
FOR THE PROGRAM AND SO WE'RE
NOT SEEN AT THIS TIME ANY
JUSTIFICATION FOR DOUBLING THE
SIZE OF THE PROGRAM. THIS CAN
IS THE LEGISLATURE. TO DATE
LACKS DATA ON WHETHER
APPRENTICESHIP PROGRAMS CREATED
OF THE IN THE PAST WITH THIS
WITH THESE MONIES ARE ACTUALLY
BEING SUSPECTED SUSTAINED AFTER
THE GRANT FUNDING ENDS AND I WE
DO UNDERSTAND THAT THE
CHANCELLOR'S OFFICE IN THE
FOUNDATION FOR CALIFORNIA
COMMUNITY COLLEGES ARE LOOKING
INTO THAT. AND WHAT HAPPENED
THE FIRST SEVERAL ROUNDS OF
FUNDING FOR THE PROGRAM AND TO
THOSE APPRENTICESHIP PROGRAMS.
SO WE RECOMMEND THE LEGISLATURE
REJECTED THE PROPOSAL FOR
DOUBLING FUNDING FOR THE
CALIFORNIA PENSION. SHOULD HAVE
AND REPURPOSE IT FOR A HIGHER
PRIORITIES SUCH AS- PROVIDING A
LARGER APPORTIONMENT
AUGMENTATION OR USING IT TO PAY
DOWN MORE DEFERRALS. AS REGARDS
TO THE WORK BASED LEARNING
INITIATIVE WE WOULD NOTE THAT
WORK BASED LEARNING IS ALREADY
A FOCUS OF A FEW PROGRAMS OF
THE LEGISLATURE FINDS. A STRONG
WORK FORCE PROGRAM WHICH
RECEIVES TWO HUNDRED FORTY
EIGHT MILLION DOLLARS A YEAR I
HAS A FOCUS ON WORK BASED
LEARNING OF GETTING STUDENTS
CONNECTION WITH INDUSTRY WHILE
THEY'RE STILL IN THEIR PROGRAMS
WILL WORK BASED LEARNING IS
ALSO A COMPONENT OF THE STATE
FUNDED GUIDED PATHWAYS
INITIATIVES. AND OF COURSE WORK
BASED LEARNING REALLY IS
APPRENTICESHIP IS A HALLMARK OF
THE APPRENTICESHIP PROGRAM THAT
THE STATE ALSO FUND SO IT'S NOT
CLEAR TO US WHY A NEW SEPARATE
INITIATIVE ON WORK BASED
LEARNING IS NEEDED SO WE
RECOMMEND REJECTING THAT
PROPOSAL AND RE PURPOSING THE
FUNDS FOR HIGHER PRIORITIES
SUCH AS- DEFERRAL PAYDOWNS OF
THE ADDITIONAL DEFERRAL
PAYDOWNS. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH CHANCELLOR'S OFFICE.
THANK YOU VERY AND THE GOVERNOR
IS PUTTING AN EMPHASIS ON
WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT SUPPORT
FOR SMALL BUSINESSES.
CALIFORNIA ME COLLEGES ARE KEY
TO THESE EFFORTS AND STAND
READY TO GET CALIFORNIANS BACK
TO WORK. AS A RESULT
INVESTMENTS IN WORKFORCE ARE
PRUDENT- ALL PRIMARILY FOCUSED
ON ADDING CONTEXT ABOUT WORK
BASED LEARNING WORK BASED
LEARNING EXPANDS ACADEMIC AND
TECHNICAL- TEACHING BEYOND THE
CLASSROOM TO ACCELERATE
ADVANCEMENT ALONG. CAREER
PATHWAYS THE APPROACH ENGAGES
INDIVIDUALS US AID WORKERS TO
GAIN SPECIFIC SKILLS IN
CONJUNCTION WITH RELATED
CLASSROOM AND LAB INSTRUCTION
IN AN INDUSTRY OR OCCUPATION.
THIS APPROACH IS INNOVATIVE AND
PROVIDES MANY OPPORTUNITIES FOR
THE FUTURE. LASTLY AS MENTIONED
A STUDY BY THE SOCIAL AND
POLICY RESEARCH ASSOCIATES
ANALYZING THE IMPLEMENTATION
AND SUCCESS OF CALIFORNIA
APPRENTICESHIP INITIATIVE IS
ANTICIPATED FOR THIS SPRING
THANK YOU. LET ME JUST. WHAT
WERE MOVED TO QUESTIONS AND
QUICKLY FOLLOW UP ON THAT THE
TO FINANCE BECAUSE I WAS GOING
TO ASK ABOUT THE PARTNERSHIP
AND IT WAS STUDY ON THE
EFFECTIVENESS BE READY IN TIME
FOR YOU TO CONSIDER AS A MAY
REVISE. ITEM. INTERNALLY AND
I'M HAPPY TO SPEAK TO THAT- I
WE DO ANTICIPATE HAVING A STUDY
BY AT THE LATEST APRIL-
HOPEFULLY IN TIME FOR. BOTH OF
THE LEGISLATURE IN THE
ADMINISTRATION TO FURTHER
ANALYZE THE CALIFORNIA
APPRENTICESHIP INITIATIVE AND
THEN LET ME ASK THE- FINANCE
DEPARTMENT. OUR WHO. IT SEEMS
TO ME THAT THE EXISTING
APPRENTICESHIP PROGRAM GOES
MORE TRADITIONALLY FOR THE
TRADES AND OTHER THINGS AND-
THE AUGMENTATION THAT'S-
RECOMMENDED GOES FOR NEW
THINGS. DO YOU THINK THE
EXISTING ONE IS MEETING THE
NEEDS AND THE IN A WAY THAT
IT'S MORE IMPORTANT TO CONTRACT
HAD NEW THINGS TO
APPRENTICESHIP THEN BEEF UP
WHAT IS BEING DONE IN THE
EXISTING PROGRAM. I ANSWER THAT
I THINK- JUTTING ARE ARE
ARGUING IS THAT THE CURRENT
FUNDSARE GOING TO BE A NEED
FOR- THE CURRENT USES OF A
PENSION MONEY AND WHAT THEY
CURRENTLY GO TOWARD THEM. I
THINK OUR- BUT THIS TO REALLY
EXPAND IT YET YOU KNOW THAT THE
APPRENTICESHIP INITIATIVE TO
OTHER KEY OPEN TO NEW FIELDS
TO. I'M BECAUSE WE THINK THAT
THAT THE MODEL WORKS AND IS
ABLE TO DEVELOP. A PROGRAM TO
COMMUNITY COLLEGES I JUST HOPE
YOU TAKE INTO ACCOUNT THE STUDY
THAT'S GOING TO BE RELEASED IN
TIME AND I. WILL SEE AGAIN THAT
I HAVE A HAND. FROM THE OHIO
ANDI'S. YEAH THE STUDY IS GOING
TO BE- VERY IMPORTANT BUDGET
BUT ALSO- IF. YOU'RE GETTING
YOUR QUESTION ABOUT THE
EXISTING NEED. YOU KNOW WE
LOOKED AT- TWENTY EIGHTEEN
NINETEEN. THE CHANCELLOR'S
OFFICE- HAD. ABOUT FIFTEEN
MILLION DOLLARS HAD FIFTEEN
MILLION DOLLARS TO AWARD. FOR
FUTURE OF DIFFERENT TYPES OF
GRANTS OF NEW INNOVATIVE GRANTS
YOUR REFERENCING. AND DIDN'T
GET ENOUGH ELIGIBLE APPLICANTS
TO. ACTUALLY WORK TO FIFTEEN
MILLION DOLLARS. AND SO THAT
WAS EIGHTEEN NINETEEN THAT.
THERE WAS NINETY TWENTY- GRASS
ARE MONEY THAT THAT ACTUALLY
NEVER WAS AWARDED AYE I DIDN'T
I HAVEN'T CONFIRMED OF THE
CHANCELLOR'S OFFICE ASSUME IT'S
RELATED TO DISRUPTIONS CAUSED
BY A PANDEMIC. BUT NEVERTHELESS
NINETEEN TWENTY MONEY HAS NOT
BEEN AWARDED THE CHANCELLOR'S
OFFICE- SAYS THAT THEY'RE
PLANNING TO PUT OUT A REQUEST
FOR PROPOSALS THIS SPRING AND
AWARD THE MONEY- IN FALL TWENTY
TWENTY ONE AGAIN USING NINETEEN
TWENTY MONEY FOR THAT SO. SO IF
ANYTHING THERE'S THERE SEEMS TO
BE SOME EXTRA MONEY OUT THERE
RIGHT NOW SO SOMETHING
LEGISLATURE YOU'LL ENCOURAGE
JUST KEEP IN MIND ON WHETHER
THAT. OF THAT MONEY CAN BE
SCOOPED AND USED FOR YOU KNOW
DIFFERENT PAY DOWNS OR
SOMETHING LIKE THAT BUT BUT
CERTAINLY TO TAKE INTO ACCOUNT
WHAT THE NEED IS RIGHT NOW I'M
ON- APPLICANTS AND WHETHER IT
REALLY JUSTIFIES DOUBLING
FUNDING. FOR THE PROGRAM GOING
FORWARD THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
ANY FURTHER QUESTIONS ON THIS
ISSUE. SEVEN NINE ARMINA MOVED
FIVE INSTRUCTIONAL MATERIALS
IT'S THE SAME THREE PANELISTS
FOR THE STARK WITH THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE. THANK
YOU DAN AND OUR DEPARTMENT
FINANCE- TO BUDGET INCLUDES TWO
PROPOSALS DESIGNED TO INCREASE
THE AFFORDABILITY OF
INSTRUCTIONAL MATERIALS THAT
HELP REDUCE THE COST OF
ATTENDANCE FOR STUDENTS. THE
BUDGET INCLUDES FIFTEEN MILLION
AND ONE TIME PROPOSITION NINETY
EIGHT FUNDING. WHAT DO YOU
PROPOSE FOR THE DEVELOPMENT OF
ZERO TEXTBOOK COST AGREES TIME
WHICH WAS DOCUMENTED FUNDING IN
THE TWENTY SIXTEEN BUT JACKS.
IN TWO FIVE MILLION- IN ONE
TIME PROPOSITION NINETY EIGHT
FUNDING. IS PROPOSED FOR
INSTRUCTION MATERIALS FOR TWO
ONE MOMENT STUDENTS AND WITH
THAT I'M NOT ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS YOU MIGHT HAVE A
CLIENT GOING TO THE GYM. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH FOR CALLING ON.
THE FIRST ALL ALL ALL TALK
ABOUT THE ZERO TEXTBOOK COST
AGREE PROPOSAL THE DEPARTMENT
OF FINANCE JUST INTRODUCED. IN
THE GOVERNOR'S FOCUS ON
TEXTBOOK AFFORDABILITY IS
LAUDABLE. OPEN EDUCATIONAL
RESOURCES THESE FREE RESOURCES
CAN SAVE STUDENTS. IN A LOT OF
MONEY. HAVING SAID THAT. THE
LEGISLATURE FUNDED ZERO
TEXTBOOK COST GRANTS IN TWENTY
SIXTEEN SEVENTEEN. AND THE
LEGISLATURE STILL. AWAITING
STATUTORILY REQUIRED REPORT
FROM THE CHANCELLOR'S OFFICE.
FINE HOW OLD THAT INITIATIVE
WENT YOU KNOW HOW MANY DEGREES
WERE CREATED HOW MANY STUDENTS
ACTUALLY. EARNED A DEGREE IN
THOSE OF THREE PATHWAYS THOSE
FREE TEXTBOOK PATHWAYS. WHAT
WERE THE BEST PRACTICES AND
LESSONS LEARNED FROM THAT
EXPERIENCE. SO THAT KIND OF
INFORMATION IS REALLY IMPORTANT
IF THE LEGISLATURE IS
CONTEMPLATING IN A SECOND ROUND
OF FUNDING SO WE READ. WE WERE-
WITHHOLD RECOMMENDATION PENDING
RECEIPT OF THIS ADDITIONAL
INFORMATION WE HAVE HEARD FROM
WHICH OFFICE THAT. THAT THE
REPORT IS CLOSE THE SENATE
FINAL STAGES AND THAT
INFORMATION- COULD YOU KNOW
WOULD BE USEFUL SO SOME OF THE
LEGISLATURE MIGHT WANT TO GET
THE CHANCELLOR'S OFFICE UNTIL.
EARLY APRIL TO SUBMIT THE
REQUIRED REPORT THE LEGISLATURE
THAT COULD DECIDE WHETHER FUND
ANOTHER ROUND. AND IF THE
LEGISLATURE DECIDES TO FIND
ANOTHER ROUND TO STRUCTURE THAT
ROUND. IN A WAY THAT REFLECTS
WHAT WERE THE LESSONS THAT WERE
LEARNED FROM THE FIRST ROUND.
NOW FOR REPORT IS NOT
FORTHCOMING- SO HAVE A LOOK THE
CHANCE OFFICE IT IS ENABLED IT
TO FINISH IT BY. YOU KNOW
WITHIN THE NEXT MONTH OR TWO
LEGISLATURE COULD REQUEST THE
CHANCELLOR'S OFFICE TO WORK
WITH. ANOTHER KEY PARTNERS
ACADEMIC SENATE. OUT OF THE CAR
CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY COLLEGES.
OVER TE COMING YEARS TO REFINE
THE PROGRAM THE PROPOSAL HOME
PROPOSAL AND HAVE IT READY FOR
CONSIDERATION AS PART OF THE-
TWENTY TWO TWENTY THREE BUDGET
PROCESS. ON THE- INSTRUCTION
WITH. FOR DOING WOMAN'S THIS IS
ACTUALLY A SUIT AGAINST WITH.
OF CERTAIN TYPE OF TOOL STUDENT
AND ACCESS PASS. OF STUDENTS
UNLIKE REGULAR. STUDENTS
SCHOOLS AND COMMUNITY COLLEGES
MUST PROVIDE INSTRUCTIONAL
MATERIALS SUCH AS BOOKS FREE OF
CHARGE TO HIGH SCHOOL STUDENTS
WHO ARE PARTICIPATING IN THE
COLLEGE AND CAREER ACCESS
PATHWAYS PROGRAM IS DUAL
ENROLLMENT PROGRAM. THE
LEGISLATURE CREATED BACK IN TWO
THOUSAND FIFTEEN. THE
ADMINISTRATION CONTENDS THAT IN
TERMS OF THE- THAT THAT THE
REQUIREMENTS- THAT SCHOOLS AND
COLLEGES HAVE TO COVER TEXTBOOK
COSTS IS SERVING AS A BARRIER
FOR THE SCHOOLS AND COLLEGES IN
OFFERING VISA THESE TYPES OF
DUAL ENROLLMENT PROGRAMS. AND
THAT'S WHY THE GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET PROPOSES TWO POINT FIVE
MILLION ONE TIME FOR THESE
INSTRUCTIONAL MATERIALS. SO WE
HAVE A COMMENTS ON THIS- YOU
KNOW IF YOU LOOK AT HOW THE
PROGRAM HAS GONE HAS GROWN
SINCE. SINCE IT BEGAN IN TWO
THOUSAND SIXTEEN SEVENTEEN- OR
SO IT'S GROWING VERY RAPIDLY IS
STARTED WITH. ABOUT TWENTY
EIGHT OF STUDENTS AT IN THE IN
THE PROS IN THIS- DUAL
ENROLLMENT PROGRAM IN TWENTY
SIXTEEN SEVENTEEN THAT GREW BY
A COUPLE THOUSAND IN TWENTY
SEVENTEEN EIGHTEEN. DOUBLED THE
NEXT YEAR AND NOW IT'S UP TO
MORE THAN FOURTEEN THOUSAND
FULL TIME EQUIVALENT STUDENTS.
OR F. T. S. SO IT'S A IT'S A
VERY POPULAR PROGRAM WITH
STUDENTS AND WITH SCHOOLS AND
WITH COLLEGES AND- SO THAT
LOOKING AT THAT IT'S UNCLEAR TO
US SAID CERTAIN CERTAINLY NOT
ASSIGN IT. IS SERVING AS A AS A
BARRIER- TO GROWTH ANOTHER
POINT TO KEEP IN MIND IS RATHER
THAN SERVING AS A FINANCIAL
BARRIER. THE FUNDING POLICIES
FOR THIS STORM RUNNER PROGRAM
THAT COLLAGEN CORRECT ACCESS
PATHWAYS PROGRAM CAN REALLY
WORK TO THE BENEFIT OF
COLLEGES. AND SCHOOLS. AT THE
OLD. THESE THESE ARE COURSES
ARE ARE MAINLY THESE ARE
COLLEGE LEVEL COURSES THAT ARE
OFFERED MAINLY. ON HIGH SCHOOL
CAMPUS ON A CLOSED HIGH SCHOOL
CAMPUS AND ALLOWS COMMUNITY
COLLEGES TO CLAIM FULL
APPORTIONMENT. FROM THE STATE
WITHOUT INCURRING FACILITY
COSTAS'S TYPICALLY AT THE HIGH
SCHOOL LOCATION AND THE
COLLEGES CAN SAVE MONEY IN
OTHER WAYS AND OTHER OPERATING.
COSTS- ANOTHER POINT IS IN MANY.
FROM DINNER BUT IF YOU BE TO
WRAP BECAUSE WE GOT TO GET TO
PAY CON HERE. FOR SURE IN A OF
THE- OTHER- THERE'S OTHER WAYS
COLLEGE CAN REDUCE COSTS OF
SUCH AS BY- USING OPEN
EDUCATIONAL RESOURCES. SO FOR
ALL THESE REASONS WE RECOMMEND
OF THE LEGISLATURE REJECT THIS
PROPOSAL YOU USING ONE TIME
MONEY FOR PURCHASING
INSTRUCTIONAL MATERIALS INSTEAD
USE IT FOR OTHER PRIORITIES
SUCH AS DEFERRED PAY DOWNS.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH WE
APPRECIATE YOUR COMMENTS THE
CHANCELLOR'S OFFICE. THE SENATE
ALERTED MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE ON MY COMMENTS WILL
FOCUS ONLY ON OPEN EDUCATIONAL
RESOURCES TEXTBOOK COSTS FOR
MANY OF OUR STUDENTS ARE
BECOMING AFFORDABILITY
CHALLENGE ON AVERAGE OUR
STUDENTS SPEND EIGHT HUNDRED
DOLLARS ON BOOKS SO
TRANSITIONING FROM OUR
DEPENDENCY ON TEXTBOOKS TO MORE
INNOVATIVE MODELS SUCH AS THE
USE OF. OPEN EDUCATIONAL
RESOURCES KNOWN AS A WE ARE CAN
SUPPORT THE AFFORDABILITY
AGENDA IN THIS BUDGET WITH THE
LEADERSHIP OF THE ACADEMIC
SENATE FOR CALIFORNIA'S
COMMUNITY COLLEGES WE ARE
WORKING TO ENSURE THAT CONTENT
DEVELOPED UNDER PRIOR- WE ARE
INVESTMENTS CAN BE SHARED
ACROSS THE SYSTEM. MOVING
FORWARD THE SUPPORT OF THE
ACADEMIC SEGMENT SENATE AND OUR
FACULTY WILL CONTINUE TO BE
CRITICAL TO THE CRITICAL DRIVER
TO MOVING THE ZERO TEXTBOOK
COST AGENDA FORWARD WE LOOK AT
WE WILL STAND READY TO
IMPLEMENT THIS AS NEEDED.
ANSWER QUESTIONS. LET ME JUST
ONE OF FINANCE BY TO OHIO. THAT
WE- THE- PIECES OF THE- FOR THE
REASONS THAT THEY- TO HAVE ANY.
TO THAT. I THINK I'D- DURING
OUR DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE I
WOULD JUST GO BACK TO WHAT I-
WE'VE SAID PREVIOUSLY THAT THIS
COUNTRY REALLY IS THE STUDENT
FOCUS BUDGET- INTO ONE OF THE
ONE OF THE GOALS PUT INTO THIS
BUDGET ESPECIALLY WITH RESPECT
TO THE YOUR TAX ACCOUNT AGREED
TO- TRYING TO PROVIDE.
CONTINUING IN ASKING A
COLLEGES. THANK YOU IT WILL BE
SOMETHING WE WILL HAVE TO
CONSIDER FOR THE QUESTIONS-
CENTER MINT. I JUST AFFECTED BY
MR HANNAH OUR DEPARTMENT
FINANCE- GOING BACK I MEAN THE
BOTH WITH RESPECT TO THE DUAL
ENROLLMENT INSTRUCTIONAL
MATERIALS- AND OR THE ZERO
TEXTBOOK COST AGREES- IT MAY BE
GOOD JUST LIKE BRIEFLY WALK US
THROUGH THE EVIDENCE YOU USE IN
FORMULATING ITS BUDGET. BECAUSE
LA- IS TELLING US THESE THESE
ARE- IS THAT. THESE WOULD NOT
HAVE THE DESIRED EFFECT SO
FOLLOWING UP ON CARE LARGE
QUESTION AT YOU REALLY WHAT WAS
THE BASIS FOR YOUR DECISION TO
MAKE THE SIGN I ASIDE FROM
BEING STUDENT CENTERED. WELL
YOU HAVE BEEN IS USED TO
DETERMINE THE STUDENTS THAT
THESE WOULD ACTUALLY BE
EFFECTIVE IN HELPING STUDENTS-
EITHER WITH THE- THE EXPANSION
OF THE ZERO TEXT BOOK- BASED
APPROACH OR WITH GOLDEN GIRL
FINALEMENT. I THINK AT THE
MOMENT I DON'T HAVE A SPECIFIC
SPECIFIC SURVEYED OR OR ANY
SORT OF STUDIED CUT TO POINT TO
I THINK BASED ON WHAT WE'VE
SEEN BOTH OF THESE PROGRAMS
HAVE BEEN. SUCCESSFUL IN
HELPING TO CREATE SAVINGS FOR
STUDENTS AND OPEN A GREAT YOU-
TRANSITIONS FOR STUDENTS TO
COMMUNITY COLLEGE AND WHATEVER
THEIR GOALS MIGHT BE. WHETHER
THAT BE THE- GTA P. PROGRAM- BY
THAT THAT THAT CALL IT A
CALIFORNIA COLLEGE AND CAREER
ACCESS PATHWAYS PROGRAMS THAT-
MY COLLEAGUE NEARLY A TALK
ABOUT. OR DID YOUR TAX BECAUSE
DEGREES- AND SO AS AS PART OF
TRYING TO HELP STUDENTS WITH
THEIR- COVER THEIRNEEDS AND
THEIR THEIR CONCERT IN WITH
COMMUNITY COLLEGE. ON THE
BUDGET DECIDED TO MAKE
ADDITIONAL. INVESTMENTS- THANK
YOU. AND I WOULD JUST MY THE
STATE THAT IF YOU HAD TO THE
MIRROR MAY. AND YOU FIND THINGS
THAT ARE RESPONSIVE. TO SENATOR
MEN'S QUESTION ABOUT EVIDENCE
BASED PLEASE BRING IT FORWARD
SO THAT. WE HAVE ANY FURTHER
QUESTIONS ON THE SIDE OF. AND-
WE WILL MOVE TO THE LAST ITEM
OF THE SIX ISSUES PROFESSIONAL
DEVELOPMENT SAME THREE
PANELISTS BEGIN WITH THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE. IN OVER
TO PERMANENT FINANCE THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET INCLUDES
TWENTY MILLION ONE TIME FOR
CULTURALLY COMPETENT
PROFESSIONAL DEVELOPMENT FOR
FACULTY THAT LEVERAGES MODERN
TECHNOLOGY- THE INTENT OF THIS
PROPOSAL IS TO PROVIDE FACULTY
WITH PROFESSIONAL DEVELOPMENT
DESIGNED TO PRIMARILY SUPPORT
THEIR CONTINUED. ADAPTATION TO
THE ONLINE AND TECHNOLOGICALLY
AT THE LEARNING ENVIRONMENT
SUCH AS PROFESSIONAL
DEVELOPMENT AN ONLINE
INSTRUCTIONAL DESIGN ONLINE
COURSE DELIVERY AND THE
UTILIZATION OF TECHNOLOGY IN
TEACHING COURSES. IT MEASURES
MINISTRATION EXPECT THAT THIS
PROFESSIONAL DEVELOPMENT.
INTEGRATE EQUITY AND CULTURAL
CONFIDENCE INTO THE
PROFESSIONAL DEVELOPMENT AT THE
KEY DESIGN PRINCIPLE- I DON'T
HAVE AN ANSWER QUESTIONS ABOUT.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH THE L. L.
BAKALY HAVE ACCESS TO MULTIPLE
FORMS OF PROFESSIONAL
DEVELOPMENT INCLUDING
PROFESSIONAL DEVELOPMENT FOCUS
SPECIFICALLY ON USING DIGITAL
TOOLS AND TEACHING ONLINE
COLLAGENS OF AS COLLEGES AND
DEPARTMENTS COMMONLY PROVIDE
TRAINING USING THEIR PORTION OF
MONEY OR OTHER FUNDS TO
FACULTY. THE STATE FUNDS
INSTITUTIONAL EFFECTIVENESS
PARTNERSHIP INITIATIVE
INCLUDING TWENTY MILLION
DOLLARS ALREADY AND BASS
FUNDING FOR TRAININGS FOR
FACULTY AND STAFF IN VARIOUS
TOPICS OF THIS PAST FALL THE
ACADEMIC SENATE REPORTS THAT
HOLDING FORTY ONE- WEBINARS ON
TEACHING ONLINE- THE STATE ALSO
FUNDS A PROGRAM THROUGH THE
ONLINE EDUCATION INITIATIVE.
FOCUSED ON. HELPING FACULTY
TEACH ONLINE DEVELOP COURSES
ONLINE. AND THERE'S EVEN
COURSES- OR OR MODULES THAT
FACULTY CAN TAKE ON CULTURALLY
COMPETENT- TEACHING
METHODOLOGIES- WE WOULD ALSO
NOTE THAT THE THAT THE US
COMMITTEE COLLEGES HAVE
RECEIVED SIGNIFICANT AMOUNT OF
MONEY BEFORE CONVERTING TO
ONLINE AND THAT'S FROM THE
STATE AS AS WELL AS THE
FEDERAL. RELIEF MONEY SO GIVEN
ALL OF THESE ARE STATE FUNDED-
PROGRAMS GIVEN THE FEDERAL
RELIEF MONEY THAT COLLEGES.
HAVE USED FOR. ONLINE- TEACHING
AND- THE CONVERSION- THAT THEY
CAN CONTINUE TO USE THE NEED
FOR ADDITIONAL FUNDS- AS
PROPOSED BY THE GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET IS UNCLEAR- SO WE
RECOMMEND REJECTING THE
PROPOSAL AND RE PURPOSING THE
FUNDS FOR HIGHER PRIORITY ONE
TIME FOR. A PRIORITY SUCH AS
DEFERRAL PAYDOWNS OR HELPING
WITH PENSIONS OTHER OTHER TYPES
OF ACTIVITIES SUCH AS THAT.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH OF THE
CHANCELLOR'S OFFICE. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH AND THE COMPANY CAN
COLLEGES OUR STUDENTS A TEN
CAMPUSES ACROSS DIVERSE SYSTEM
OF WHICH 72% OF OUR STUDENTS
OUR STUDENTS OF COLOR
IMMIGRANTS ARE BOTH SUPPORTING
EFFORTS TO INCREASE DIVERSITY
AND CULTURAL COMPETENCY ARE
VITAL TO ENSURING THAT
STUDENTS. CAN IDENTIFY WITH
FACULTY AND STAFF AND TO HELP
THEM SUCCEED IN NOVEMBER OF
TWENTY EIGHTEEN THE BOARD OF
GOVERNORS REQUESTED THE
CHANCELLOR'S OFFICE TO
ESTABLISH A FACULTY AND STAFF
DIVERSITY EQUITY AND INCLUSION
TASK FORCE. THE TASK FORCE HAS
PRESENTED A SET OF
RECOMMENDATIONS ON STRUCTURAL
CHANGES INCLUDING POLICIES
PRACTICES AND TOOLS THAT WILL
SPPORT DIVERSITY INITIATIVES.
THE GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL FOR
TWENTY MILLION ONE TIME FOR
CULT FOR FACULTY PROFESSIONAL
DEVELOPMENT RELATED TO ONLINE
EDUCATION AND CULTURE CULTURAL
COMPETENCY ALIGNS WITH THESE
GOALS AND RECOGNIZES THE
OPPORTUNITIES TO IMPROVE
PRACTICES- UNDER THE CURRENT
LEARNING MODALITIES THAT WERE
OPERATING SO WE- SUPPORT. THESE
EFFORTS THANK YOU. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH- QUESTIONS ROM
COMMITTEE MEMBERS ANY QUESTIONS
ON THIS. ONE NONE FROM SENATOR
MAN NONE FROM CENTER OF
TROUBLED BY ME JUST NOTE THAT.
WE DID. A NOTE THAT THE
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST- SUGGESTED
REJECTING THIS PROPOSAL I ALSO
KNOW THAT THERE WERE SOME
PORTAGE CAME IN FROM SOME OF
THE STAKEHOLDER GROUPS ABOUT
THE PROFESSIONAL DEVELOPMENT SO
WE'LL JUST. TAKE THAT INTO
ACCOUNT AS WE MOVE TOWARD OF
THE MAY REVISED BUT THAT
COMPLETES OUR SIX ISSUES AND WE
DO HAVE AN OPPORTUNITY FOR
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC. TO
COMMENT ON ANY ITEM. THAT WAS-
DISCUSSED TODAY BUT WE'RE NOT
TAKING ACTION THIS WAS JUST AN
INFORMATIONAL HEARING AND LET
ME IN A MOMENT WE WILL GET TO-
THE TELECONFERENCE SERVICE AND
I'LL JUST REMIND EVERYONE THAT
TODAY'S PARTICIPANT NUMBER IS.
844-291-6364. EIGHT FOUR FOUR
TWO NINE ONE SIX THREE SIX
FOUR. AND THE ACCESS CODE. IS.
654-289-7654 TWO EIGHT NINE
SEVEN. AND SO. DUE TO THE
CONSTRAINTS OF THE TIME OF THE
HEARING OF THE PROTOCOLS I'M
KIND OF LIMIT EVERYBODY TO ONE
MINUTE. YESTERDAY IN OUR
HEARING NOBODY COULD HANDLE
THAT- SO HARD YOU REALLY WOULD
NOT LIKE TO HAVE TO CUT YOU OFF
BUT JUST REMEMBER I WILL IF YOU
GO MUCH OVER. ONE MINUTE. WE'RE
GOING TO BEGIN WITH ANY
WITNESSES- IN THE HEARING ROOM.
ARE THERE ANY WITNESSES HERE IN
THE HEARING ROOM ON THE SIDE OF.
SINGING ON THE STAFF APPARENTLY
HAS NO FURTHER OPINION. SO WE
WILL MOVE TO ROOM TWENTY FORTY
WHICH IS OUR OVERFLOW ROOMS OR
ANYBODY IN ROOM TWENTY FORTY
THAT HAS AN OPINION TO OFFER.
WE SEE NO ONE THERE SO WE WILL
MOVE TO THE MODERATOR MODERATOR
WOULD YOU QUEUE UP THE FIRST.
CALLER AND A VERY MINDER IF YOU
WISH TO COMMENT PRESS ONE THEN
ZERO AGAIN LONDON ZERO TO
COMMENT VIA THE PHONE. WE DO
HAVE ABOUT SEVENTEEN AND LIKE
YOU LOCAL COMBINED TWENTY FIVE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO GOOD
AFTERNOON THIS IS MY AREA FROM
YOUNG INVINCIBLES. WE CAN HELP
YOU. THREE ZERO ZERO TWO IF YOU
WOULD NUMBER TEN ANY OTHER
CALLERS MUTE ANY OTHER DEVICE
YOU HAVE IN THE BACKGROUND SO
THAT IT DOESN'T- OF. REPEAT
OKAY HELLO MY FAMILY WITH WIRES
ARE PUSHING THE INCLUSION AND
FUNDING PERSONS WHICH NEED AND
THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET AS A
COMBAT MAKE HAVE LONG LASTING
EFFECTS ON SO MANY STUDENTS I
AM REQUESTING THAT SOME OF THE
FUNDS BE USED FOR ONGOING FOR
COMMITTEE COLLEGES ROAD JUST
ONE TIME. BECAUSE THE HUNDRED
MILLION. FOR EARLY ACTION OR
SCRATCH EIGHT TWENTY BECAUSE
STUDENTS AND URGE YOU TO
STRUCTURE THE FUNDS IN A WAY.
THAT ENABLE CALL STUDENTS
ADDRESS DIDN'T EMERGENCY. IN
MEMORY AND QUICKLY. I REQUEST
THAT YOU ELIGIBILITY IMITATION
TRULY CENTRAL TIME ROLLED OR
FULL TIME EMPLOYEE. PASSED OR
SHOOT LEGALIZATION COULD
EXCLUDE MANY CHEMICAL STUDENTS
STRUGGLING WITH UNEXPECTED
COSTS AND BASIC NEEDS THANK YOU
THANK YOU VERY MUCH WE
APPRECIATE THE COMMENTS
MODERATOR- NEXT CALLER. NEXT
DOOR TO LINE TWENTY SIX PLEASE
GO AHEAD. HI MY NAME IS. ELLIE
CC I'M SPEAKING ON BEHALF OF
YOUNG INVINCIBLES. READING
CUSHION OF FUNDING FOR THE
STUDENT BASIC NEEDS IN THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET BUT OF THE
PANDEMIC HAS LONG LASTING
EFFECTS ON SO MANY STUDENTS
REQUESTING THAT SOME OF THESE
ONE FOR COMMUNITY COLLEGE ARE
ONGOING AS OPPOSED TO A ONE
HUNDRED. TWENTY WE SUPPORT THE
HUNDRED MILLION ALLOCATION FOR
EARLY ACTION EMERGENCY
FINANCIAL AID FOR COMMUNITY
COLLEGE STUDENTS. AND URGE YOU
TO STRUCTURE THE FUNDS IN A WAY
THAT ENABLE COLLEGE STUDENTS.
TO ADDRESS STUDENT EMERGENCIES
NEEDS. ASSEMBLY AND QUICKLY. I
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST THAT YOU
REMOVE ELIGIBILITY LIMITATIONS
RELATED TO STUDENT FULL TIME
ENROLLMENT OR FULL TIME
EMPLOYMENT PAST OR FUTURE.
ASIAN WITH MANY COMMUNITY
COLLEGE STUDENTS STRUGGLING
WITH UNEXPECTED COSTS BASIC
NEEDS VERIFICATION OF
ELIGIBILITY WOULD ALSO SERVE TO
DELAY THE STUDENTS ARE STEEP OF
A WILL CONSUME CALLED RESOURCES
DURING CHALLENGING TIMES THANK
YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH- NEXT
CALLER. NEXT LEVEL TRYING
TWENTY SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
MY NAME IS GROUP AND I'M
SPEAKING ON BEHALF OF YOUNG
INVINCIBLE AND AS A FORMER
COMMUNITY COLLEGE STUDENT I
APPRECIATE THE INCLUSION OF
FUNDING PER STUDENT BASIC NEEDS
AND THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET BUT
AT THE TIME TO MAKE YOUR LONG
LASTING EFFECT ON SO MANY
STUDENTS I AM REQUESTING THAT
SOME OF THESE BONDS. ARE GOING
FOR COMMUNITY COLLEGE STUDENTS
RATHER THAN JUST ONE TIME WE
SUPPORT THE ONE HUNDRED MILLION
DOLLAR A LOCATION FOR EARLY
ACTION EMERGENCY FINANCIAL AID
FOR COMMUNITY COLLEGE STUDENTS
AND URGE YOU TO STRUCTURE THE
FIND IN A WAY THAT ENABLE
COLLEGE COLLEGES ADDRESS
STUDENT EMERGENCY NEEDS NIMBLY
AND QUICKLY RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST THAT YOU REMOVE
ELIGIBILITY LIMITATIONS.
RELATED TO STUDENT FULL TIME
ENROLLMENT OR FULL TIME
EMPLOYMENT PASS OR FUTURE
SPECIAL MEDICATIONS WOULD
EXCLUDE MANY COMMUNITY COLLEGE
STUDENTS STRUGGLING WITH
UNEXPECTED COSTS AND BASIC
NEEDS AND THE VERIFICATION OF
ELIGIBILITY WOULD ALSO- DELAYS
IN RECEIPT OF EIGHT. EIGHT AND
ENTERING COLLEGE REPORTER
DURING. THANK YOU THANK YOU
VERY MUCH OF THEM MODERATE NEXT.
THE NEXT ELECTION LINE THIRTY
SIX PLEASE AHEAD. HELLO MY NAME
IS CHINA. I AM SPEAKING ON
BEHALF YOUR MENTAL I APPRECIATE
THE INCLUSION OF FUNDING FOR
STUDENT BASIC NEEDS IN THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET THAT THE
PANDEMIC HAS HAD LONG LASTING
EFFECTS ON SO MANY STUDENTS I
AM REQUESTING THAT SOMEBODY
FUNDS BE ONGOING FOR COMMUNITY
COLLEGES RATHER THAN JUST ONE
TIME. WE SUPPORT THE HUNDRED
MILLION ALLOCATION FOR EARLY
ACTION EMERGING FINANCIAL AID
FOR COMMUNITY COLLEGE STUDENTS
ARE YOU CONSTRUCTION THE BOND
IN A WAY THAT LABEL COLLEGES
THAT JUDGE THE MERGING
BURGEONING AND QUICKLY WE
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST THAT YOU
REMOVE ELIGIBILITY LIMITATIONS
OR IT PLAYED IT TO STUDENTS
TIME EMPLOYMENT ARE FULL TIME
EMPLOYMENT STRASBOURG FUTURE
PRESENTATIONS LOCAL MANY
COMMUNITY COLLEGE STUDENTS
STRUGGLING WITH UNEXPECTED
BECAUSE THE BASIC NEEDS AND THE
VERIFICATION OF ELIGIBILITY BUT
ALSO THIRTY DELAYS INCREASE.
WITH AGE COLLEGE RECORDED
DURING. THE CHARGING. THANK YOU
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. MODERATOR
NOW HOUR. EXCELLENT POINT EIGHT
WE'VE GOT. BY MY NAME IS THIS
IS MY RAIMES ON BEHALF OF YOUNG
INVINCIBLES AS A FORMER
COMMUNITY COLLEGE STUDENT. I
APPRECIATE THE INCLUSION OF
FUNDING PER STUDENT BASIC NEEDS
AND THE GOVERNMENT BUDGET BUT
AS THE PANDEMIC HAS LONG
LASTING EFFECTS ON SO MANY
STUDENTS I AM REQUESTING THAT
SOME OF THESE FUNDS BEYOND
GOING FOR COMMUNITY COLLEGE.
AGES BETTER THAN JUST ONE TIME
WE SUPPORT THE HUNDRED MILLION
ALLOCATION PER DAY ACTION
EMERGENCY FINANCIAL AID FOR
COMMUNITY COLLEGE STUDENTS AND
URGE YOU TO INS STRUCTURE THE
FUNDS IN A WAY THAT ENABLE
COLLEGES TO ADDRESS STUDENT
EMERGENCY NEEDS ASSEMBLY AND
QUICKLY RESPECTFULLY REQUEST
THAT YOU REMOVE AT AGE ABILITY.
IMITATIONS RELATED TO STUDENTS
FOR GENERAL MEN OR FULL TIME
EMPLOYMENT THAT'S OUR FUTURE
SUCH LIMITATIONS WOULD EXCLUDE
MANY COMMUNITY COLLEGE STUDENTS
STRUGGLING WITH UNEXPECTED
CAUGHT IN BETWEEN. AND THAT
WE'RE CREEK VERIFICATION OF
ELIGIBILITY WILL ALSO SERVE TO
DELAY STUDENTS RECEIVE AID AND
CONSUME COLLEGE RESOURCES
DURING A CHALLENGING TIME THANK
YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH- ARE
RETURNING CALL. YES NOT TO A
LOT LINE FIFTH FOUR PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HELLO LAWYER AND NUMBERS
MY NAME IS AND I STUDENTS
MODESTO CALL. I WANT TO EXPRESS
SUPPORT FOR A FULL FUNDED- C.
APPRECIATE- AND- EARLY ACTION
EMERGED GRANTS PROTECTION
STRATEGY BASIC NEEDS ZERO COST
TEXTBOOKS TECHNOLOGY MENTAL
HEALTH REQUIRED COMPLETION OF
THE FASTER I WOULD SHOULD BE
THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET. ALL
THESE ARE CRITICAL PRIORITIES
FIRST CTC STUDENTS PROGRESS IN
THE PROPOSAL MUST BE MODIFIED
REALLY 70% OF STUDENTS ONE MORE
PART TIME LAST FALL YOU CAN
MEETING. TO WORK PART TIME TO
SUPPORT YOUR FAMILY. THE
PROPOSAL IS BILL VERY FOR THE
MORE TO GRAHAM LOCKOUT MOSTLY.
FROM CRITICAL EIGHT. HOW
STUDENT DO NOT HAVE. PART TIME.
NEXT WEEK ACCORDING SHOULD BE
AN ONGOING INVEST TO SUPPORT ON
GOING. ADDITIONAL PROP SIX
THREE REVOLUTIONS USED FUND
MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES TO
CONSERVE SCARCE PROP NINETY
EIGHT RUNS. FINALLY ENVESTNET
CAL GRANT REFORM IS NEEDED TO
ENSURE THE TOTAL COST OF
ATTENDANCE ACCOUNTED FOR NOT
SURE TUITION FEES THANK YOU
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. OF A
MODERATOR NEXT CALL. THE
EXPANSION JUST GIVE ME AN
UPDATE WE HAVE ABOUT THIRTY
FOUR LEFT IN THE CUBICLE NEXT
MOVES TO LINE. FIFTY FIVE.
BUTCHER LEARN MANY NUMBERS MY
NAME IS VICTOR HERNANDEZ I'M
HONESTLY NOT SURE IF THE
COLLEGE I WANT TO EXPRESS MY
SUPPORT BURKE BOTH FUNDED
CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY COLLEGE
SYSTEM AND APPRECIATION FOR
EARLY ACTION EMERGENCY GRANT.
RETENTION STRATEGIES BASIC
NEEDS LARA CROFT TEXTBOOK
TECHNOLOGY MENTAL HEALTH AND
REQUIRED COMPLETION. OF ALL OF
THESE ARE CRITICAL PRIORITIES
FOR CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY
COLLEGE STUDENTS HOWEVER SOME
OF THESE PROPOSALS MUST BE
MODIFIED. NEARLY 70% OF
STUDENTS WERE ENROLLED PART
TIME LAST YEAR DUE TO NEEDING
WORK. PART TIME TO SUPPORT THE
FAMILY. WAS DOLLARS BILLION.
FOR THE EMERGING GRANTS WILL
LOCK. MOST OF THE STATE
PHARMACY CRITICAL. ARE TIMES TO
DON'T HAVE PART TIME EIGHT NEXT
BIG NEEDS SHOULD BE AN ONGOING
AND- JUST. ONGOING NEED.
ADDITIONALLY COP SIXTY REVENUE
SHOULD BE USED TO ON MENTAL
HEALTH SERVICES TO CAN. SCARCE
CROP NINETY EIGHT RATHER. ONLY
AND INVESTMENT GRANT WANTED ME
TO ENSURE THAT THE WHOLE COST
OF THE- AT THE COUNTER DOOR.
NOT JUST TUITION FEES. THANK
YOU I HOPE YOU HAVE A GREAT DAY.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH AND LET ME
JUST SAY- BECAUSE WE HAVE A
THIRTY MORE PEOPLE THE QUEUE
GOING TO HAVE. TO FORTY PEOPLE.
THAT TO COME HAVE BEEN PRETTY
MUCH A LONG TO SCRIPS AND IF
YOU FEEL FREE TO SAY. WHERE
YOU'RE CALLING FROM AND ME TOO
IF YOU JUST WISH TO ECHO WHAT
SOMEBODY ELSE'S SAID BUT WE
WILL HEAR. FROM EVERYBODY
MODERATOR NEXT CALL. THE NEXT
AVAILABLE TO LINE SIXTY THREE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI MY NAME IS
TERRY ROZIER WITH JOHN BURTON
ADVOCATES FOR YOU. WE'RE
REQUESTING THAT THE FUNDS
ALLOCATED FOR COMMUNITY
COLLEGES TO ADDRESS FOOD AND
HOUSING INSECURITY ON GOING
RATHER THAN ONE TIME. STUDENT
WHO ARE THIRTY HOUSING
INSECURITY ACCESS TO A PERSON
WHO CAN HELP THEM TO
TROUBLESHOOT ACCESS RESOURCES
AND SUPPORT THEM TO REMAIN
INVOLVED. MANY CAMPUSES HOWEVER
WILL NOT HIRE NEW STAFF WITH
ONE TIME FUNDING. ALSO WHILE WE
UNDERSTAND THE APPEAL OF A
BLOCK GRANT STRUCTURE WE ARE
CONCERNED THAT SUCH A QUESTION.
WOULD RESULT IN INCONSISTENT
LEVEL OF SERVICE ACROSS
CAMPUSES WHEN IT COMES TO
SERVING STUDENTS WITH THE MOST
SEVERE LEVEL OF NEED. WE WOULD
ENCOURAGE A MINIMUM STANDARD
REGARDING HOW FUNDS ARE USED TO
ADDRESS FOOD AND HOUSING
INSECURITY. FOR EXAMPLE AB
SEVEN SEVEN FIVE ASSEMBLY
MEMBER BERMAN COULD PROVIDE A
FRAMEWORK FOR WHAT THE MINIMUM
STANDARD COULD LOOK LIKE THANK
YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
MODERATOR NEXT CALL. MAXO
CAROLINA THIRTEEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. MAXIMO TELL MY IN A
LEVIN PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
MORNING SENATOR LAYERED AND
COMMITTEE MEMBERS MY NAME IS
TODD FAR RESIDENT OF CONTRA
COSTA COMMUNITY- AND IN THE SAN
FRANCISCO BAY AREA. AND I'M
APPRECIATIVE OF THE GOVERNOR'S
INCLUSION OF THE FUNDING FOR
STUDENT BASIC NEEDS I'VE SEEN
FIRSTHAND THE GREAT METER
STUDENTS HAVE AN LIMITED
RESOURCES. THAT OUR COMMUNITY
HAS AVAILABLE FOR ONGOING BASIC
NEEDS PLEASE DESIGNATE A
PORTION OF THESE BASIC NEEDS TO
FUND ON GOING TO HELP REDUCE
THE EQUITY GAPS RATHER THAN ONE
TIME ALL STUDENTS NEED ACCESS
IN OBTAINING DEGREES
CERTIFICATES AND EMPLOYABILITY
SKILLS THAT PREPARE THEM IN
ACQUIRING GAINFUL EMPLOYMENT
WITH LIVING WAGES THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH APPRECIATE
YOUR COMMENTS MODERATOR NEXT
CALLER. MAXIM TELLING SIX
PLEASE FAR. DOES YOUR LANE
COMMITTEE MEMBERS MY NAME'S
JACOB COUCHES AND I'M A STUDENT
AT AMERICAN RIVER COLLEGE IN
SACRAMENTO I WANT TO EXPRESS MY
ROOM- SUPPORT FOR A FULLY
FUNDED HE HOOKED THEM WHAT THE
OTHER PRIORITIES OUTLINED BY MY
COLLEAGUES. SPECIFICALLY WANTED
TO HIGHLIGHT 70% OF STUDENTS
WERE ENROLLED PART TIME LAST
YEAR. THIS MEANS MANY OF THEM
HAVE TO ALSO BE- WORKING PART
TIME TO SUPPORT THEIR FAMILIES
I HOPE YOU ALL RIGHT THE
REQUESTED MY COLLEAGUE THANK
YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH OUR
MODERATOR NEXT CALL. MAXIMAL
TIMELINE SIXTY ONE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD MORNING EDU
MARCHING UP TO THE CLEARLY
CALLED LINDA CALIFORNIA WE ARE
PLEASED TO THE PUBLIC HOLIDAY
INCLUDING HOW WE CAN ADDRESS
THE PEARLS ARE JOB CREATIONS
BUT ALSO LIKE THE PRESIDENT
BUSH CONSIDERATION OF
PRESERVATION SO SOMETHING ABOUT
WHAT FOR DISTRICTS. CONTAINING
ARTICLES INCREASING COSTS AND
MAKING. IT IS ARE ALSO NEXT FOR
THE LOCAL FOR FUNDAMENTAL
CHRISTIAN NEEDS OF COURSE AND
THAT WE CONTINUE TO EVALUATE
ANALYZE INTERPLAY BETWEEN STATE
AND FEDERAL COURTS ENSURE THAT
WE'RE NOT KEEPING UP WITH SOME
AREAS OF THE NUMBERS BEHIND.
THANK YOU SO MUCH. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH- MODERATOR NINE CALL.
MAXIMO LINE FIVE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HI MY NAME IS JOHANNA
AND MINE AND I WANT TO LET WITH
EXPERIENCE BASIC NEEDS OF THE
AT ALL WITH COLLEGE I WANTED
YOU FOR YOUR TIME MORNING AND
POINT OUT THE EDGE OF THE FOCAL
SERVER ENTITY IN WHICH HELPED
CALIFORNIANS AND CAL BECOMING
ECONOMIC. HOUSE AND MAINTAIN
THAT IN THE WORLD TO THIS END
I'M APPRECIATIVE OF THE
GOVERNOR INCLUDING FUNDING HAS
PROPOSAL TO ADDRESS STUDENT
BASIC NEEDS THE COMMUNITY
COLLEGES BUT I AM HERE TO
DESPERATELY REQUESTED A PORTION
OF THESE FUNDS BE DESIGNATED AS
ONGOING RATHER THAN ONE TIME TO
SPEND DOING WOULD NOT ONLY
ENSURE ACCESS. FOR STUDENTS FOR
MUCH NEEDED RESOURCES BUT ARE
ALSO ALLOWED US TO PROVIDE
STAFFING TO ENSURE A CONSISTENT
LEVEL OF SERVICE TO OUR
STUDENTS THANK YOU VERY MUCH
FOR YOUR TIME AND HAVE A GREAT
DAY THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR
YOUR CALL. OUR MODERATOR NEXT
CALLER. THANKS A LOT TIME
THIRTY. PLEASE BY. GOOD MORNING
SENATOR LAYERED AND COMMITTEE
MEMBERS THIS IS DEBBIE KLEIN
PRESIDENT OF THE FACULTY
ASSOCIATION OF THE CALIFORNIA
COMMUNITY COLLEGES WHILE WE ARE
GRATEFUL FOR MUCH OF THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSED JANUARY
BUDGET. WE ARE DISAPPOINTED TO
SEE CONTINUED FUNDING FOR
CALIBRATE THE FACULTY HAVE HAD
CONCERNS ABOUT HELD RIGHT SINCE
ITS INCEPTION. FOUR YEARS LATER
WE REMAIN DEEPLY OPPOSED AT THE
COLLEGE CONTINUES TO FAIL TO
MEET ITS PROMISES. AT A TIME
WHEN FUNDING IS LIMITED AND ALL
ONE HUNDRED AND FIFTEEN
ACCREDITED COLLEGES HAVE GONE
ONLINE IT IS AND WHY IS TO
CONTINUE INVESTING IN UNPROVEN
INSTITUTION SERVING ONLY FIVE
HUNDRED STUDENTS. IN HER RECENT
BOOK DIANE RAVITCH DOCUMENTS
THE DECADES OF FAILURES OF THE
SO CALLED EDUCATION REFORMERS
INCLUDING THE VERY FOUNDATIONS
CURRENTLY FUNDING CALIBRATE.
CALIBRATE IS EMBLEMATIC OF THIS
FAILED REFORM MOVEMENT. I
FACULTY CONTINUE TO TEACH
ONLINE DURING THE PANDEMIC AND
BEYOND PLEASE RE DIRECT
RESOURCES TO THE ONE HUNDRED
AND FIFTEEN COLLEGES SERVING
OVER 99% OF OUR STUDENTS. MORE
FULL TIME FACULTY POSITIONS
PROFESSIONAL DEVELOPMENT AND
PART TIME FACULTY SUPPORT ARE
DESPERATELY NEEDED TO ENSURE
THAT ALL STUDENTS HAVE
EQUITABLE ACCESS TO
OPPORTUNITIES TO ACHIEVE THEIR
GOALS. THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY
MUCH OUR MODERATOR NEXT CALL.
MAXIMAL TO LINE TWENTY PLEASE
CALL I HAD. GOOD MORNING
STEPHANIE GOLDMAN ON BEHALF OF
THE FACULTY ASSOCIATION OF THE
CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY COLLEGES.
WE APPRECIATE THE PROPOSED PAID
OUT OF THE WORLD FOOTBALL'S THE
FUNDING FOR STUDENT NEEDS AND
THE PROFESSIONAL DEVELOPMENT
FUNDING AND WROTE THE GRATEFUL
FOR A CALL UP BUT WE BELIEVE IT
SHOULD MATCH THE THREE POINT
84% COLA THAT THE K. TWELVE
MATH FOR CULTURE. THE ARE THERE
MORE THE COALITION. BE
CONDEMNED ON INCREASE AND
AUGMENTATION POLITICS. A
UNDERMINE THE PURPOSE OF THE
CALL- WHICH MAINTAIN PURCHASING.
WE CONTINUE TO BELIEVE THE
STUDENT CENTERED FUNDING
FORMULAS NOT BENEFITING OUR
COLLEGES. OF THE RESULT THE
WHOLE HARLEM HOME HARMLESS
DIVISION NEEDS TO BE EXTENDED
ONCE AGAIN IN THE- BUDGET TO
PREVENT. INTO HARDSHIP. MANY OF
OUR COLLEGES. FORWARD TO
WORKING WITH YOU THROUGHOUT THE
BUDGET THANK ACCORDING TO
QUALITY ANDERSON. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH A MODERATE
NEXT. MAXIMO CAROLINE THIRTY
PLEASE GO AHEAD. THE MORNING
CARE LAYERED AND COMMITTEE
MEMBERS I WOULD LIKE TO
REITERATE THE IMPORTANCE TO
INCLUDE PARKING STAMPS THERE IS
DEMAND MY DUTY GRAHAM THAT IT
DISREGARDS THE NEEDS OF PART
TIME STUDENTS IS IT IN JUST FOR
THE RECORD COULD YOU STATE YOUR
NAME PLEASE. MY NAME IS CRYSTAL
I AM AS IN AND AT THE END THAT
COMMUNITY COLLEGE THANK YOU- OF
COURSE SHARE THIS RECORD IN THE
DRY THE NEED A PART TIME
STUDENT AS CHAIR BY THAT
BECAUSE- STUDENTS OF THEIR
EDUCATION HOW ARE LIMITED BY
THEIR FINANCES. MAGS I WANT
THAT TALK ABOUT THE BASICS PLAN
AND HOW I THINK SHOULD BE AN ON
INVESTMENT- BECAUSE THERE IS AN
ONGOING NEED THIS IS AN
INVESTMENT THAT WILL PROVIDE
BETTER OPPORTUNITIES FOR
STUDENTS. WHO ARE ALREADY AT A
FINANCIAL DISADVANTAGE WHERE
JACK- WHERE DIRECTLY AFFECTS
THEIR STUDENT SUCCESS AS A
STUDENT. I NEED FOR A BASIC
NEED FUNDING IS NOT AN ISSUE
THAT AS A CONSEQUENCE AS
CATHOLIC COBIT NINETEEN
PANDEMIC BUT RATHER IS AN ISSUE
THAT HAS BEEN BROUGHT TO THE
LIGHT BECAUSE OF IT. YOUR IDEA
DIDN'T EXIST WITH THEM ARE
PEOPLE OF COLOR AND THEY NEED
OUR SUPPORT TO CREATE MORE
OPPORTUNITIES FOR THEM THANK
YOU THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
MODERATOR NEXT CALL. NEXT ONE
MORE KILLING THIRTY TWO PLEASE
AHEAD. HELLO JERRY LEARN AND
COME MEMBER MY NAME IS KHAN
PASSED AND I AM A STUDENT AT
THE COLLEGE IN CUPERTINO
CALIFORNIA ACCORDING TO A STUDY
CONDUCTED BY THE AMERICAN
COLLEGE HEALTH ASSOCIATION
PUBLISHED IN THE U. S. NATIONAL
LIBRARY OF MEDICINE INTO
IDENTIFIED AS ASIAN OR PACIFIC
ISLANDERS MULTI RACIAL AND
HISPANIC WERE MORE LIKELY TO
REPORT FEELINGS OF HOPELESSNESS
DEPRESSION AND ULTIMATELY HAD
MORE SUICIDAL IDEATIONS THE
OTHER ETHNICITY. BUT MAJORITY
OF THE STUDENTS THAT THE AND
THE COLLEGE BEING ASIAN AND
HISPANIC RESPECTFULLY AND WITH
70% OF STUDENTS BEING ENROLLED
PART TIME LAST FALL DUE TO
NEEDING TO WORK PART TIME AND
WITH MYSELF PERSONALLY BEING A
PART TIME MULTI RACIAL PACIFIC
ISLANDER STUDENT WHO HAS TAKEN
ADVANTAGE OF MANY SUPPORT
SERVICES I WOULD SURELY HOPE
THAT WOULD BE CONTINUAL FUNDING
PROVIDED FOR STUDENTS THAT ARE
IN NEED. REGARDLESS OF THEIR
AVAILABILITY OF EDUCATION DUE
TO OBLIGATIONS OUT OF THEIR
CONTROL AND THE PERSONAL
ADVISORS ESPECIALLY GIVEN THE
RECENT PANDEMIC. THANK YOU
VERY. MUCH THANK YOU VERY MUCH-
MODERATOR NECK CALL. NEXT THE
MOST FIFTY ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
ONE FIFTY ONE YOU MAY BE NEEDED.
HI THERE. ALL RIGHT THANK YOU
SO MUCH. THIS IS FANTA EDWARDS
AND I WORK AT THE COLLEGE UP IN
NORTHERN CALIFORNIA I'M
SPEAKING IN SUPPORT OF THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL TO ADDRESS
STUDENT BASIC NEEDS I'D LIKE TO
ECHO WHAT OTHERS HAVE SAID. AND
SAY THAT I WOULD LIKE YES BY
FUNDING TO BE ONGOING IF YOU
COLLEGE I THE FIRST HAND THAT
THE BEER STUDENT NAME STUDENT
BASIC NEEDS HAVE BEEN
EXACERBATED BY THE PANDEMIC AND
I NEED A LONG TERM FINANCIAL
COMMITMENT THANK YOU SO MUCH
THANK YOU VERY MUCH WE
APPRECIATE YOUR COMMENTS. A
MODERATOR NEXT CALLER. MAXIM
CALLING FORTY NINE GO AHEAD.
HELLO THIS YEAR LATER IN
COMMITTEE MEMBERS MY NAME IS
DORADO CHAVEZ AND I AM A
STUDENT AT RIVERSIDE CITY
COLLEGE. RIGHT LOWER TUITION
COSTS COMPARED TO USING THE
ZERO ZERO IT COST MORE TO CALL
THE COPS. FOR LOW INCOME TO
ATTEND A UC AND CSU CAN A CALL.
THE STATUS I'M HAVING THE
HIGHER UNIT COSTS AND.
COMPOUNDED BY THE THAT ALTHOUGH
HALF OF ALL COMMUNITY COLLEGE
TO NEED LOW IN STAND DIVERSE
PEOPLE IN TUITION AND WHERE ALL
ABOUT FIVE PER RECEIVE A COPY.
UNDER NEEDS STRUCTURE THE
CHARACTER USE AND ANKLE AND
BERIA'S EACH EACH TIME OUT OF
SCHOOL IN G. TO CALIFORNIA FROM
ACCESSING HIGHER. WE NEED A K.
PUT BY COULD READ AND- ALL LOW
INCOME COMMUNICATIONS THANK.
YOU THANK YOU VERY MUCH MISSED
MODEL NEXT CALL. IMAXTREE TO
LINE TWENTY TWO PLEASE CALL.
GREAT CAN YOU ALL HEAR ME YES
JUST FINE. HELLO MY NAME IS MY
BILL AND MELINDA AND JIM
FLASHPOINT FOR THE BIG COLLEGE-
I WANT TO GO THE OTHERS WHO
HAVE- STATED THAT WE WOULD LIKE
TO- ABSOLUTE UNIT BASICALLY.
FUNDING ONGOING THAN ONE TIME I
WENT DIRECTLY WILL THE PROGRAM
THROUGH THE COURTS STUDENTS WHO
ARE. OR HOW DO INSECURE ARE NOT.
IMPORTANT THAT HAVING FUNDING
TO BE I'M GOING TO GO TO
SUPPORT THE- THANK YOU. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. OUR MODERATOR
NEXT CALL. NEXT TO THE MOTEL
FOR SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD. GREAT
MORNING LEE AND COMMITTEE NOT
MY IS ANGELICA. AND I'M WITH
YOU AT THE CALL REFERENCE OF- A
TO THE HEALTH YOU KNOW
COMMISSION BASED NEEDS TALENT
ARE DIRE SO MANY. AND THEN THEN
MORE THAN SEVEN I OF TEN
O'CLOCK SOME OR ALL OF THE
INCOME TO THE CO NINETY. AS
BASIC NEEDS AND SECURITY GUY
ROCK. HOT BUTTON BEEN
DESTRUCTIVE EFFECT AND ROMAN
DUMB THAN 20% I YOU TO COLLEGES.
AND 10% EIGHT WELL ONE TIME FOR
A GREAT WE NEED GOING FOR NEEDS
ARE THAT OLD. THIS CRISIS AND
THE LONG RUN. I I'M GOING
FUNDING FOR NEEDS IS A GOOD
INVESTMENT BECAUSE THE FUNDS
ARE DONE LEVERAGE TO THE
STUDENT GAIN ACCESS TO FEDERAL
FINANCIAL AID ALFRESCO A BIT.
MEDICAL FAIRLY HOUSING
OPPORTUNITIES AND MORE CREATING
A SIGNET DIP AND- OUR DESPITE A
LOW JEWISH. COSTS ACCORDING YOU
I MEAN COULD TO IF YOU A CALL
MORE FOR LOW INCOME STUDENTS TO
ATTEND IF YOU YOU ARE SEE THAT
I CAN CALLED. LEADING TO THIS
STATUS HAVING THE HIGH THAT
CAUGHT THE TEN. DISAFFECTED
COMP BY THE BY THAT ALL DO
NEARLY HALF WHILE A CALL
STUDENT NEAT THE LOWER STANDARD
RECEIVE. TUITION AND FEE WAIVER
ONLY FIVE PER WITH THE LOOK
GRANT. THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. MODERATOR NEXT CALL. THE
ACTION TO SAVE ENOUGH DALY HOW
ABOUT ONE LEFT IN QUEUE WILL
NOT MOVE TO A FOR TWO. HI MY
NAME IS PAM FLEMING I WERE AT
THE CALL MOSCOW CALLED IN DIEGO
CA. AND I TO WEAR STAY THE
BASIC NEEDS BECAUSE- ARE. KERR
THEY WORK WITH HOMELESS STUDENT
STUDENTS TO RAISING OUR- AND
POPPED YOU. AND THEIR NEEDS AND
MANY OTHERS. THEY DON'T GO WITH
THERE'S A PAY. OR NOT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY APPRECIATE YOUR
COMMON MODERATOR NEXT CALLER.
IN MAXIMO TO FOR. PLEASE GO
AHEAD. NINE SIXTEEN YOU MAY BE
NEEDED. MAXIMO TIMELINE FIFTY
EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO MY
NAME IS DARCY CORWIN AND THE
LEAD OF THE BOMB A PANTRY BASIC
NEEDS PROGRAM LOS ANGELES YOUR
COLLEGE WHERE I PROVIDE
STUDENTS WITH PROGRAMMING AND
RESOURCES WHICH INCLUDE HOUSING
CASE MANAGEMENT SERVICES HE
DIDN'T BASIC NEEDS TO COME.
THAT AND AS MANY OTHER BAD
WHILE WE APPRECIATE THE FUNDING
INCLUDED IN THE GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET PROPOSAL TO ADDRESS
BASIC NEEDS ARE COLLEGES NEED
ONGOING FUNDING RATHER THAN ONE
TIME FUNDS BECAUSE BASIC NEEDS
SERVICES ARE VITAL. OVERCOME
SOCIOECONOMIC BARRIERS AND
SYSTEMIC INEQUITIES IN THE WAY
OF THEIR PERSONAL PROFESSIONAL
AND ACADEMIC ACHIEVEMENT SO I'M
GOING FUNDING WILL ALLOW US TO
BETTER SERVE OUR COMMUNITY AND
MAKE MEANINGFUL AND LONG TERM
IMPACT. ON JUNE FIVE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. MONTEREY
AND CALL. MAXIMO THIRTY PLEASED
AHEAD. BLIND FOUR YEAR LINE IS
OPEN. HE A YES WE CAN. GOOD
MORNING TURN MEMBERS DAVID NOW
BEEN ON BEHALF OF SANTA MONICA
COMMUNITY COLLEGE DISTRICT- WE
SUBMITTED A LETTER OUTLINING
OUR MAIN PRIORITIES NO I JUST
LIKE TO HIGHLIGHT A FEW. WE DO
SUPPORT AN ADDITIONAL COLA
REFLECTING COST INCREASES FOR
THE TWENTY TWENTY TWENTY TWENTY
ONE FISCAL YEAR AS WELL AS
ADDITIONAL PAY DOWNS OF ANY
APPORTIONMENT OF FOR ALL THAT
STILL REMAIN. AND WE AND
FINALLY WE DO SUPPORT GIVING
DISTRICTS THE FLEXIBILITY FOR
COURSE REPEATABILITY POLICIES
FOR UP 25% OF ANNUAL COURSE
OFFERINGS. AND ONCE AGAIN THE
REST OF OUR REQUESTS ARE
DETAILED IN THE LETTER THAT WE
SUBMITTED TO THE COMMITTEE
THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
WE APPRECIATE BOTH THE LETTER
AND YOUR COMMENTS. A MODERATOR
NEXT CALL. MAXTOR MOTEL LINE
TWENTY FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD MORNING SURE LAYERED
COMMITTEE MEMBERS MANY
RODRIGUEZ OF THE APPLICATION
TRUST WEST RECORDED WITH THE
TOO EARLY ACTION PROPOSALS YOU
DISCUSS TODAY ON THE EMERGENCY
GRANTS WE ALIGN OURSELVES WITH
THE CHANCELLOR'S OFFICE AND
THEIR DESIRE FOR FLEXIBILITY IN
PRIOR TRANSITION OF STUDENTS
WITH THE HIGHEST NEEDS. UP TO
THE STUDENT RETENTION AND
RECRUITMENT GREEN CAGE AND
DOLLARS WE APPRECIATE THOSE
FUNDS BEING APPROPRIATED FOR
THOSE ACTIVITIES IN ASK THE
LEGISLATURE THE CHANCELLOR'S
OFFICE- TO ISSUE GUIDANCE ABOUT
EVIDENCE BASED WILL MEET
RETENTION. STRATEGIES COLLEGES
CAN IMPLEMENT. WE SUPPORT BE
NEEDS. IN YOU KNOW OUR
COMMUNITY CALL. HAVE BEEN HARD
BY AND YOUR SESSION. BUT WE DO
NEED TO. A PART OF THIS ON
GOING OVER AT LEAST HAVE TO. ON
THE SERVICES. ON MANTA HEALTH
AND DIGITAL TO YOUR- THE SCHOOL
INVESTMENT- WE ARE LARGELY TO
DO TO WILL BE FROM ONE. I GUY
ON HOW THESE ONE SHOULD BE. TO
DEVELOP. TO MAKE SURE THAT THE
DOLLARS ARE HELPING. DIRECTLY
WHETHER GOING TO THE PANDEMIC
AND THE DIGITAL AND FACING THE.
DIGITAL WE SUPPORT THE IN ALL
ON MY- AND THOSE OVER YOUR TAX
THE COST AND IN. MATERIALS FOR
ALL THE YOU. THANK YOU VERY.
OUR MODERATOR NEXT CALLER. IN
MAXIMO SIXTY SEVEN PLEASED
AHEAD. THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
MEMBERS THIS IS TOM LORD WITH
THE CALIFORNIA SCHOOL EMPLOYEES
ASSOCIATION REPRESENTING NEARLY
A QUARTER MILLION CLASSIFIED
SCHOOL EMPLOYEES IN BOTH K.
TWELVE AND COMMUNITY COLLEGES.
SHANK THAT THE GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET PROPOSAL PROVIDES A ONE
AND A HALF PERCENT COLLEGIATE
IT DIDN'T CENTER FUNDING
FORMULA HOWEVER WE URGE THE
LEGISLATURE AND THE GOVERNOR TO
ALSO PROVIDE THE SAME
COMPOUNDED THREE POINT 84% COLA
HE COMMUNITY COLLEGES TO BE
CONSISTENT WITH THE- HOLIDAYS
PROVIDED TO K. TWELVE. WE ALSO
URGE A COMMENSURATE AMOUNT OF
PROFESSIONAL DEVELOPMENT
FUNDING FOR OUR CLASS EIGHT
PROFESSIONAL MUCH OF THE NEW
PROFESSIONAL DEVELOPMENT
FUNDING IN THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSAL IS GEARED TOWARDS
TEACHERS AND FACULTY ARE
CLASSIFIED PROFESSIONALS ALSO
SUPPORTS STUDENTS WITH IT IS
FINDING AND DESERVE TO RECEIVE
TRAINING ON THE LATEST
DEVELOPMENTS. AND BEST
PRACTICES IN THE FIELD THANK
YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH. A
MODERATOR NEXT CALLER. MAX TO
FOR EAST. PLEASE GO AHEAD.
MISTER CHAIRMAN MATH TEACHER
THE SYSTEM FOUND THE OF THE
COLLEGE OF CO. THE PCS THE
RESPECT REQUEST THAT FIVE
MILLION OF THE BASIC NEEDS
PROPOSAL BE DESIGNATED TO
SUPPORT PLANNING AND
FEASIBILITY STUDIES FOR
COMMUNITY COLLEGE STUDENT
HOUSING PROJECTS. YLIDES
STUDIES CAN COST APPROXIMATELY
A HUNDRED THOUSAND DOLLARS AND
COLLEGES DON'T HAVE SPECIFIC
FUNDING SOURCES TO COVER THESE
COSTS. WELL COLLEGES MAY KNOW
THAT THEIR STUDENTS FACE
HOUSING INSECURITY THEY NEED TO
PERFORM IN DEPTH FINANCIAL AND
MARKET ANALYSIS TO ASSESS IF
THEY HAVE A VIABLE PROJECT. TO
SEE IF HE RECOMMENDS OF THESE
FUNDS BE AVAILABLE FOR
FEASIBILITY STUDIES AS WELL AS
OTHER PLANNING AND PRE
CONSTRUCTION SERVICES THIS
WOULD ALLOW THE LEGISLATURE AND
THE GOVERNOR TO USE THESE ONE
TIME FUNDS. IN A WAY THAT
PROVIDES AN ONGOING BENEFIT TO
STUDENTS. LAST YEAR 35% OF
CALIFORNIA'S COMMUNITY COLLEGE
STUDENTS REPORTED EXPERIENCING
HOUSING INSECURITY AND
HOMELESSNESS. WE RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST YOUR SUPPORT OF THIS
PROPOSAL THANK YOU. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH CHAU MODERATOR NEXT
CALLER. MAXIMO TO LINE SIXTY
NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
MORNING LAURA BARBECUE THAT
FROM THE INSTITUTE FOR COLLEGE
ACCESS AND SUCCESS THE HIGHER
EDUCATION RESEARCH POLICY AND
ADVOCACY ORGANIZATION WE URGE
YOUR SUPPORT OF THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSAL TO PROVIDE A HUNDRED
MILLION DOLLARS IN EARLY ACTION
EMERGENCY FINANCIAL AID FOR
COMMUNITY COLLEGE STUDENTS AND
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST THAT YOU
REMOVE ELIGIBILITY LIMITATIONS
RELATED TO STUDENT FULL TIME
ENROLLMENT OR EMPLOYMENT PAST
OR FUTURE WHICH COULD EXCLUDE
MANY STUDENTS STRUGGLING WITH
UNEXPECTED COSTS AND BASICALLY.
ENSURING YOU CRITICAL RESOURCES
CAN BE DEPLOYED MILLION
EFFICIENTLY. IS KEY TO
SUPPORTING VULNERABLE STUDENTS
ABILITY TO ENROLL OR REMAIN
ENROLLED IN HAVE THEIR BASIC
NEEDS MET THAT THEY CAN BE
SUCCESSFUL. STUDENT MAY WANT TO
ATTEND FULL TIME THEY MAY BE
UNABLE TO DO SO FOR A VARIETY
OF REASONS INCLUDING WORK
FAMILY AND OTHER
RESPONSIBILITIES ONLY BEEN THAT
MAGNIFIED BY THE PANDEMIC.
ADDITIONALLY LOW INCOME
COMMUNITIES AND COMMUNITIES OF
COLOR HAVE BEEN MOST IMPACTED
BY ON AN UNDEREMPLOYMENT DURING
THE ON GOING RIGHT THAT SHE TO
REALIZE EMERGENCY AID SPOKE
ATTENTION ON SUPPORTING
STUDENTS RESPECTFULLY URGE YOU
TO SUPPORT EARLY ACTION WITHOUT
ANY BARRIERS TO INTERCEDE.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR
CONSIDERATION THANK YOU VERY
MUCH FOR YOUR COMMENTS. A
MODERATOR NEXT CALLER. THANKS
CAL MAIN TEAM CALL HAD. GOOD
MORNING THIS IS DANIELLE ONE
DRAW WITH CHILDREN NOW WE
REALLY APPRECIATE THAT THE
GOVERNOR INCLUDED FUNDING IN
HIS PROPOSED BUDGET FOR
STUDENTS BASIC NEEDS THAT
COMMUNITY COLLEGES THIS FUNDING
IS CRITICAL FOR SO MANY
STUDENTS WHO ARE STRUGGLING
INCLUDING STUDENTS CURRENTLY OR
FORMERLY IN FOSTER CARE WHO
FACE SIGNIFICANT BARRIERS TO
COLLEGE SUCCESS BEFORE COATED
NINETEEN THAT HAVE ONLY BEEN
EXACERBATED BY THE PANDEMIC. WE
WANT TO ENSURE THAT THE
SUPPORTIVE STABLE GOING FORWARD
SO I GOING WHAT OTHERS HAVE
MENTIONED WE ASK THAT MORE OF
THE FUNDING FOR STUDENT BASIC
NEEDS TO BE DESIGNATED AS
ONGOING FUNDS RATHER THAN ONE
TIME FIND. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH A MODERATOR NEXT CALL.
MAXIMO CAROLINE FORTY FOUR
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD MORNING
CHERYL COMMITTEE MEMBERS MY
NAME IS MEGAN BARBERA AND I AM-A STUDENT AT THE AMBER I WANTED
TO EXPRESS MY SUPPORT FOR A
FULLY FUNDED CALIFORNIA
COMMUNITY COLLEGE SYSTEM AND I
APPRECIATE. YOU CREATION FOR
EARLY ACTION OF EMERGENCY GRANT
ANY OTHER. PRIORITIES THE
GOVERNOR SAID IN HIS BUDGET
HOWEVER I DO THINK THAT SOME OF
THE PROPOSALS MAY BE MODIFIED.
MYSELF THE NEARLY 70% OF OTHER
STUDENTS WERE ENROLLED PART
TIME LAST FALL DUE TO MEETING
TO WORK PART TIME AND SUPPORT
OUR FAMILIES. FOR PROPOSED.
BARRIERS FOR MUNCHING WILL LOCK
OUT MOST OF THE STUDENT MYSELF.
FROM RECEIVING CRITICAL AID AND
PART TIME STUDENTS DON'T HAVE
PART TIME NEEDS WE ALSO HAVE
BOTH PARTIES I ALSO BELIEVE.
THAT BASICALLY NEED NEEDS
FUNDING SHOULD BE ONGOING
INVESTMENT. ARM TO SUPPORT. ON
GOING NEED THANK YOU VERY MUCH
FOR YOUR TIME. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH A MODERATOR NEXT CALLER.
NEXT ALMOST LINE SEVENTY TWO
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI CHAIRMAN
LAYERED. THE COMMITTEE
APPRECIATE YOUR PATIENCE AND
STAMINA THIS MORNING MY NAME IS
LARRY BELIEVE ZERO ON THERE
PRESIDENT AND CEO OF THE
COMMUNITY COLLEGE LEAGUE OF
CALIFORNIA. AND THE NECESSARY
CONDITION OF AN EFFECTIVE
STRATEGIC INVESTMENT IN OUR
COMMUNITY COLLEGES. IMPORTANT
FAR MORE EQUITABLE RECOVERY AN
ECONOMY. MUST INCLUDE MAXIMUM
MAXIMIZING FLEXIBLE BASE
RESOURCES TO COMPLEMENT THE
CRITICAL AID STUDENTS WHO'VE
BEEN DISPROPORTIONATELY
IMPACTED BY THE PANDEMIC AND
THE RECESSION. REDIRECTING
ONGOING RESOURCES PROPOSED IN
THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET AND OR
INVESTING NEW RESOURCES SHOULD
BECOME AVAILABLE THE MARY
BISHEH. IS REALLY ESSENTIAL TO
CONFRONT THE SUBSTANTIAL
INCREASES. IN COSTS HEALTHCARE
PENSION OBLIGATIONS EMPLOYEE
COMPENSATION. AND ALSO TO
MAINTAIN OUR COLLEGES CAPACITY
TO EDUCATE YOUR CENTRAL WORK
FORCE TO CONFRONT THE PANDEMIC
AND ITS AFTERMATH. ALSO TO
PROVIDE AFFORDABLE QUALITY
TRANSFER EDUCATION AND TO OFFER
EDUCATIONAL CAREER
OPPORTUNITIES TO THE MOST
UNDERSERVED CALIFORNIANS AND
THEIR FAMILIES. LOOK FORWARD TO
WORKING WITH YOU THROUGHOUT THE
SESSION. THANK YOU VERY MUCH WE
APPRECIATE YOUR COMMENTS THE
MODERATOR NEXT CALLER. MAXIMO
TIMELINE SEVENTY THREE PLEASE
GO AHEAD. HI GOOD MORNING
THOUSAND DOLLARS ON THE HOUSE
WHAT YOU'RE A COMMUNITY COLLEGE
DISTRICT. WAS ROSA PARKS THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET PROPOSAL FOR
THE ONE POINT FIVE COST OF
LIVING ADJUSTMENT FOR THE
TWENTY TWENTY ONE TWENTY TWO
YEAR LAST YEAR COMMUNITY
COLLEGE THAT ARE THE LOCAL
LANGUAGE BUT A STRAIN ON THE
DISTRICT'S BUDGET TRYING TO
ADDRESS THE CONSEQUENCES. OF
THE COVER NINETEEN PANDEMIC.
WORKING DOWN THE COMMUNITY. TO
THE DISTRICTS ARE ALSO. SUPPORT
AND A- AT BERKELEY CA DOWN THE-
DEFER ALL BALLOT TEMPER THE
DISTRICTS. PASSION JEWISH SO
MAKE SURE TERM BORROWING COSTS.
WHAT YOU'RE SUPPORT THE GENERAL
USE OF GENERAL FUND TO REDUCE
HEALTHCARE CAN HELP. THEM
CONTRIBUTION RIGHT THE PROPOSAL
REDUCES LONG TERM LIABILITY.
AND BOTH STATE PENSION FUNDS
AND PROVIDES DISTRICTS WITH
ABILITY TO FREE UP THEIR
OPERATING FUNDS TO ADDRESS
OTHER CRITICAL NEED IN THE
BUDGET. OTHER PRIORITIES
INCLUDE SUPPORTING EXPANDING
CAL GRANT AND STREAMLINING. THE
TRANSFER PROCESS FOR. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY- NO CALL. AND I
MOVES ONLINE SEVENTY EIGHT
PLEASE GO AHEAD. I HARD WITH A
COW TEACHERS ASSOCIATION AND
PTA APPRECIATE MANY OF THE
PROPOSED INVESTMENT FOR
COMMUNITY COLLEGES- WE ASK THE
LEGISLATURE TO PROVIDE THAT
COMPOUNDED THREE POINT EIGHT
CRITICAL OPPORTUNITY COLLEGES
GIVEN THAT AND THE CODE NOT
PROVIDED LAST YEAR.
ADDITIONALLY TJ OR DID THE
LEGISLATURE TO INCREASE
INVESTMENT PART TIME FACULTY
SUPPORT THE TYPICALLY YOU ARE
ASKING FOR AN ADDITIONAL
FIFTEEN MILLION ONGOING FUNDING
FOR A PART TIME FACULTY AND
CATEGORICAL PROGRAM THANK YOU
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR YOUR
COMMENTS. OUR MODERATOR NEXT
CALLER. MAXIM TELLING SEVENTY
PLEASE GO AHEAD. LAYERED
COMMITTEE MEMBERS MY NAME IS
PHILIP KIM I'M TODAY SPEAKING
ON BEHALF OF DR GARY MICHELSON
AND MICHAEL SINCE OUR PUBLIC
POLICY IN SUPPORT OF GOVERNOR
NUISANCE PROPOSED FIFTEEN
MILLION DOLLAR ALLOCATION FOR
THE ZERO TEXTBOOK COST DEGREE
PROGRAM. I APPRECIATE THE
EARLIER COMMENT ON THIS ITEM
FROM THE ELIO WITH REGARD TO
THE NEED FOR IMPACT METRICS ON
THE FIRST TWENTY SIXTEEN DPC
ALLOCATION. I THINK THE CHANCES
OFFICE FROM VOICING THEIR
SUPPORT IN THIS MATTER. I
WANTED THE SERVICE IF YOU DATA
POINTS FROM THE TECHNICAL LEAD
TO HELP COORDINATE AND
IMPLEMENT THE FIRST SIXTY FIFTH
PROGRAM. METRICS THAT WILL
HOPEFULLY BE EXPANDED UPON IN
THE REPORT FROM THE
CHANCELLOR'S OFFICE. FIVE
MILLION DOLLARS FOR EACH PC
PROGRAMS IN TWENTY SIXTEEN
ALLOWED TWENTY THREE COLLEGES
THE BILL 34 DEGREES OR
CERTIFICATE PATHWAYS WHICH WERE
ENTIRELY FREE OF A TACKLE COST.
IT WAS AN UNQUALIFIED SUCCESS
SAVING STUDENTS MORE THAN FORTY
TWO MILLION DOLLARS I'M MORE
THAN EIGHT X. RETURN ON
INVESTMENT FOR THE STATE TO BE
ON TV MONEY STUDENTS ENROLLED
IN THE EASY PROGRAMS PERFORMED
MARKEDLY BETTER IN THEIR
CLASSES. IN OUR VIEW OF OVER A
HUNDRED AND SEVENTY NINE
THOUSAND LETTER GRADES THE
PROGRAM ISSUED A THREE POINT
ONE INCREASE. 4% INCREASE FOR
THE PC STUDENTS COMPARED TO NON
GAAP STUDENTS. HELLO RECIPIENTS
ON EVEN GREATER SEVEN POINT 6%
RATE INCREASE IN DTC PATHWAYS
COMPARED TO NON GAAP SEEK HELP
COUNTERPARTS. IN ADDITION
MINORITY- I DON'T FOR A MINUTE
SO YOU FOR COM. A MODERN LET'S
TO THE CALL. IN MAXIMO TIME
FORTY PLEASE BY. GOOD MORNING
CARE LAYERED AND- MY NAME IS
MADHU KAKA NINE THANK YOU HE
HAD CARE NEXT COORDINATOR OPEN
LIKE COLLEGE THANK YOU FOR YOUR
CONTINUED- WORK ON CREATING A
BUDGET THAT INCREASES
INVESTMENT IN CALIFORNIA'S MOST
MARGINALIZED STUDENTS I
APPRECIATE THE LEGISLATURE
CONTINUED SUPPORT AND EVEN YES
AND THE GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL OF
THE COLON FOR A PROGRAM. THAT
MEANS THAT OUR PROGRAM NEEDS
YOUR SUPPORT TO BETTER SERVE
YOU CAN'T WHO HAVE BEEN
DISPROPORTIONATELY IMPACTED BY
CO THAT WE'RE REQUESTING THIRTY
MILLION IN ONE TIME FUNDING FOR
ETHIOPIA FINANCIAL AID GRANTS
TO ENSURE WE CAN CONTINUE
PROVIDING DIRECT AND EQUITABLE
ASSISTANCE TO CALIFORNIA
DISPONIBLE STUDENTS.
ADDITIONALLY WE ARE ASKING FOR
ELEVEN POINT SIX MILLION ONE
TIME FUNDING FOR THE DREAM
RESOURCE LIAISON PROGRAM
CREATED BY AB SIXTEEN FORTY
FIVE ONE NOT EVERY COLLEGE IN
PLACE THE PROGRAM WITHIN
ETHIOPIA THOSE THAT HAVE ARE
UNDERFUNDED. AND NEED
ADDITIONAL RESOURCES. THANK YOU
FOR YOUR CONTINUED SUPPORT OF
OUR GUESTS. IMPACTED STUDENTS
AND HAVE A LOVELY. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH WE APPRECIATE YOUR
COMMENTS. OUR MODERATOR NEXT
CALL. IN MAXIMO TO LINE FORTY
EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO
YES WE CAN WE CAN THE- HELLO MY
NAME IS HANNAH AND I AM AT THE
END OF TWO THEN I WOULD JUST
REPORTS BOOK PART OF BEFORE THE-
CALIFORNIA- COME. FROM COLLEGE
WITH THEM. AND THE- FOR EARLY
MY BE GRANTED. WITH HE COUGHED
SMOKE AT SOME OF WHEN HEALTH
AND WE- ALL THESE ARE CRITICAL.
FAR COME. COMMUNITY STUDENTS
OUR SOME OF THE OF. MUST BE
MODIFIED. M. SIMPSONS WERE LOW
PARK AND THAT FOR YOU NEED ANY
TO WORK PART TIME THIS YOUR
FAMILY. POSTED SHOULD BE. BE
VERY FOR THEM THE MERCY GRAN SO
LOCKED UP MOST OF THE STUDENTS
FROM THE CRITICAL. PART OF THE
BILL HAVE OUR A NEED. NEXT WEEK
NEED FUNDING TO THE ONGOING
SUPPORT AND ON GOING.
ADDITIONALLY CROPS FIFTY CLEAR
AND NIELSEN A. WATCH FOR SURE
YOUR COMMENTS MODERATOR NEXT
CALLER. ADVIL MOTRIN EIGHT LINE
EIGHTY THREE CRITICAL I HAD.
GOOD MORNING MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS ARE NOT ABOUT OTHER
WITH THE CALIFORNIA COALITION
HERE IN STRONG SUPPORT OF THE
AMERICAN V. EIGHT GRAND TOTAL
THAT WILL ASSIST COMMUNITY
COLLEGE STUDENT COMMUNITY
COLLEGES ARE THE MOST DIVERSE
STUDENT POPULATION INCLUDING
ADULT LEARNERS WHO HAVE BEEN
SEVERELY IMPACTED BY THE
PANDEMIC HAVE LOST THEIR JOBS
AND I WANTED TO RETURN TO A
COMMUNITY COLLEGE TO RETRAIN
AND UPSKILL IN ORDER TO RE
ENTER THE WORKFORCE. THIS
FUNDING IT'S CRITICAL PER
STUDENT ECONOMIC MOBILITY
INCLUDING FUNDING FOR BASIC
NEEDS WHICH WILL HELP STUDENTS
COMPLETE THEIR PROGRAMS WE ALSO
LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING WITH
THE COMMITTEE AND OUR PARTNERS
ON THE WORK. I AS THESE ARE AND-
FOR TWO. ECONOMIC RICK. THANK
YOU SO MUCH. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH FOR YOUR COMMENTS
MODERATOR NEXT CALLER. NEXT A
MOTEL LINE EIGHTY FOUR PLEASE
GO AHEAD. THE- SHE WAS TALKING
WITH THE ASSOCIATION FOR
AMERICAN PUBLISHERS I WOULD
LEARN MORE EXPRESSED SUPPORT
FOR THE LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S
RECOMMENDATION TO SUBMIT THE
EVALUATION- ON THE GENERAL TAB
COSTED ME STUDY- THAT- THAT.
WOULD BE. BUT WE JUST WANTED.
ALSO POINT OUT- OVER THE PAST
SIX YEARS HAS BEEN A IN.
SPENDING ON COURSE WHICH- A
STUDENT WALKS FOUND THAT THIRTY
FIVE PER DROP IN STUDENT AND
OVER THE PAST SIX YEARS. THE
DALLAS BASED ON A SURVEY OF
MORE THAN FOURTEEN THOUSAND.
ACROSS FIVE. COLLEGES IT WAS
ALSO A SIR TEAMS MOM WHICH- A
THIRTY NINE PER DECLINE IN
STUDENTS THANK YOU DON'T IN
COURSE MATURE OF THE SIX YEARS.
THAT WAS BASED ON A CAR ONE A
ONE. THIRTY OF NIGHT AND CAMPUS
IN CAN ALONG FOR FULL TIME
UNDER. AT NINETY THREE TO BE OF
COURSE. THANK YOU THANK VERY
MUCH WE YOUR COMMENTS ON MY NAY
CALL. MAXIMO LINE ET SIX PLEASE
GO AHEAD. MAXIMAL TWO ONE
NINETY TWO PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HELLO MY NAME IS. WELL I HAD
LEASE CONTINUE. THANK YOU-
CHERYL ARE MY NAME IS INTERNET
CANS AND I'M THE VICE PRESIDENT
OF LEGISLATIVE AFFAIRS FOR THE
STUDENT CENTER FOR CALIFORNIA
COMMUNITY COLLEGES I WHERE THE
OFFICIAL VOICE BOB TWO POINT
ONE MILLION CUNY COLLEGE
STUDENTS IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA I LIKE TO ALIGN MY
COMMENTS THE PREVIOUS STUDENTS
THAT HAVE SPOKEN. AND I
REFERRED OR SUBMIT A LETTER FOR
OTHER COMMENTS BUT BASIC
ELECTED TO ADDRESS TO QUESTIONS
POSED TO THE COMMITTEE IN THE
POSTAGE AND ONE OF THE LONG
TERM STRATEGY TO ADDRESS LONG
LONG TERM BASIC NEEDS AND WHAT
STRATEGIES CAN THE STATE USED
TO LEVERAGE EXISTING PUBLIC
AID. WELL WE APPRECIATE THE
APPEAL OF A BLOCK GRANT TO
ADDRESS STUDENT NEEDS WHAT
HAPPENED WHEN THE STATE IS THAT
IT BROUGHT TO A BLOCK GRANT
LAST. YEAR NOT BY A- IN TWENTY
PER. IN SOME OF THE CALLS. BUT
IT WAS. A TICKET. APPROACH
ADDRESSING STUDENT. I WOULD OFF.
A RISK. CHAIR THE SALUTE IS A
IN AB SEVEN SEVEN. LARGEST
WOULD ESTABLISH BASIC NEEDS
COORDINATORS DESIGNED TO
SUPPORT STUDENT NEEDS AND
CONNECT THEM TO THAT PUBLIC
AID. WHICH WOULD CREATE
DIVIDENDS- FAR BEYOND
INVESTMENT AT THE STATE MAKES
IN FUNDING NEEDS COORDINATORS.
PROVIDING RESOURCES TARGETED
RESOURCES TO STUDENTS. I DON'T
THINK A BLOCK GRANT IS NOT THE
SOLUTION. AND VOTE ON IN YOUR
LICCARDO MINUTOS. BID OVER A
MINUTE THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY
MUCH FOR YOUR COMMENTS
MODERATE. COLOR. MAX CAROLINE
NINETY. PLEASE AHEAD. THANK YOU
GOOD MORNING WITH A ON BEHALF
THANK YOU FOR UP. WE ARE
GRATEFUL TO THE GOVERNOR'S BODY
PROPOSAL CRITICAL IN BACK IN
EMERGENCY AID GRANTS FOR
COMMUNITY STUDENTS WE URGE THE
LEGISLATURE TO SUPPORT THESE
INVESTMENT AND EMERGENCY
FINANCIAL ASSISTANCE TO
STUDENTS AND TO STRENGTHEN
THEIR IMPACT BY ENSURING THAT
THEY ARE DISTRIBUTED THROUGH AN
EQUITY BASED FRAMEWORK. WE'RE
ALSO APPRECIATIVE OF THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL TO
IMPACTING CULTURALLY COMPETENT
PROFESSIONAL DEVELOPMENT WHICH
IS INVESTMENT PROVIDE MUCH
NEEDED STRIDES TOWARD
IMPLEMENTING ANTI RACIST
EDUCATIONAL ENVIRONMENTS AGAIN
WE URGE THE LEGISLATURE TO
SUPPORT INVESTMENT AND TO
STRENGTHEN ITS IMPACT BY
INCORPORATING REPORTING
REQUIREMENTS FOR PROGRESS MADE
AND WHAT PRACTICE AT THE BEEN
IMPLEMENTED THANK YOU. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH A. MODERATOR IN
MEXICO. MAXIM TILL I AT ONE
HUNDRED PLEASED AHEAD. HELLO
CAN YOU HEAR ME YES WE CAN JUST
FINE AT. I THANK YOU VERY MUCH
EARLIER THAN THAT MEMBERS MINE
IS- KENNETH ASHER STUDENT AT
THE END. I WANT TO THAT SAME
SUPPORT THAT MY- COST MATES-
EXPRESSED. I IN SUPPORTING A
FULLY FUNDED- CALL SYSTEM HERE
IN CALIFORNIA AND- DEPRECIATION
EARLY ACTION EMERGENCY GRANTS
STRATEGIES BASICALLY MADE. YOUR
COSTS BOOKS TECHNOLOGY HEALTH
AND REQUIRED TO COMPLETION OF
DUST AND ALLOCATING THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET ALL THESE ARE
CRITICAL PRIORITIES BUT YOU
COMMUNITY COLLEGE THAT A
STUDENT. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR YOUR
COMMENTS MODERATOR NEXT CALL.
MAXIMO TO LINE ONE HUNDRED AND
ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD. FOUR
MONTHS HELLO MY NAME FOR A
MINUTE. FIVE THAT. AND COULD IN
A BUDGET THE ENTRANCE IN BASIC
NAME. ALL ON ONE FRONT FUNDING
ONE THEY WANT ONE. I BELIEVE
WORKING FOR YOU HOW FUNDING TO
HELP WITH THE BIG BECAUSE ONE
I'M A PARENT. AND IT WAS SO
HARD TO CALL WILL BE ABLE TO
ACCESS- DIAPERS WIPES OFF I
BOOK AND OTHERS. THAT I NEEDED
A IN ORDER TO MEET GET. WHEN I
NEEDED IT HAD TO TAKE THE BUS
YEAH. QUICKER THANK YOU SO MUCH
FOR GIVING ME THE TIME TO SPEAK
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR YOUR
COMMENTS MODERATOR NEXT CALLER.
OKAY AND OUR LAST COMMENT WILL
COME FROM WIND A ONE OH TWO
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO AND GOOD
MORNING MY NAME IS KENNY ROGERS
AND I'M CALLING FROM THE CENTER
AS A JUNIOR COLLEGE I WORK IN
THE LPS PROGRAM AS A FOSTER USE
SUPPORT SPECIALIST. I WOULD
LIKE TO ECHO THE SENTIMENTS OF
THE BASIC NEEDS STUDENTS BASIC
NEEDS ARE AN ONGOING NEED AND
NOT A ONE TIME NEED THANK YOU
FOR YOUR CONSIDERATION. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH MODERATE OR DOES
THAT EXHAUSTED Q. THAT THAT'S
COMPLETE ARE KEOGH. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH WE REALLY APPRECIATE.
YOUR COOPERATION BECAUSE BY MY
COUNT TWEET I HAD FORTY SEVEN
PEOPLE FOR WHICH THE- OFFER FOR
A COUPLE OF THEM SO. THAT WAS
GREAT WORK AND WE APPRECIATE
YOUR DILIGENCE- THAT MOVES TO
THE END OF OUR HEARINGS ARE
THERE ANY COMMENTS FROM OTHER
MEMBERS. THEN LET ME JUST THANK
EVERYBODY WHO PARTICIPATED IN
THE PUBLIC TESTIMONY TODAY IF
YOU'RE NOT ABLE TO TESTIFY. OR
YOU COULD NOT COMPLETE YOUR
COMMENTS PLEASE SUBMIT YOUR
COMMENTS AND SUGGESTIONS IN
WRITING TO THE SUBCOMMITTEE ONE
WE VALUE THEM. AND ARE THERE IN
THE OFFICIAL RECORDS THANKS FOR
EVERYBODY'S PATIENCE AND
COOPERATION THAT CONCLUDES THE
AGENDA AND THE SENATE BUDGET
AND FISCAL REVIEWS SUB
COMMITTEE ONE STANDS A JERK.